Intro/Outro
So ist ja der September. Du hast nicht 70000 Dollar für deine Frisur abgesetzt. Wolfgang warum.
Nein ich komme ein bisschen günstiger weg obwohl ich einen sehr sehr guten Friseur habe.
Und ich bin ja auch jemand der sehr gern zum Friseur geht und auch sehr regelmäßig nämlich alle vier Wochen.
Alle vier Wochen ist jeden Tag gegangen. Er hat für seine Zeit wie wir jetzt aus der New York Times wissen 75 000 Dollar abgesetzt. Der Spiegel hat den Text daraus gemacht. In Deutschland werden es 60 000 Euro. Alle mal vergleichen können.
75 000 Dollar. Selbst der Spiegel hat extra ausgemacht informiert. In Deutschland werden 60000 Euro begleichen können.
So eine Frage gewinnt Trump die Wahl oder gibt es immer noch viele.
Eine Frage gewinnt Trump die Wahl oder nicht.
Es gibt Anhänger von Trump die das lesen und dann denken das könne ich ja auch mal machen.
Anhänger von Trump die das lesen und dann denken das könnte ich ja auch mal machen.
Meine Frisur bei der nächsten Steuererklärung als Betriebskosten Ausgabe deklarieren.
Meine Frisur bei der nächsten Steuererklärung als Betriebskosten Ausgaben Declan möglicherweise.
Ich kann das sehr schwer einschätzen wie solche Skandale.
Ein weiterer ist es ja jetzt dazu beitragen dass das auch in der Bevölkerung tatsächlich ein heiß diskutiertes Thema ist.
Wenn ich das mal vergleiche was wir jetzt hatten mit Comex und ähnlichen Geschichten da gab es ja jetzt so eine Handvoll solcher Geschichten.
Dann merkt man Das ist mal ein journalistisches Thema und da gibt es dann auch mal längere Sachen zu lesen.
Aber das ist nicht das was die Talkshows dominiert und wenn ein Olaf Scholz dann im Gespräch ist dann wird er nochmal nachgefragt einmal vielleicht auch zweimal bei einem sehr kritischen Moderator und dann war es das.
Und wenn man draußen auf der Straße fragen würde Was sagen Sie dazu,
dann würden sie vielleicht sagen Ja die machen was sie wollen aber es wird keine Debatte die eine Politisierung erfährt insofern als es in irgendeiner Weise wahlentscheidend ist.
Man sieht das sehr schön wie Fabio de Masi ist ja jemand der auf Twitter sehr sehr pointiert Stellung nimmt das auch sehr gut erklären kann was da eigentlich passiert.
Aber der ist trotzdem in einer ganz ganz marginalisierten Position heraus aus der er das tut.
Das ist eigentlich etwas was viel mehr im Fokus der öffentlichkeit stehen muss aber was im Fernsehen dann zum Beispiel schon ganz wenig stattfindet.
Du wirst es im Fernseh Podcast verfolgen können dass das so ist und was dann auch sonst keine hohen Wellen schlägt.
Man hat das ja gerade jetzt gesehen dass wenn etwas zum Beispiel auch was Friedrich Merz äußert hohe Wellen schlägt dann ist das so etwas.
Wie seine Aussage Homosexualität wo die erste Assoziation,
Pädophilie kommt und er dann sagt Ach ich wusste gar nicht dass das mal irgendwie so ein Diskurs war so als hätte er in den 90er Jahren ja gar nicht gelebt und in den 80ern wurde das ja auch von seiner Partei betrieben wurde.
Das hat Skandal Potenzial. Während solche anderen ökonomischen Dinge steuerlichen Dinge oft nicht.
Ich kenne es sogar von regionaler Ebene also Politiker die Steuerhinterziehung gemacht haben 65 000 hinterzogen oder so.
Und trotzdem in der Bevölkerung kein schlechtes Ansehen hatten.
Also cem özdemir ist mal zurückgetreten wegen verwendeter Flugmeilen die er beruflich erworben hat. Privat nutzte,
es wurden noch vor nicht allzu langer Zeit Bundespräsidenten aus dem Amt geschrieben wegen absurder Kinkerlitzchen wie wir jetzt wissen.
Und auch Philipp haben wir noch nicht wiedergesehen seitdem die Wirkmächtigkeit von solchen Skandalen sind schon groß bei dieser Sache jetzt. Ich meine die kam jetzt gestern Abend.
Man müsse es jetzt heute morgen gelesen haben um das hier zu diskutieren.
Auf der anderen Seite Ich saß da draußen auf der Bank und hab diesen Text der New York Times gestern gelesen und gedacht es lohnt sich eigentlich nicht es überhaupt zu thematisieren wenn wir jetzt die Woche noch einen Salon aufnehmen.
Es ist nicht der Mühe wert irgendwie nochmal sich das anzuschauen.
Aber eine große Frage stellt sich ja doch in die Richtung wie du es eben auch problematisiert hast kann es noch die Wahl bewegen.
Denn wir wissen ja in zwei Tagen ist die erste Debatte von dreien und schon kurz darauf ist dann der Wahltag und es wird jetzt schon gewählt und wir haben ja hier schon dokumentiert wie Trump beispielsweise die religiösen Konservativen,
nicht mehrheitlich aber einen großen Anteil verloren hat weil beispielsweise,
eine große Welle im Senat losgeschlagen hat mit der Aufkündigung dieses.
Schützt unseren religiösen Lebensstil und dafür verzichten wir darauf.
Die ökonomischen Vorteile eines modernen Landes zu genießen sondern hier vor euch.
Und Trump hat ja noch eine Gruppe bei der immer eine Mehrheit bisher verzeichnet hat im Vergleich zu beiden und das sind die die sagen Trump kann das mit der Wirtschaft besser so die große Botschaft.
Deswegen muss man gar nicht die Texte lesen sondern da reichen jetzt die überschriften die müssen sich verfestigen.
Die große Botschaft ist Trump ist pleite.
Trump hat so viele Sachen als Verlust deklariert seine Frisur beispielsweise erst jetzt zur Lachnummer.
Aber da kam so viel zusammen und er hat alle möglichen null Prozent Zinsen da kann man doch noch einen Kredit aufnehmen und so weiter.
Das hat sich so aufsummiert dass er unterm Strich pleite ist.
Hat in zehn von elf von 18 Jahren zurückliegen gar keine Einkommenssteuer gezahlt.
Dann mal 750 Dollar pro Jahr und Trump ist jetzt pleite dieses ganze Gebäude von 100 Milliarden.
Ich bin hier als Milliardär und ich kenne mich aus.
Das Einzige mit dem er jemals wirklich plus gemacht hat ist seine Fernsehsendung.
Und jetzt hat natürlich schon dieser Zucker Zucker Zucker wieder ausgesprochen habe ich jetzt CNN Manager oder so der damals bei NBC oder wo auch immer das lief hofiert hat ob er nicht eine Mitschuld hat.
Es wird jetzt auf so einer historischen Ebene aufgedröselt.
Aber dieser große Block den Trump danach hatte in den Umfragen nämlich Ich kann das mit der Wirtschaft besser.
Was natürlich nur darauf beruht dass er eine Milliarde Steuergeschenke gemacht haben und die Sieger dann doch mal durch so viel Yücel dauerndes zugestanden dass ihm das jetzt in den letzten Monaten abhanden kommt.
Bei beiden könnte sich jetzt noch eine Woche Zeit nehmen sagen Trump Claire Dudas. Mit den Fragen der Journalisten.
Und dann steht er irgendwie da mit Warren Buffet im präsentiert so ein Plan für Amerika.
Also nicht Recovery sondern Ré Bild oder sowas. So richtig groß angelegt.
Und ich frage mich dann wirklich für alle die jetzt immer noch Angst haben dass Trump gewinnt wie krass wäre es eigentlich wenn Trump wirklich gewinnt.
Er hat trotz allen diesen Vorfällen die wir jetzt gesehen haben.
Also kann man sich eigentlich vorstellen dass das noch möglich ist das es noch gewinnen kann. Viele glauben.
Ich halte es für ausgeschlossen und damit ist alles gesagt jetzt im September. Das muss jetzt einfach abwarten bis der Wahltag ist.
Ich denke auch wir sehen da fast keine Bewegung bisher gewesen.
Wir sehen da fast keine Bewegung bisher gewesen in den Umfragen.
In den Umfragen ist dieser kleine Vorsprung den beiden beiden müsste jetzt die Zustimmung verlieren damit überhaupt noch eine Chance hat. Das ist ja auch überlegen.
Das ist einfach dieser kleine Vorsprung den beiden hat beiden müsste jetzt Zustimmung verlieren damit Trump überhaupt noch eine Chance hat.
Das muss man sich mal überlegen wodurch sollte beide jetzt verlieren.
Beide verlieren wenn dann nur wenn sie denn weiter unten im Keller und dann erst im November rauslassen dann abtauchen.
Da muss ja nichts machen. Einfach ein bisschen abtauchen und nicht auf Podien auftreten. Die Debatten sind natürlich klar.
Die Debatten sind natürlich klar.
Aber diese Debatten werden der große Moment wo dann wirklich eine vermeiden. feststellt Es reicht gerade nicht für mich.
Diese Debatten werden der große Moment vorbei. Es reicht nicht für mich.
Ich kann es nicht weiter Monolog machen sondern ich muss jetzt in so einen Kampf einsteigen. Wir kennen aus den Podcasts von David Axelrod und wie schwer es ist ein regierenden Präsidenten in eine Debatten Vorbereitung zu bekommen.
Ich kann es nicht weiter Monolog machen sondern ich muss jetzt in das Camp einsteigen.
Wir kennen aus den Wodkas von der Art wie schwer es ist ein regierenden Präsidenten in eine Debatten Vorbereitung zu bekommen.
Bei Trump ist es völlig unmöglich. Es gibt keine Erzählung davon dass er sich überhaupt vorbereitet. Das heißt dieser Debatten wird dann auch ein großer Moment der Wahrheit irgendwie für ihn.
Das ist völlig unmöglich. Es gibt keine Erzählung davon dass sie überhaupt vorbereitet. Das heißt diese Debatten Armenvierteln Rosa.
Wenn er nicht als Entertainer brillieren kann in irgendeiner Weise für ein Publikum das sicherlich nicht an einem rationalen Diskurs interessiert ist für ein Publikum das nicht,
am Vormittag die New York Times gelesen hat aber ich habe mir ja nochmal einige ältere Shows angesehen weil ich ja ein bisschen mit Joan Rivers beschäftigt hatte dieser Comedian die ja auch der aufgetauchtes und das war erstaunlich gut.
Innerhalb dieses Formats wie er das da gemacht hat und das war mir sehr sehr klar warum das funktionieren kann.
Vor dem Publikum. Insofern ist seine einzige Chance in so einer Debatte dort einen aufschaut zu machen also zu steppen zu singen zu tanzen quasi ja alles zu machen was der Entertainer tut.
Aber.
Denn rationale Argumente können ja von ihm keine sinnvollen mehr kommen.
Er kann sich ja höchstens noch selbst widerlegen.
Die Debatte ist auch davon geprägt dass sie unterbrochen wird durch Fragen. Das heißt jeder Showeffekt auch wenn er gelingt.
Er hat eine Bewährungsprobe von 90 Sekunden.
Danach muss ihm etwas Neues einfallen und so viel überraschung steckt in ihnen nicht mehr drin.
Wir kennen jetzt seit vier Jahren. Es ist auch ein bisschen old man ist gelangweilt von Trump wenn man ihn sieht das war 2016 noch anders. Naja.
Ja Ja Ja klar.
Aber wir bleiben in der Showbranche und wir bleiben in Amerika auch wenn wir heute sonst nicht USA lastig sind.
Es gibt würde ich doch fast behaupten ein neues Filmgenre ein Do&Co Genre das wir bei YouTube besichtigen können.
Ich nenne es den Therapy Film und zwar hat YouTube und das ist jetzt quasi nachgeholt jetzt schon Anfang Januar eine Doku-Serie veröffentlicht mit,
und über Justin Bieber und die jetzt gerade in diesem Monat September erschienen ist eine große Dokumentation über Paris Hilton.
Ich habe beides mir sehr genau angesehen und wir haben es,
bei Paris Hilton mit einer Protagonistin der Nullerjahre vor allem zu tun die diese Jahre geprägt hat mit Justin Bieber haben wir jemanden der die zehner Jahre geprägt hat 2010 im Januar kam Baby.
Das kam raus damals und seitdem ist viel passiert und das wird aufgearbeitet.
Ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt erstmal zu Justin Bieber über denn das ist hochinteressant was wir hier erleben können.
Ich glaube dass wir hier sehr viel über unsere Gesellschaft erfahren und gar nicht so viel über diese einzelnen Leute die mich jetzt an sich nicht so interessieren.
Wir müssen sie als Phänomen begreifen und wir müssen auch als Phänomen begreifen wie diese Dokumentationen aufgebaut sind und da hören wir uns jetzt den ganz kurzen Part aus Justin Bieber an.
Serie.
Hellebarde.
So leitet er also die Dokumentation ein. Er will etwas von sich erzählen und sagt Kann ich es noch einmal machen und dann sagen sie aus dem Off Ja kannst du aber sie lassen exakt um das Ganze zu authentifizieren.
Das ist die Strategie dann auch immer wieder kommt man zeigt Justin Bieber wie er in einem Raum Platz nimmt der eher wie ein Container wirkt den man irgendwo hingestellt hat er kommt da rein in seinem,
Outfit das ist ja immer so ein bisschen wenn man Justin Bieber sieht denkt man habe ich ein Portmonee dabei kann ich ein bisschen was geben vielleicht und das ist dann sehr interessant dass,
Justin Bieber versucht diese letzten Jahre Revue passieren zu lassen und erst einmal rollt man das auf wie beschäftigt dieser junge Star Tournee.
Ganz wichtig das Prinzip Arbeit Arbeit Arbeit Arbeit Arbeit das Leben jeder arbeitet.
Ja ja.
Genau. Und dann denkt man Na gut er ist ja auch jung und er ist 18. 19 20.
Da kann man ja noch ein bisschen arbeiten dann werden immer die Orte eingeblendet wo er überall Konzerte gegeben hat.
Und ich dachte mir na gut das mache ich Sharjah in zwei Monaten dreimal bekommt das noch hin.
Aber man sagt dann eben der Justin Bieber dem ging es so schlecht dann durch diesen ganzen Stress.
Das war alles so negativ dass er dann anfing Drogen zu nehmen das Medikamenten abhängig wurde dass er unter Schlaflosigkeit litt und das Interessante ist dass hier,
wirklich so ein Krankheitsverlauf plötzlich als Dokumentation,
sich breit macht und dann wird auch erklärt man zeigt ihnen immer wieder wie er im Studio arbeitet dass er ganz kreative Künstler ist der auch schlechte Tage hat und dazu sagt auch Justin Bieber Was.
BND.
Kommt ins Studio. Und dann hat er einen schlechten Tag und dann ist aber auch das Management und die Leute die mit ihm zusammenarbeiten so verständnisvoll und sagt.
Permanent in dieser Doku als etwas vollkommen Normales angesehen das man,
gänzlich undiszipliniert ist und jetzt muss man aber eine Rechtfertigung dafür finden denn das weiß ja jeder Mensch der irgendwie arbeiten muss dass er nicht einfach sagen kann Oh,
ich komme morgen nochmal wieder.
Das ist einfach eine Frage des Budgets. Wenn du genug Budget hast dann kannst du halt morgens in den Status verfallen heute nicht morgen wieder.
Ja
Genau. Ja.
Und dann brauchst aber auch eine Ausrede. Also muss es einen verkaufen und dann steht vor dem Team und ich stimme übrig.
Ja
Leider ist in dem Moment von dir verlangt dass du leidest damit alle die Geschichte erzählen. Er leidet heute kommt Wir leiden mit ihm.
Ja puzzeln nennt man das. Die Stimme puzzeln nennt man das.
Das haben wir hier eine Wespe drin.
Was macht die hier,
fliegt bestimmt gleich von alleine wieder raus. Solche rausbringt.
Meinst du nicht dass wir einen Wespen Angriff heute noch erleben.
Intro/Outro
Die Vespers.
Die Wespe ist besiegt und wir fragen uns ja was hat denn Justin Bieber eigentlich.
Und dann gibt es eben Stresssymptome und er ist dann jemand der auch nicht ganz leicht in der Kindheit hatte wird dann selbstverständlich sofort geholt als Argument und er hat dann einen Arzt Dr.
Armin heißt er und der stellt dann mal eine Diagnose.
Wie.
Ja man muss sich das Schicksal ein bisschen auch aussuchen. Du bist ja ein großer Fan von Psychoanalyse und Bocks bestimmt gleich an die Zählung an der erklärt wird Die Mutter hat es schwer und deswegen hat sich das übertragen an den Sohn.
Überhauptnicht überhaupt nicht bin ich denn das ist eigentlich nicht Psychoanalyse dass es diese Art der Psychoanalyse wie sie in den USA gerne betrieben wird nämlich um Menschen zurück auf den American Way of Life zu pressen.
Ein bisschen vulgär.
Und deswegen ist das ganz beliebt und ich hab dann nachgeschaut was macht dann eigentlich dieser Doktor der da vorgestellt wird.
Lassen.
Die haben ja das letzte Mal Lisa Eckhart gehört und Lisa Eckhart sitzt ja genau so bestimmt über ihre Geschichte zu deuten in den Interviews und sagt dann einfach Nee also mit 110 muss man sich emanzipiert haben vor seinem Elternhaus.
Ja genau über ihre Geschichte,
mit 110 muss man sich emanzipieren.
Wenn es noch so Shetty war dann steht man auf eigenen Füßen.
Ja genau das ist genauso Programm.
Das fordert sie von sich und damit auch allen im Publikum. Es ist genau das Gegenmodell ist genauso Programm wie die Kamera.
Aber es wird da sogar deutlicher wie man sich aussuchen kann welche Erzählung Welchen roten also welches Drehbuch man verfolgt wenn man eine Doku über sein eigenes Leben.
Aussuchen kann man.
Dieses Drehbuch ist sehr eng verknüpft mit den ärzten mit denen Justin Bieber da zusammenarbeitet wenngleich ich schon fast das Wort Arzt nicht in den Mund nehmen will denn die Dr.
Amon ist so ein Doktor für die Superreichen ist ständig irgendwo im Fernsehen zu sehen und bietet eine Therapie an..
Die Therapie heißt das. Und da gab es einen beiße Artikel mal dazu zu einer solchen Gehirn Neustart Infusion.
Da heißt es Der Hauptbestandteil des intravenösen Cocktails ist ein unaussprechlich Nukleotide.
Dann gibt es dieses Enzym wurde 1906 entdeckt und lässt sich in allen lebenden Zellen finden.
Das Internet sagt mir dass die Anti-Aging Community unglaublich beliebt ist und man bekommt dann immer solche Infusionen.
Und dann gibt es nochmal überDruck kann man,
so Sauerstoffzelt denn das sieht man auch er hat also überall zu Hause im Studio überall ein,
Zelt und da legt er sich dann rein und dann wird er gefilmt dann kommt er immer ganz frisch wieder raus spaziert und wir uns auch ganz kurz einen Clip an.
Biesdorf.
Sex-Szenen.
Wellenbad.
Das war Hayley seine Ehefrau Man hat jetzt die Antwort auf alle Probleme gefunden ebenso eine merkwürdige Therapie die ganz ganz viel Geld kostet.
Und diese ärzte haben dann auch neue Homepages kreiert.
Ich hab das mal so ein bisschen nachgeforscht was das für die jetzt die ideale Plattform ist mit dieser Dokumentation nochmal ganz neue Kunden zu akquirieren.
Dann gibt es auch noch einen weiteren Arzt Dr. Bass Mindel und.
Dr. Amon Dr. Bass.
Dr. Dr. Bass genannt.
Und er hat das mit dem Zelt entdeckt und er macht er ist Brain Healthy Doctor und überwacht dann immer dass er positive Gedanken habe dann wird ihm.
Und er machen. Er ist dran und überwacht dann immer das Positive Gedanken hat dann wird auch erklärt er.
Auch erklärt wenn er eine schwierige Situation gerade hat er wird z.B.
Schwierige Situation geraten gezeigt werden Musikvideos dann soll er sich immer den Kopf massieren und dann erfrischt er damit auch wieder denken und alles.
Bei einem Dreh gezeigt für ein Musikvideo dann soll er sich immer so ein bisschen den Kopf massieren und dann erfrischt er damit auch wieder sein Denken und alles und kann dann ganz neu in die Arbeit starten.
Ich hab gestern eine Metallica Doku-Reihe geguckt. Es gibt ja eine andere. Ich habe nicht gestern aber es gibt eine.
Da so eine Szenerie wie sie zusammensitzen als Band und den neuen Bassisten aufnehmen und so weiter und feststellen.
Wir brauchen Psychologen und Psychologen. Und der begleitet sie dann weil die paar tausend Euro Monat die das kostet ja auch bei so Budget und Psychologen.
Und dann sitzen sie irgendwann zusammen und sagen Ja wir machen jetzt ja so und so und so. Und dann sagt der Psychologe zu denen ja kein Problem ich hab mir schon gesagt dass wir umziehen hier zu euch.
Und in dem Moment hat James Hetfield gesagt Also hat man so kurz gemerkt wie dieses aussehen auseinander klaffen auseinander Aufeinandertreffen von diesen Lebenswelten.
Die geben halt mal so nebenbei 10000 Dollar aus und sagen Psychologen Wir brauchen und der andere baut sein ganzes Leben darum für Metallica da zu sein.
In dem Moment kündigen sie ihm sagen Sie uns das ist ein bisschen übertrieben.
Du gehst hier zu weit aus. Das scheint dann für James Hetfield auch eine ganz befreiende Moment gewesen zu sein sich von diesem Psychologen der ihnen ohne dass es gemerkt hat die ganze Zeit so bis hin zu Ich baue mein Leben für dich um so sich dann einfach von ihm zu entsagen.
Und das hat wahrscheinlich mehr folgen und Erweckung gebracht als alle psychologischen Therapien die mit.
Das Entscheidende bei der Psychoanalyse dass man sich irgendwann von dem Analytiker frei macht und dass es hier überhaupt nicht der Fall sondern,
jetzt einige Ersatzvater die alle dadurch authentifiziert sind dass sie einen Doktortitel tragen wo immer sie diesen auch haben mögen und was denn die eigentliche Ausbildung ist und Hayley seine Frau macht das vollkommen mit.
Und jetzt kommt dann noch hinzu dass Justin Bieber sich kreativ anfängt auszuleben in der Form dass er eine Modemarke auch dann herausgebracht hat.
So ist sein zweiter Name. Und dann sieht man sich diese Mode an.
Und was soll ich sagen das sind halt überdimensionale Säcke statt Pullover würde ich dann irgendwelche Baggy Jeans Schlappen. Was auch immer.
Und das Einzige was diese nichtssagende Mode die man wahrscheinlich auch exakt so bei Kik bestellen könnte ausmacht ist dass es einen Smiley drauf gibt einen gelben.
Und er hat auch noch als Mund drauf da stehen und dass es diese große Mode Idee von Justin Bieber,
mit der er sich einfach auch mal kreativ austoben kann das wird alles in dieser Dokumentation hingestellt als hätte er jetzt weiß Gott was auch noch die Mode für sich entdeckt und fängt an zu designen.
Vor allem kreativ ausbreiten das kann man nicht wie Tim Curry so für sich machen einfach wechseln in die bildende Kunst.
Nee das muss natürlich ein Produkt sein das hier verkauft weil darin,
die eigene Erwartung die man daran knüpft seine.
Na ja jetzt kommt etwas was wir auch wiederfinden werden bei Paris Hilton.
Denn Justin Bieber möchte ja auch seinen Fans mit dieser Dokumentation etwas mitteilen.
Der Multimillionär spricht hier zu den anderen Leuten die morgens schlecht aus dem Bett kommen und denen will er mitteilen Jonathan Stallone.
Aber ich meine wenn wir jetzt so ein Superstar hast den wir zu vermarkten.
Keine Ahnung was auch schon gemacht hat sich verkauft. Dann willst du so einen Film machen. Ich hab jetzt nur noch selten diesen Text von Nils Minkmar dazu gelesen. Also ich war auf irgendeiner Schule. Was wusste man vorher nicht.
Justin Bieber hat man jetzt einen Film gemacht ohne das Mindestmaß an irgendeiner Möglichkeit noch eine Story zu entfalten. Und dann kommt so etwas,
noch nochmal dokumentiert worden in der eigenen Aussprache in einem eigenen Beitrag dass es ihm schwerfällt morgens aufzustehen.
Ich kann ihm nachfühlen Wir waren alle mal in der Schule da hat der Wecker halb sieben geklingelt und es ist auch wirklich schlimm nur weil man kein Sauerstoffzelt hat steht man wenn man Sauerstoffzelt macht mal ein Drama bis zur Mittagspause.
Und mit 25 das ist ja das Erstaunliche eigentlich dass man hier jemanden erlebt der nicht erwachsen geworden ist der sich auch einfach nicht am Zippel reißen kann.
Manchmal sind ja so alte Erziehungsmethoden wie ich sie von meiner ostpreußischen Großmutter noch hin und wieder erfahren habe.
Sätze wie Stell dich nicht so an man zusammen. Das will ich jetzt nicht hören hin und wieder auch ganz hilfreich genau hin und wieder ganz hilfreich dass man dann eben genau.
Du bist das Kind nicht ich,
komme im Salon auf Lagerfeld. Lagerfeld hat die beste Erziehung überhaupt genossen. Er wurde einfach nie als Kind akzeptiert.
Großartig. Die Mutter will schon mal ein Detail will ich schon mal verraten als der Vater von Lagerfelds starb hat seine Mutter dann der Verwandtschaft von ihrem Ehemann gesagt So,
jetzt sind wir wieder per se mit der Verwandtschaft.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt auf Lagerfeld. Ich werde mir auch einen Anzug anziehen es wird ein Beweisfoto geben im Salon.
Sehr schön sehr schön. Da wird sich auch Alfons Kaiser von der F.A.Z. wahrscheinlich freuen.
Ja das ist die Dramaturgie Wir schauen mal in den Kopf von Justin Bieber ein Wir lassen mal die ärzte sprechen.
Was ist da jetzt falsch welche Blutbahnen müssen umgeleitet werden damit wir ihn wieder auf Vordermann bekommen.
Bei Paris Hilton gibt es eine ähnliche Dramaturgie insofern als auch sie unter Burn out leidet sagt dass sie depressiv ist dass sie Schlafstörungen hat all das,
was wir bei Justin Bieber finden aber sie ist wesentlich agiler.
Sie ist eine die sich Monate Jahre lang hängen lässt sondern sie macht unglaublich viel.
Allein schon um ihre Produktlinien zu vermarkten.
Und da hören wir auch erst mal was denn hier das Thema ist nämlich Wir finden die Authentizität wieder.
Bauunternehmern.
Also Wir sollen jetzt hier erfahren wer sie wirklich ist.
Wir haben immer eine falsche Perrys selten gesehen und es gab da etwas in ihrer Kindheit auf einer Schule das immer noch für Albträume bei ihr sorgt.
Aber es holt einen wenigstens ab bei der Frage Hat man sich immer gestellt.
So wie Paris Hilton ist kann man ja eigentlich gar nicht sein. Also irgendwas muss ja dahinterstecken. Man wird es ein bisschen angehen.
Nein genau ja das.
Paris Hilton. Diese Dokumentation hat mich getriggert durch einen Text der bei Spiegel Online erschienen ist und zwar von Nils Minkmar und ich habe zunächst diesen Text gelesen bevor ich die Doku gesehen habe.
Diese Dokumentation hat mich durch einen bei Spiegel Online entschieden.
Ich habe zunächst diesen Text gelesen bevor ich die dieser Text erzählt dann den Film erst einmal nach was wir da getan und dann stehen da so Sätze wie Sie eben beschrieben wurde.
Dieser Text erzählt dann den Film erst einmal nach was wird da getan und dann stehen da so Sätze wie dass Sie eben beschrieben wurde,
nicht so ist wie sie sich präsentiert hat in irgendwelchen Reality Formaten.
Nicht so ist wie sie sich präsentiert hat in irgendwelchen Reality.
Da steht dann so ganz bedeutsam. Die Wahrheit ist eine andere.
Und ich denke mir Ja denn es ist Showbusiness. Ich kann nur davon ausgehen dass die Wahrheit eine andere ist.
Bei.
Show-Business stets fest aber jedes Mal wenn Menschen im Fernsehen sind kriegen sie Dalla von ihrem Umfeld.
Du sagst aber ich habe es aber hübsch gemacht im Fernsehen Niemand ist vor der Kamera so wie er nicht einmal augenscheinlicher.
Aber das Tolle ist jetzt dass Nils Minkmar im Prinzip genau den Fehler wiederholt den jetzt Leute in einem naiven aufblicken gemacht haben wenn sie sagten Ach so Die ist so blöde oder so naiv,
und sonst kann die gar nichts anderes sagen.
Während er jetzt die Dokumentation nicht als auch etwas Fiktionales begreift sondern dass es das Abbild der Realität.
Und dann sind dann ebenso Sachen dort zu lesen in dem Text das ja nicht leicht hatte denn die Eltern die haben ja nicht vom kleinen so viel geerbt sondern die mussten arbeiten gehen.
Da denke ich mir ja wie fast alle Menschen.
Und dann wurde sie sehr sehr perfektionistisch erzogen.
Aber es ist eben nicht alles perfekt.
Nils Minkmar schreibt das war es nicht. Denn wo ist das schon auf Erden wo ist es das schon auf Erden.
Und das Fazit dann beim Ansehen dieser Loco lautet dass hier die Kohle nicht gegen Albträume helfen kann ist die Wahrheit die der Film herausarbeitet.
Und das Fazit dann beim Ansehen dieser Doku lautet dass ihr die Kohle nicht gegen Albträume helfen kann ist die Wahrheit die der Film herausarbeitet und sie wirkt weit über die einzelne Geschichte hinaus.
Und sie wirkt weit über die einzelne Geschichte hinaus. Gegen Ende spaziert Paris Hilton.
Gegen Ende spaziert Paris Hilton durch einen ihrer immensen begehbaren Kleiderschränke gelassener als zu Beginn der Dreharbeiten in gemütlichen Klamotten und erklärt das ganze Zeug hier habe sie eh nie beachtet kaum getragen.
Durch einen ihrer immensen begehbaren Kleiderschränke gelassener als zu Beginn der Dreharbeiten in gemütlichen Klamotten und erklärt das ganze Zeug hier habe sie nie beachtet kaum getragen. Eigentlich wichtig.
Es sei nicht wichtig dass es ja eine bloße Attitüde die sie in und wieder einnimmt sie lebt ja genau davon diese Produkte zu bewerben sie zu tragen und sie trägt sie auch immer ob sie zu Hause in der Jogginghose rumläuft das kann ja gut sein.
Aber dann ist man wieder bei diesem merkwürdigen authentischen ich das überhaupt nicht relevant ist.
Und jetzt sollen wir aber auch selbst wie das Justin Bieber auch will.
Wir sollen ja eine Moral mitnehmen aus dieser Dokumentation und Nils Minkmar schreibt dass ihr das alles nicht so wichtig ist.
Das ist keine banale sondern eine brisante politische Botschaft.
Denn der Kapitalismus lebt von dem Versprechen mit Geld auch äußere Sicherheit und inneren Frieden kaufen zu können.
Man könnte viele Ressourcen schonen wenn diese Güter auf anderem Wege durch eine humanere Gesellschaft und umfassendere Bildung hervorgebracht werden könnten.
Insofern ist der Film nicht voyeuristisch und auch kein Jammern auf hohem Niveau sondern wirft Fragen auf die auch jene beschäftigen sollten die sich für Paris Hilton nicht interessieren.
Ich habe diesen Text auch gelesen als er erschien an dem Morgen dort ist mir geschrieben ich guck diese Doku dann hab ich dir geantwortet Ja ich habe diesen Text gelesen hast du geschrieben.
Das hat mich getriggert weil im Minkmar hab ich so kennengelernt als ich bei der FAZ war und war Minkmar immer dieses Gespenst im Hintergrund.
Wir saßen alle hier in Frankfurt und in Berlin im Sonntagszeitungen Twitter gab es so einen Autor.
Der hat dann auch immer mal für die Wochenzeitung Texte geliefert wo immer klar war Seite 1 nochmal umbauen Minkmar hat angekündigt.
Na klar egal was dann kommt die Ankündigung reicht. 15 Uhr kommt ein Text der auf jeden Fall die Seite eins auf.
Und dann irgendwann kam der Moment des Minkmar in Frankfurt auftauchte natürlich sofort als neue Feuilletonchef und so Minkmar hat damals tatsächlich immer so geschrieben im Sinne von,
Wir dachten alle ihr hättet was verstanden Hier kommt nochmal der neue Dreh zum Abend und es war eigentlich immer überraschend Man hat immer zu Recht eben diese Plätze freigeräumt. Deswegen habe ich das nicht verstanden.
Ich habe die Doku nicht gesehen hat mich jetzt nicht so Schickhardt weil du gesagt hast.
Aber der Text selber ist überhaupt nicht Minkmar. überhaupt nicht ganz das Gegenteil.
Als ob man vom F.A.Z. Torpfosten hinabsteigt in die Spoon morgens Text Schmider und dann nochmal drei Absätze zu schicken indem nochmal nacherzählt wird was im Fernsehen passierte.
Das ist wirklich ganz traurig. Diesen Text haben.
Man hätte auch einfach die Produktionsfirma fragen können ob sie in den Pressetext schicken und den eigenen Namen drüber.
Aber diese Moral die wir hier noch mitnehmen sollen das ist,
ganz verrückt und jetzt widmen wir uns dieser Dokumentation mal denn es lohnt sich wirklich Wir sehen also Paris Hilton unterwegs in der Welt wie sie ihre Produkte vorstellt 19 Produktlinien hat sie,
da sagt sie auch etwas was ihr die Fans zu bedeuten.
Wird auch so die Idee einer Community schrieben die ja total an den Haaren herbeigezogen ist völlig verlogen ist und sie sieht sich auch als die erste die eigentlich das Influencer Business betrieben hat.
Wir hatten aber im Salon ja über Instagram gesprochen.
Man muss sagen Eigentlich sind es die Kardashians die das Influencer Wesen hergestellt haben.
Ein paar Prinzipien gehypte sie damals ankündigte mit irgendeinem anderen Superstar ist er leider nicht erschienen nur sie war da aber da hat sie schon ein paar Sachen entwickelt und sich auch getraut bei denen man so denkt.
Bei ihr kommt das hinzu Dieses Berühmtsein fürs Berühmtsein das gab's ja dann auch in Deutschland mit Naddel Ariane Sommer Verona Feldbusch.
Da gab es einige aber das digitale hat sie dann noch rechtzeitig mitgemacht da waren aber dann doch die Kardashians eigentlich die Vorreiter.
Man sieht also dass man sich selbst produziert dass man selbst Selfies macht aber dennoch sieht sie sich so und sagt dann auch etwas denn sie muss ja heute als erwachsene Frau da sehr kritisch darauf blicken.
Kehlmanns.
Lady Gaga wäre hätte sie Little Monsters genannt.
Und das Schöne ist dass die Dokumentation immer wieder irgendwie versucht doch die verantwortungsbewußte Paris Hilton zu zeigen aber das bekommst du natürlich nur für so kurze Momente mal hin,
denn sonst lebt sie ja genau davon dass es genügend genügend Idioten gibt die diese Produkte,
die meist vollkommen unsinnig sind kaufen.
Also wie will man es sonst schaffen.
Es ist ja vollkommen verrückt wenn man von ihr jetzt erwartet dass sie verantwortungsbewusst damit umgeht dann müsste sie sagen Ja ich verkaufe meine Produkte nicht mehr. Ich lasse es jetzt sein.
Dann hat auch Paris Hilton wie Justin Bieber Probleme mit dem Schlafen. Sie sagt jetzt Folgendes dazu.
Stahr.
Stages.
Also meine initiale Einschätzung zu diesem Clip.
Das ist typischer Deutscher All inclusive Urlaub vermag das noch Produkte sondern du bist irgendwo da weiß gar nicht genau wo bin ich eigentlich in Spanien oder in der Türkei so ungefähr seit eine Hotelanlage.
Irgendwo muss man halt eine melden und man wird die ganze Zeit gefragt wie es dir Guten Morgen wie gehts.
Man sagt Die sei den Mitarbeitern ja gut ich mache doch hier gerade Urlaub Mir gehts voll gut und so man die ganze Zeit Autosuggestion Ich mache ja super geilen Urlaub. Ich weiß gar nicht wo ich bin.
So kommen wir das ja auch so ein bisschen Feuer. Sie ist halt. Sie macht halt sie reist herum und weiß nicht wo sie ist.
Und wer will es ihr verdenken dass sie da mit dem Schlaf schon mal durcheinander kommt. Ich würde es auch nicht aushalten.
Aber was hier die Dokumentation wieder versucht ist dass wir uns alle auch darin wiedererkennen.
Wir alle leiden ja mal unter Schlaflosigkeit oder haben mal einen schlechten Tag und das sollen wir jetzt irgendwie nachempfinden und wir sollen auch noch Mitleid mit ihr haben für das was sie da tut.
Niemand hat sie ja gezwungen das zu tun dieses Universum da aufzubauen.
Zeigt.
Wie du es so ein bisschen als den schifft sehen. Wir hatten ja in den 80ern und 90ern so Superstars die absolut richtig Spaß Michael Jackson Madonna und jetzt haben wir über diese YouTube Schiene.
Ja
Richtig.
Und jetzt haben wir YouTube.
Die Kamera muss wackeln der Ton muss schlecht sein authentisch weggefallen von der Straße.
Kann es noch mal machen. Nein wir lassen gerade das so im Schnitt.
Wenn du jung bist du willst aber noch 20 30 Jahre den weiter fahren musste diesen Shift halt auch mitmachen.
Halt auch mitmachen.
Und dann brauchst du solche Dokus von der einwählt in die authentischer rüber holen. Das scheint ja hier ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Als It-Girl würde sie es nämlich nicht mehr schaffen. Und es ist exakt das was du gerade schon angesprochen hast dass nämlich was Michel Foucault die Pastoral macht nennt.
Michel Foucault geht davon aus dass die Beichte nach wie vor in unserer modernen säkularisierten Zeit eine ganz wichtige Rolle spielt nur beichten wir nicht mehr in der Kirche sondern wir beichten unserem Therapeuten wir beichten dem Unternehmen,
wir beichten intime Sitzungen wir Beichten in irgendwelchen Workshops dann gibt's diese Exkursionen mit Firmen draußen im Wald erleben überall beichten wir wir beichten bei Twitter bei Instagram.
Wir können das erleben dass Leute dort permanent kundtun also die in der öffentlichkeit stehen die Rede jetzt nicht von Leuten die das privat nutzen und dort dann auch privat über ihre Bedürfnisse und Leiden berichten sondern Menschen die in der öffentlichkeit stehen die auch immer wieder.
Dort thematisieren dass sie Depressionen haben dass sie Schlafstörungen haben dass sie keinen Mann finden oder keine Frau finden all diese ganzen Sachen.
Die werden so ausgewalzt in einer Weise dass man erst einmal erschrocken ist darüber wenn man noch ein bisschen anders gestrickt ist dann aber verstehen muss.
Ja das ist eigentlich das neue Geschäftsfeld. Damit kann man den nächsten Buch Vertrag bekommen damit kannst du dann zur Not auch ein YouTube Original bekommen.
Denn das ist ja so toll dass Youtube sagt Wir machen ja wir produzieren jetzt auch nicht nur Netflix kann.Das oder Amazon Prime.
Aber wir machen etwas bei YouTube was ganz typisch ist für YouTube nämlich dass Menschen dort in die Kamera blicken und einfach so etwas aus ihrem Leben erzählen nur machen wir das eben mit Justin Bieber und Paris Hilton.
Wir hören uns mal einen Auszug aus einem Text zur Gowers Mentalität von Michel Foucault.
Dort erklärt er die Pastoral macht.
Die Pastoral macht ist eine Macht religiösen Ursprungs.
Es ist die die beansprucht die Menschen während ihres gesamten Lebens und in jeder Lebenssituation zu führen und zu leiten.
Eine Macht die die Existenz der Menschen in allen Details und in ihrer gesamten Entwicklung von der Geburt bis zum Tod in Beschlag nehmen will und zwar um sie zu einer bestimmten Weise des Verhaltens,
zu ihrem Seelenheil zu zwingen.
Während die Pastoral macht einerseits über die gesamte Gruppe ausgeübt wird ist ihre Hauptsorge und Hauptaufgabe andererseits die,
sich um das Heil aller so zu kümmern dass sie sich zugleich um jedes einzelne Schaf der Herde um jedes Individuum kümmert nicht nur um es zu zwingen in dieser oder jener Weise zu handeln,
sondern zugleich um es zu erkennen es zu entdecken um seine Subjektivität hervortreten zu lassen die Pastoral macht lässt sich nur ausüben,
wenn man weiß was in den Köpfen der Menschen vor sich geht wenn man ihre Seele erforscht wenn man sie zwingt ihre intimsten Geheimnisse preiszugeben.
Sie setzt voraus dass man das Bewusstsein des Einzelnen kennt und zu lenken vermag.
Da habe ich jetzt eine Assoziation. Vielleicht haben es einige mitbekommen. Kai Pflaume der ja zuletzt im Fernsehen weiß hat seit zehn Jahren oder so quasi ein Quiz moderieren ist ja auch ein YouTube-Star geworden.
Seit drei Wochen bei YouTube und jedes dieser Videos hat irgendwie dann doch eine Million Views und so richtig eingeschlagen. Und welches Genre hat er sich ausgesucht. Er fährt zu Youtubern hin und lässt die mal sage ich jetzt im Lichte dessen mal richtig beichten.
Eine halbe Stunde.
Montana blank oder wieder heiß. Erzähl mir doch jetzt mal abseits von deiner Kamera in meine Kamera wie du so in eine Kamera sprichst.
Das scheint mir genau dieses scheint genau das zu bedienen was hier in den Raum stellt als Möglichkeit der Abarbeitung.
Und wenn man gegen dieses neoliberale Regime denn nichts anderes ist es eigentlich ankämpfen will dann muss man sich verschließen.
Man muss wenig preisgeben Man muss nicht diese Introspektion zulassen die ja bei Justin Bieber bis in die Blutbahn bis ins Gehirn geht und bei Paris Hilton gehts dann in die Kindheit.
Wir können das ein bisschen ausklammern Es geht also darum dass sie in einer in einem Internat war das extrem streng war man wird über Nacht abgeholt wie von Räubern.
Die Eltern organisieren das und dann wird man dort zum Teil unter Medikamente gesetzt es gibt auch so etwas wie Einzelhaft Provo heißt diese,
merkwürdige Institution Schule und die waschen häufiger in der Kritik und die,
Narration in dieser Dokumentation ist nun dass sich Paris Hilton zum ersten Mal zu diesen Vorfällen äußert auch gegenüber ihrer Mutter.
Und dass sie dann ehemalige Mitschülerinnen trifft und mit denen so eine Hashtag Kampagne macht dass sie jetzt Mut fassen wollen gemeinsam und dass sie auch,
jungen Menschen Mut machen wollen dass sie über ihre.
Leiden die sie erfahren haben dort in solchen Internaten sprechen und damit will man irgendwie versuchen dieser Dokumentation etwas Sinnstiftendes zu geben.
Aber auch dem Leben von Paris Hilton etwas Sinnstiftendes zu geben das können wir ja jetzt aber einfach mal als eine ganz hübsche Narration weglassen nicht dass sich das Leid da minimieren will von nivellieren will.
Aber es ist wirklich so ganz nach diesem Schema gesucht Wir müssen jetzt mal gucken ob wir noch so eine positive Influencer Kampagne daraus gestalten können.
Können wir noch irgendwas machen das viral geht und dann setzt sie sich mit diesen Mädels von damals mal kurz zusammen und dann machen sie malen sie auf Plakate Hashtags und lassen sich damit fotografieren.
Und dann weißt du schon okay.
Wahrscheinlich werden sie nie wiedersehen.
Diese Schulsachen scheinen ja die Filmemacher sehr froh gewesen zu sein.
Aber wurde mir erklärt warum die Schule das macht dieses nachts abholen.
Nein.
Das scheint mir wirklich ein bisschen.
Es gibt da einige Artikel. Aber ich habe mich dann auch nicht mehr länger damit beschäftigen wollen.
Zu beschäftigen wollen was du gerade noch angesprochen dieser Therapie.
Was du gerade noch angesprochen hast mit dieser Therapie ist interessant es gibt ja noch einen anderen Star der neuen 20er Jahre schon Billy eilig die auch ihre Depressionen ganz groß zum Thema macht.
Zwanzigerjahre,
ihre Depressionen ganz groß zum Thema macht psychologischen Leitsysteme kommt am Ende auch noch mal hin und gibt dann auch noch ihre Absolution was das eigentlich toller Mensch ist.
Ihre psychologischen Leiden zum Thema macht.
Die kommt am Ende auch nochmal in der Justin Bieber Doku und gibt dann auch nochmal ihre Absolution was das eigentlich für ein toller Mensch ist und wie wichtig das ist dass es ihm jetzt besser geht.
Wie wichtig ist das jetzt wirklich das Geschäft das Du hast so eine Verkettung Asha Asha entdeckt Justin Bieber.
Das ist jetzt wirklich das Geschäft das man betreiben muss wenn man etwas schaffen will. Ja ja.
Justin Bieber hilft Billy nächstes präsentiert.
Genau. Wichtig ist nur dass da auch irgendeine psychische Disposition vorliegt die man dann später auch dokumentarische ausschlachten kann.
Weitergegebenen,
irgendwelche Gründe geben.
Erschreckend sind auch die Kommentare darunter dass die Menschen sich tatsächlich damit identifizieren können und sagen Ja genauso geht es mir ja auch und da würde ich dann doch sagen Hört doch mal genau hin Hier wird nämlich Perez Hilton von ihrer Schwester gefragt.
Die Kommentare tatsächlich damit identifizieren.
Würde ich sagen würde doch mal genau hin hier von ihrer Schwester gefragt Brauchst du denn eigentlich.
Wieviel Geld brauchst du denn eigentlich.
Sie würde ja eigentlich gerne eine Familie gründen aber sie muss eigentlich noch weiter arbeiten damit sie unabhängig ist weil sie ja so traumatisiert ist und deswegen hat sie sich jetzt erst mal die Eizellen einfrieren lassen und muss jetzt einfach noch weiterarbeiten.
Aber sie muss eigentlich noch weiter arbeiten damit sie unabhängig ist weil sie so traumatisiert ist und deswegen hat sie sich jetzt erst mal die Eizellen einfrieren lassen und muss jetzt.
Aber wie viel muss es denn sein.
Hi.
Jetzt. Ich glaube ich habe es abgeschnitten. Sie sagt also Sie braucht eine Milliarde.
Auflösen.
Sie muss eine Milliarde Dollar verdienen nein sie würde ein bisschen verrückt klingen gibt sie zu aber sie glaubt dass sie eine Milliarde Dollar verdienen muss.
Erklärt sie das auch.
Erst dann ist sie unabhängig dann kann sie sich auch um Kinderwunsch oder so etwas kümmern.
Das deckt sich mit fast allen Frauen in Deutschland die heute gefragt werden wann ihr Kinder zu muss der Mietvertrag unterschrieben sein Arbeitsvertrag dann der Kreditvertrag für das eigene Haus.
Wann die Kinder. Erst muss der Mietvertrag unterschrieben sein dann der Arbeitsvertrag dann der Kreditvertrag das eigene Haus.
Dann muss über den neuen Arbeitsvertrag schon geklärt sein dass das mit dem Kredit auch wirklich hinhaut und dann vielleicht kann man Kinder planen.
Dann muss über den neuen Arbeitsvertrag schon geklärt sein dass das mit dem Kredit für das Haus auch wirklich hinaus.
Und dann vielleicht kann man Kinder planen.
Eheverträge und so. Ich bin ja gar nicht so eine große Rolle vielleicht nochmal als psychologischer Anker irgendwie aber es ist tatsächlich erst der Mietvertrag dann Arbeitsvertrag und dann irgendwann mal kommen die Kinder.
Eheverträge Ich bin ja gar nicht so eine große Rolle vielleicht einmal als psychologischer Academie.
Aber es ist tatsächlich mit Arbeitsvertrag und dann höher wenn man mal kommt und bei den Männern ist es ja nicht anders.
Die sagen ja dann auch mit 45. Jetzt habe ich schon.
Männer lassen sich früher breitschlagen aber bei Frauen ist das wirklich so ein bisschen fest.
Das zweite Auto. Jetzt könnte ich mir vielleicht sogar leisten dass man noch ein Kind ist aber dann doch bei allen Parallelen.
Erstaunlich dass Leute sich glauben mit einer Figur zu identifizieren die sagt Ich muss jetzt erst mal eine Milliarde Dollar verdienen damit ich eine gewisse Unabhängigkeit habe.
Daran sieht man wie weit man Rentner Republique treiben kann. Die Sicherheit des CWS die Sicherheit des Arbeitsvertrags die Sicherheit des Mietvertrags und die finanzielle Sicherheit. Warum nicht.
Wir haben das sehr schön,
bei Klaas Heufer-Umlauf der in so einem Gespräch mit Frank Elstner war das war diese Netflix Interview Reihe diese Sinnlosigkeit. Ich habe gelesen. Christian Eichler hatte eine sehr gute Rezension dazu geschrieben.
Da war es wohl auch so dass Klaas Heufer-Umlauf gefragt wird ob er denn noch so Wünsche habe oder was für ihn wichtig sei.
Und dann sagt er ja ein bisschen mehr Sicherheit wäre schön. Und dann denkt man Na ja er hat mehrere Shows.
Er wird wahrscheinlich schon jetzt genug verdient haben dass er nicht mehr arbeiten muss.
Was wieviel Sicherheit muss es sein aber gut bei einer Milliarde. Ist sicherlich auch Klaas noch nicht.
Insofern muss auch er noch morgens aufstehen und ran.
Ja sie macht sich dann Sorgen um die Jugend und sie sagt etwas zu Social Media heute.
HSC.
Bekämen Tausende von.
Hört man selten und denkt ja irgendeine Schlussfolgerung daraus dass es als Diagnose nicht falsch aber ist eigentlich an dieser Dokumentation.
Sie verspricht die echte Perrys.
Und sie verspricht dann wie in einem Entwicklungsroman wenn man jetzt nochmal zurückgeht nochmal durch geht durch das Leben das man dann woanders rauskommt.
Aber wir hören uns jetzt das große Finale an. sagt.
Sie fällt dann auch gleich in ihre Stimme zurück wie man sie kennen und das ist so schön hier zu sehen.
Es ist nur der ökonomische Geist der hier waltet.
Bis zum Schluss. Man hat jetzt das mal ausgeschlachtet hat bestimmt sehr viel Geld dafür bekommen bei YouTube hat nochmal eine ganz neue Prominenz erfahren.
Selbst das Feuilleton findet dann plötzlich mal interessant dass man sehr viel soziales Kapital noch einmal gesammelt hat.
Jetzt macht man aber mit seinem Brant davon ist permanent in diesem Film die Rede.
Richtig Kohle weiter. Und man hört selbstverständlich nicht auf man ändert sein Leben gar nicht sondern man hat lange gesucht und hier gab es noch irgendwas was ich noch nicht ausgeschlachtet habe.
Das ist wie ein altes Tape von Bands.
Ja wir hatten dann nochmal drei Aufnahmen aus den 70ern da machen wir nochmal eine CD draus.
So ist das eigentlich. Das findet hier statt.
Und dann wird sie als großes Opfer der öffentlichkeit dargestellt da wurde ja dieser Porno dann von ihrem Freund veröffentlicht was ja eine Straftat ist.
Ganz klar aber dass sie dann in dieser Dokumentation so tut als sei man verwundert wie die öffentlichkeit darauf reagiert Naja,
das ist ja vollkommen klar wenn man eine Person des öffentlichen Lebens ist dann eine Joan Rivers sagt Mein Gott was für eine Schande für die Familie Hilton Paris hatte einen Porno gemacht in einem Marriott-Hotel.
Man versucht halt so weit zu treiben wie geht.
Man kann ja hier immer noch auf die Pionierleistung blicken sie kann ja immer noch despektierlich über Influenza sprechen unter der Doktrin Ich bin ja das Original.
Aber wenn ich mir das heute anschaue und es tut mir leid für die Kinder dass sie nicht alles machen müssen und dann gucken was ich so an Möglichkeiten ergibt.
Es ist ja auch tatsächlich viel Trial and Error Gentner überlegen in welche Richtung kann man es denn treiben.
So wie auch die ganzen deutschen YouTuber natürlich da sitzen und gerade hier die Mädels B&B und wenn sie dann schwanger sind wird denen ganz klar durchgerechnet wie viel ihr Wert steigt dadurch dass sie ebenso eine neue Klientel jung Beter und so weiter erreichen,
dass halt durchkalkuliert werden die Videos geplant und abgedreht,
und dann hofft man dass der rote Faden Nehmern konzipiert hat.
Irgendwie verfängt da was ja auch meistens funktioniert weil so kompliziert ist es ja eine.
Man kann immer noch ein Geschäft draus machen. Bei Salehi kann man das ja auch sehen dass es die YouTubern die ja kocht und backt,
und die hat ja dann irgendwann angefangen auch noch bauen mit hinzuzuziehen Hausbau und damit glaub ich jetzt sogar noch erfolgreicher als mit den Koch Videos.
Man kann das immer erweitern es gibt ein schönes Detail In dieser Doku Am Ende kommt eine sehr melancholische Version auch nicht von Cindy Lauper selbst gesungen aber es ist ihr Lied Girls.
Und das hat mich dann gleich noch einmal bei YouTube ist dazu angehalten Mir sind die Videos anzusehen.
Und da dachte ich ja eine solche quirliger und eine solche Impertinenz auch im Auftreten die auch dann eine,
Weiblichkeit ist die ganz anders in den 80ern sie aber auch Cindy Lauper noch immer durchzieht mit einer großartigen Stimme.
Das ist dann doch ein Emanzipation Modell wenn man sich irgendwie,
in der Popwelt orientieren will das mir sehr viel erstrebenswerter erscheint als Paris Hilton die nichts anderes tut als Produkte in die Kamera oder einen Justin Bieber der sich kaum disziplinieren kann da so ein paar Töne mal ins Mikrofon zu singen.
Denn das ist wirklich wenn man sich ansieht wie diese Texte da konstruieren ein bisschen wie bei der Geschichte mit Böhmermann und den Affen aus einem Popsong kreiert haben.
Viel anders scheint das bei den Lyrics von Justin Bieber auch nicht zu laufen.
Insofern ist die gute alte Zeit hab ich gedacht Cindy Lauper als Role Model für junge Frauen hundertmal geeigneter vielleicht auch für junge Männer geeigneter als alles was wir hier von Paris Hilton und Justin Bieber erleben.
Allerdings braucht man dann auch so eine Stimme mit der das funktionieren wenn man den nicht hat muss man sich halt etwas anderes gehört.
Das ist schon sehr sehr gut.
Gehört. Dann sind wir informiert und die Unterhaltungsindustrie.
Dann sind wir informiert über die beiden die Boys und Girls.
Wir werden dieses Narrativ jetzt in den nächsten zehn Jahren laufend erleben.
Übereilte Ich vermute man wird in der Politik noch viel stärker darauf setzen Man macht das ja schon so ein bisschen.
Manche Politiker haben ja auch Schicksale die sie erzählen können aber das verkauft sich wahnsinnig gut.
Also die Pastoral macht wird eine ganz entscheidende Macht in den neuen 20ern.
Sehr gut.
Dann wechseln wir jetzt das Genre und alles komplett einmal durch.
Wir gehen also nicht zu dem was vor der Kamera viel abspielt sondern das was hinter der Kamera abspielt.
Ich es nicht mit dem Schicksal einzelner Menschen das zugegebenermaßen materiell gar nicht bedroht ist also gar nicht erwähnenswert wäre sondern wir gehen dahin wo Millionen und Milliarden Menschen betroffen sind von Umständen wie sie sind.
Denn im September gab es eine Sache nicht obwohl sie versprochen war und bevor das auflösen.
Gehen wir zurück ins Jahr 1999.
Man muss sich es noch mal vergegenwärtigen for Trump for Brexit vom 11.
September vor allem Wir sind in dieser ganz heilen Welt der Neunziger als Michael Jackson noch tourte und Großes und so weiter die Show,
da saß Kofi Annan damals UN-Generalsekretär bei einer gerade 75jährige.
Vor den Davos Gästen den Wirtschafts Chefs und so weiter die sich damals auch schon trafen und sagte In zwei Minuten folgendes.
Abwandte challenge to Join Me in tollkühner relationship to tell heilender Wunden.
Apropos seit Lieu Business Leaders Hier gab er den Dubois an der United Nations Global Compact Valeurs,
Hymen Face zu der Global Market Mobilisation ist der Verkauf live bei der wabernde mailte,
made in the Global Market people do not specific Alkohol Anjou individuelle,
kollektive business associations Breaks Support Erne nackt Zlof Kowalewski areas of human rights Lebers Standes annehmbarer mental Practices,
Trey in the Face Pleiße because a b Areas Queue as Businessman in Woman can make a real,
normal Sprecher from Scrubs to love the right.
Between Global Market Radwan bei Kalkulation of Short Term Profit Van der Hyman Face Between the World Daems,
Cortal Race Scola.
At hat liesst Prosperität in erhellte Environment between,
Free Elysées The Future Strong Success von Accept Responsibility Global Vision ein Leadership,
Ladies and Gentlemen Jewel.
Er hat es kurz gehalten zwei Minuten ist die ganze Rede und wir wissen allerdings wie das programmatisch und erfordert unterfüttert war durch die Millenniumsziele und so weiter.
Der Kontext ist heute ganz interessant wenn man heute zurückblickt. Die Containerschifffahrt kam es in den 70er Jahren auf als der maßgebliche Katalysator,
des Welthandels der es wirklich ermöglicht hat in Hamburg das wirklich Interessante in Hamburg kann man sich heute die Schiffe im Hafen angucken wo noch der Kran in die Luke.
Da hat man so einen Sack rausgeholt und so weiter und es waren noch 967 Containerschiffe die dann wirklich gesagt hat Okay wir haben jetzt hier so viel Megatonnen Zeug und schaffen das einfach.
Das kam dann in den 70ern auf. Wir sind hier bei 99 gerade in der zweiten Halbzeit der Globalisierung von heute aus betrachtet begann gerade die zweite Halbzeit und diese zweite Halbzeit von der wissen wir wie sie geprägt ist.
11. September 2008 Finanzkrise dann der ganze krame so Krise niederschlagen dass wir Flüchtlingswellen haben bei denen wir immer sagen dass wir eigentlich Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge,
aus humanitären Gründen sondern weil sie wirtschaftliche Not haben Wo kommt die eigentlich her.
Und damals Kofi Annan. 1999 hat das so Die ist ja nicht meine Ansprache an Politiker vor allem sondern an Wirtschaftsbossen so hat es halt so ins Blaue hinein gesagt.
Keiner der Politiker die heute maßgeblich sind war damals schon nennenswert.
Merkel vielleicht gerade so Ministerin oder so Gerd Müller noch so ein einfacher Bundestagsabgeordneter,
von Hubertus Heil war mir damals noch gar nichts gehört aber die Zeit läuft ins Land und am 13. September also vor ein paar Tagen,
hat Gerd Müller Unser Entwicklungsminister von der CSU den abfiel feiern weil er dann doch mal Goody hat.
Hat gesagt er hört auf nach dieser Wahl ist jetzt 65 und so weiter.
Daraufhin schrieb Hubertus Heil lieber BMZ Gerd Müller kann eigene Twitter-Accounts haben,
bevor du die Brücke verlässt haben wir beide noch etwas zu erledigen Herzlichst Dein Arbeitsminister Hashtag Lieferketten Gesetz und Lieferketten Gesetz hört man von denen hört man immer mal so ein bisschen was kommt mal da auf mal da,
110 Minuten gemacht Mikroökonomie thematisieren das immer mal.
Aber was ist eigentlich diese Lieferketten gesetzt das uns eigentlich zu August versprochen wurde.
Und da steigen wir mal nicht in den Inhalt sondern erst mal in dieser zeitlichen Dimension nochmal ein.
Denn am 9. 9. gab es bei der SPD-Fraktion unter Corona Bedingung Keine anwesenden nennenswert und das Video haben jetzt 300 Leute im Youtube Stream gesehen,
saß Frank Zappa vom Deutschen Gewerkschaftsbund zuständig für die eine oder andere Diskussion zum Thema und hat hier mal dargestellt.
Wir haben es ja mit einem anderen Problem zu tun als wenn wir einfach nur einen Tarifpartner schaffen mal kurz den nächsten Vertrag für die Tarifrunde durchschauen das dauert dann nämlich drei Monate hier ist es anders.
Wenn man im internationalen Geschäft unterwegs ist dann denkt man eher in Dekaden. Das dauert halt immer so ein bisschen.
Das zeigt sich jetzt beim Lieferketten Gesetz bedauerlicherweise auch.
Wir haben 21 Jahre ist es jetzt her dass Kofi Annan eine sehr kluge Rede vom Weltwirtschaftsforum in Davos gehalten hat wo genau die Probleme die wir heute haben teilweise mit Protektionismus und Nationalismus vorhergesagt hat.
Weil die Globalisierung nur eine wirtschaftliche Globalisierung ist und keinen sozialen und politischen Fortschritt gebracht hat.
Das hat er damals sehr in einer wunderbaren sehr kurz gehaltenen Rede wunderbar beschrieben.
Heute haben wir Donald Trump Wir haben Brexit und so weiter. Es ist alles bestätigt worden was der gute Mann damals erzählt hat.
Und wenn man die Rede 1099 hat könnte man denken Na gut hat halt gefordert ein menschliches Antlitz für die Globalisierung Wir wissen aber heute worum es ging nämlich tatsächlich zu sagen neben,
dem freien Handel brauchen wir einen Fernhandel der die Menschen und nicht nur die Güter als Produkte der Arbeit in den Mittelpunkt stellt.
Und wir müssen jetzt sagen die ersten 20 Jahre waren verschenkt.
Und bevor wir auf die funktionalen Argumente kommen haben wir uns Scots ein bisschen warm.
Was so ein bisschen auch die moralische Dimension die da drin steckt weil leiden Menschen an.
Und da hat Gerd Müller bei der Vorstellung dieses Gesetzesvorhaben mit Hubertus Heil gemeinsam eine Pressekonferenz gemacht.
Dieses Jahr hat über Teebeutel gesprochen.
Das ist ein Teebeutel aus der Region Assam aus Indien.
Die weidenden Teeplantagen mit dem Frauen und ich habe sie unter vier Augen gefragt Wie sind da ihre Verhältnisse. Das sind Verhältnisse wie in der früheren Kolonialzeit. Meine Damen und Herren in Azam.
Die Frauen arbeiten zwölf Stunden Hitze Hange und verdienen einen Dollar am Tag.
Dieser Teebeutel den sie genüsslich reinhängen der Früh der kostet hier einen Cent 1,5 Cent.
Wir werden neben der Produktionskette zwei Cent bezahlt werden und vor Ort das Einkommen ankommen müssten diese Frauen nicht wie Lohnsklaven in ihren Hütten arbeiten wie in früheren Jahrhunderten.
Das ist so eine Rechnung die kann man nachvollziehen. Ein Viertel Cent mehr pro Teebeutel also einen Euro auf 400 Teetassen hebt den Lebensstandard derjenigen die den Tee in Indien herstellen substanziell an und den Preis.
Das ist der Gründer eines Unternehmens das irgendwas mit Internet macht hat sein,
Gehalt auf einmal von 1,1 Millionen Dollar auf 70 000 Dollar gesenkt und damit gleichzeitig sich selbst auf den Mindestlohn den er in seinem Unternehmen eingeführt hat gesenkt.
Und deswegen folge ich ihn bei Twitter weil man diese Welle durchgehe und er hat auf Twitter jetzt von der New York Times einen Text verlinkt.
McDonalds Mitarbeiter in Dänemark bekommen 22 Dollar die Stunde.
Sechs Wochen bezahlten Urlaub ein Jahr bezahlte Eltern Pause.
Wenn sie sie brauchen Rente und Krankenversicherung mcdonalds mitarbeiter in Amerika bekommen sieben Dollar 25 die Stunde. Und sonst keine weiteren Benefits.
Der einzige Unterschied zwischen dem dänischen und dem amerikanischen McDonalds ist dass der Big Mac in Dänemark 27 Cent mehr kostet.
Ich meine diese Rechnung habe ich versucht ein bisschen nachvollzieht zu vollziehen.
Er kostet in Dänemark gar nicht mehr wenn man mindestens einen Big Mac Index.
Weltweit verglichen wird. Man käme sogar ohne Kostenargument nochmal drauf aber die 27 Cent kommen von dem Erstautor so seine Beobachtung.
Man kann es ein bisschen hochrechnen. McDonalds verkauft pro Sekunde 17 Big Macs.
Es geht also tatsächlich um 550 Millionen Dollar im Jahr allein über Big Macs. Die Produktpalette ist noch ein bisschen größer.
Man kommt schon auf substanzielle Werte durch im Endprodukt zu kleine Abweichungen.
Einen halben Cent irgendwie den man hier TByte drauf macht oder beim Big Mac dann ein viertel Dollar und so.
Aus marxistischer Perspektive muss ich selbstverständlich gleich fragen ob daraus jetzt zu schließen ist unsere Produkte sind zu günstig.
Oder ob daraus zu schließen ist dass.
Oder ob daraus zu schließen ist dass die Unternehmen größere Profite einfahren.
Das ist genau der Punkt. Denn dieses Gesetz heißt ja nicht ohne Grund Lieferketten gesetzt.
Es geht darum die Kette nachzuvollziehen sodass hier sichergestellt werden kann dass der Mehrwert im Verkauf tatsächlich durchgereicht wird in einer Kette,
nicht als Marge abgegriffen von irgendeinem Händler sondern ankommt bei denjenigen die tatsächlich den Tee ernten. Genau darum geht es.
Hubertus Heil nennt es das Lieferketten Gesetz. Gerd Müller nennt es das Sorgfaltspflichten Gesetz.
Ich finde Lieferketten Gesetz eigentlich ein bisschen passender weil nochmal diese Dimension die Verkettung von und das muss dann wirklich durchgereicht werden sowie der Mehrwert durchgereicht wird muss halt auch in die Richtung durchgereicht werden.
Na ja wir drücken ein bisschen auf die Tränendrüse denn diese Politiker von denen wir immer sagen Ach die kenne ich nicht aus Die denken immer nur an ihre eigene Wiederwahl und so weiter.
Hier Bärbel Kofler bei der gleichen Veranstaltung sie hat auch nochmals einen kleinen Erfahrungsbericht warum ihr auch dieses Gesetz am Herzen liegt.
Ich war einmal in einer Mine in Pakistan das werde ich nie vergessen. In einem Tal wo kleine Kinder mit eheähnlichen in eine Kohlemine hinein gepfercht wurden.
Und wer einmal in die Augen solcher Kinder und in die Augen dieser Menschen sieht der weiß warum wir Verantwortung menschenrechtliche Verantwortung entlang der Lieferkette nehmen müssen.
Und das ist eigentlich ganz interessant sie hat es über Kohle gesprochen es gibt auch so eine Szene da hat Gerd Müller so ein Stein in der Hand und sagte einfach alles was in einem Telefonat drin ist steckt in diesem Stein dann zählt er die Elemente auf.
Und darum geht's. Arm und Reich zu verbinden weil das ist ja aus unserer Logik so dass wir sagen Ja wir sind reich wir haben die technischen Geräte also haben sie so veredelt.
Sie kommen aus Regionen wo Armut herrscht und deswegen gibt's da halt diese Steine als Rohstoff.
Aber man kann sich ja auch soziologisch ein bisschen die Frage stellen Warum ist es eigentlich nicht umgedreht.
Warum sind wir nicht so abhängig von diejenigen die die Rohstoffe haben. Warum sind die von uns abhängig. Welche.
Welcher Zauber. Welcher kapitalistische Zauber welcher Raffinesse der Herrenmenschen steckt eigentlich dahinter diese Logik so umzudrehen weil logisch ist das ja nicht dass wir die Herrenmenschen über die Sklaven sind obwohl wir deren Rohstoffe brauchen.
Es müsste ja eigentlich umgedreht sein da ist es schon total verrückt wenn man sich das mal anschaut.
Hubertus Heil hat auch eine ganz interessante historische Dimension in der Thematisierung.
Ich habe aber auch im Fleisch Bereich hätte ich beinahe gesagt In diesem Fall im übergang von Fleisch zu textilen nämlich in einer Gerberei,
erlebt dass da Bilder und Gerüche da waren und Situationen wo Frauen bis zu den Knien in Chemikalien standen wo es keinerlei Schutz gab.
Erlebt dass Bilder da waren und Situationen Frauen bis zu den Knien in China standen wo es keinerlei Schutz gab für den Sozialdemokraten so etwas zu erleben ist ein Begriff dafür zu bekommen warum eine deutsche.
Für einen Sozialdemokraten sowas zu erleben ist ein Begriff dafür zu bekommen warum eine deutsche Sozialdemokratie vor über 150 Jahren entstanden ist das war so eine Art Vorkampf jihadistische Hölle die man sich einigen konnte.
Einmal entstanden ist.
Und ich befürchte man muss sich das vor Augen führen.
Ich finde es schön dass kapitalistische Hölle sagt frühkapitalistischen.
Da hat er sich versprochen Ehrlich gesagt Er meinte frühkapitalistischen. Es gibt sehr viele er häufiger diese frühkapitalistischen.
Aber es ist im Grunde die soziale Marktwirtschaft oder.
Aber es ist im Grunde diese soziale Marktwirtschaft. Ja aber es ist ganz interessant.
Aber ist ganz interessant. Hubertus Heil ist in einer Partei die noch einmal ihren Ursprung live erleben kann.
Hubertus Heil ist eine Partei die nochmal ihren Ursprung live erleben.
Sie muss einfach nur dahin gehen wo die Ursprünge der CDU oder der FDP würde so jetzt nicht mehr gelingen.
Nee die können das sehr gut machen. Man kann das auch im übrigen im Kapital wunderbar nachlesen Es gibt da ein großes Kapitel das gar nicht so schwer zu lesen ist wie manche andere Teile über den Arbeitstag.
Und dann geht es darum wie die Kapitalisten dafür selbstverständlich sorgen wollen dass Kinder lange arbeiten müssen dass kein Wochenende für sie gewährt wird.
Es geht da um 16 18 Stunden Tage für Minderjährige aber auch für Erwachsene selbstverständlich und das nachzulesen ist so unglaublich wenn man da dann die sozialstaatlichen Errungenschaften nochmal ganz deutlich vorgeführt bekommt.
Ein Fall ist da die Café Marie die mit Kaffee übertage hochgepäppelt wurde und mit Likör.
Damit sie überhaupt nicht schläft damit sie alle Kleider fertigstellen kann und die stirbt dann das Schicksal schildert auch,
Marx dort und da kann man eben sehr sehr gut daran sehen dass wir es mit,
Profitinteressen zu tun haben die eben nicht darauf zurückzuführen sind dass wir irgendwie mehr Werte oder was den Unternehmen doch mal.
Von denen einfordern sollen oder so.
Sondern es geht nur mit ganz klaren Regulierungen die sagen Nein,
Mit 12 darf niemand arbeiten und Nein in Indien geht das genauso nicht und wir müssen wenn wir jetzt heute ein Produkt aus Indien haben darauf achten dass das auch so eingehalten wurde.
Das ist aber einfach nur eine Frage von Regulationen und es ist überhaupt keine Frage ob ein Unternehmer da Lust drauf hat oder nicht.
Also ich weiß gar nicht warum auch immer wieder diese Fokussierung da ist das man den Unternehmen da erst einmal an Tisch holen muss und die man befragen muss dazu das ist ja vollkommener Unsinn.
Na ja die Frage wie bei diesem Gesetz die Wirtschaft noch rein wirkt ist,
interessant aber wir werden nachher hören Es gibt sehr viele Unternehmen die das eigentlich wollen weil zum Beispiel wenn Menschen ein Ehring kaufen ist sehr vielen sehr wichtig dass das eben nicht Gold aus irgendeiner Mine ist wo die Kinder gestorben.
Das ist bei Investitionslust Gold in Form von Barren anders da geht es nur um die Masse des Goldes.
Aber bei so veredelten Schmuck also man dann so Eheringe hat so schmuck da machen die Leute doch wissen wo ist das eigentlich her und da sind die Unternehmen dann doch erpicht darauf über diesen Qualitätsmerkmal eine Markt.
Schließung zu erreichen und sagen dann Wir brauchen diese Regulierung denn es wäre blöd wenn nur weil ein paar Leuten egal ist woher Ehring herkommt.
Deswegen Nachteile haben und die CDU um es vorweg zu greifen weil wir haben sehr wenige Klubs von der CDU gleich weil die dazu nämlich schweigt.
Die CDU hat sozusagen einen vorauseilenden Gehorsam.
Die möchte die Wirtschaft erst gar nicht in Unruhe versetzen obwohl sie gar nicht selber weiß ob das nicht doch gewollt ist dass man vielleicht so eine Art Standard einzieht an denen sich dann aber alle halten sodass alle wieder Planungshorizont haben und Sicherheiten.
Es ist total verrückt wie die CDU sich da verhält.
Aber er kann hier sehen warum eigentlich mal vor 150 Jahren seine Partei gegründet wurde.
Und genau dieser Arbeitsauftrag bleibt nur eben jetzt nicht mehr hier sondern dort wo man die ganzen Sachen externer hin.
Machen was ein bisschen lebensweltlich denn man wills sozusagen handgreiflich verstehen Gerd Müller hat nicht nur den Teebeutel gehabt sondern auch noch eine Dschihads.
Diese Jeans die ich vorher überreicht habe ist durchgehend kontrolliert von Bangladesch in der Näherei,
bis hier auf den Bügel und dazu sind 40 Standards festgelegt soziale und ökologische.
Aufgebaut.
Es geht also viel weiter als wir mit dem Sorgfaltspflichten Gesetz andenken können.
Also weiter.
So eine Jeans die nach 5 Standards hergestellt wurde über die man sich vorher kollektiv verständigte.
Das sind die auf die wir achten müssen sozial und ökologisch.
Diese ökologisch Dimension kommt ein bisschen kurz im Gesetz aber es ist ein Gesetz das sozialdemokratisch,
angelegt ist und er hat noch angefügt diese Jeans ist viel besser noch produziert als wir es Angedenken mit dem Gesetz das wir jetzt machen wollen.
Und jetzt kann man allemal überlegen. Dann müsste die Jeans ja voll mega viel Geld kosten und so um wieviel Geld geht es wirklich diese Aufklärung hier ist einfach grotesk auf so eine Art und Weise.
Diese Jeans kostet in der Produktion sieben Euro und wurde fair produziert nach ökologisch sozialen Standards.
Und sie ist zertifiziert mit dem grünen Knopf. Diese entschieden. kostet. Jeans kostet im Einkauf sieben Euro.
Ohne diese Standards kauft der deutsche Handel für fünf Euro ein.
Diese zwei Euro sind die Kosten um nachhaltig zu produzieren.
Alle ökologischen und sozialen Standards die weit über das angedachte die verketten Gesetz hinausgehen machen die Segens von fünf auf sieben Euro in der Produktion teurer wird hier trotzdem für hundert Euro verkauft.
Die Frage ist nur diese zwei Euro Wem wird das als Marge zugeschrieben und wenn man es an der Quelle in der Produktion zuschreibt hat man dieses Ziel erreicht.
Ich überlege gerade ist es wirklich so dass er jetzt hier beschreibt weil er sagt vom Einkauf der Händler. Wer ist denn jetzt der Händler bei dieser.
Der Händler ist der allererste in der Lieferkette der an der Produktion kauft also in Bangladesch im Werk Bangladesch ist,
eine Chiffre für diesen Unfall vor fünf oder zehn Jahren.
Naja und die hatten extrem zu leiden jetzt unter Corona Da haben nämlich ganz ganz viele Modekonzern einfach gesagt Nö wir produzieren jetzt doch nicht.
Ihr bleibt jetzt darauf sitzen vieles war schon angefertigt und dann hatten sie kein Druckmittel dagegen irgendwie vorzugehen vielleicht sogar gerichtlich sondern die mussten es akzeptieren weil ihnen zugleich signalisiert wurde wenn ihr das jetzt nicht macht,
dann müssen wir mal gucken wo wir die nächste Saison unsere Mode produzieren.
Und man muss sich das klarmachen denn das ist ja immer so verrückt wenn über Preise geredet wird.
Das ist ja etwas anderes wie jetzt bei diesen Preisen bei Fleisch es nochmal etwas direkter ist was. Was damit gemacht wird.
Wir haben es hier mit einem Unterschied von zwei Euro zu tun und du hast ja vollkommen recht.
Eine normale Jeans kostet wahrscheinlich in dieser Qualität 1000 Euro.
Verdienen schon mal ganz viel mit und man kann dann ja nur sich ausmalen welche Marge da drauf kommt wenn da die entsprechende Marke drauf ist.
Denn das haben wir ja jetzt ja schon in der Grundschule eigentlich gelernt dass diese Marken Es sind die eigentlich das Geld generieren.
Und wir haben das gerade bei Paris Hilton dann gehört wo eine Person nur noch von sich als Brant spricht.
Also diese Logo Gesellschaft die Naomi Klein beschrieben hat Die sehen wir da ganz deutlich was nicht heißt dass qualitativ hochwertige Mode jetzt generell.
Minderwertig eigentlich ist nur weil die Marke drauf ist aber es ist selbstverständlich so dass man extrem viel für die Marke mitbezahlt Man kann das sehr schön darin sehen wenn so,
Hersteller wie Adidas oder so sondern Kollektionen machen das heißt irgendeinen Superstar,
kreiert dann Sneakers Es sind exakt dies die Adidas halt immer macht und der hat dann auch noch wie,
Justin Bieber sonst Smiley drauf gemacht und dann gehen die direkt für hundert Euro mehr weg.
Das ist ein Mehrwert der erwirtschaftet wird der geht direkt an die Leute die in New Yorker Hotels rumsitzen oder so.
Der geht überhaupt nicht mehr nach Bangladesch oder so. Das heißt wenn wir von Preisen reden die sich erhöhen und dann sind wir auf so eine ganz Low Level angekommen und wo die eigentlichen Preiserhöhungen stattfinden das ist dann in den Geschäften oder auch,
allein die Unterschiede Luxuskaufhaus die eine Jeans kaufst oder das selbe Modell in einem nicht so luxuriösen Kaufhaus macht schon 10 15 Euro aus.
Diese Dimension der geringe Anteil der Produktionskosten auf unter zehn Prozent durch die Bank alles T Jeans Fleisch und so weiter.
Das ist eine Dimension die wird komplett unterschätzt wenn Wenn wir über unseren Alltag nachdenken.
Frank Zach stellt diese politische Dimension hinter dem Preis nochmal da.
Wenn wir die Arbeitsschutz Standards der Europäischen Union in Bangladesch anwenden würden würde das bei einem Hemd eine Preissteigerung von 25 Cent ausmachen.
Hält eine Preissteigerung von 25 Cent.
Und das ist im Grunde eine lächerliche Summe wenn man sich anschaut dass 1200 Näherin dort ums Leben gekommen.
Der europäische Arbeitsschutz Standard Damit meint er die komplette soziale Dimension bis hin zur Renten und Krankenversicherung.
Also nicht nur hohe Lohn sondern einfach die komplette Bandbreite europäischen Lebens der europäischen Arbeitswelt.
Und es macht bei einem Hemd 25 Cent Unterschied.
Es ist sozusagen finanziell absolut zu leisten. Die Frage ist nur Warum wird es nicht gemacht.
Es kostet nicht mal mehr im Laden sondern man müsse nur ein bisschen. Das ist so ein bisschen wie haben Sie ja jetzt auch bei Tönnies gesehen.
Der Einzelne Subunternehmer der aus Bulgarien irgendwie hergefahren wird macht ja tatsächlich ein Jahresumsatz von 450000 Euro,
davon gehen 98 Prozent in Tönnies Tasche ein Prozent geht an den Subunternehmer und das letzte Prozent wenn überhaupt ein Prozent ist verschwindend gering fällt dann sozusagen als Lohnkosten an.
Und man müsste ja quasi nur auf ein paar zehntausend pro Band verzichten immer noch im einstelligen Prozentbereich und man hätte da schon ein akzeptables Monatsgehalt wo die Leute sich dann einfach selber eine Wohnung kaufen und,
selber eine Wohnung mieten anstatt irgendwie noch feudalistische auf die Wohnung des Arbeitgebers angewiesen zu sein.
Naja es ist jedenfalls was das angeht sehr dramatisch und.
Warum macht man es denn nicht. Das ist eine wirtschaftliche überlegungen die man anstellen könnte und sagen Na ja wir stehen als Unternehmen doch ohnehin ein bisschen besser da.
Das ist ja jetzt eine wirtschaftliche überlegungen die man anstellen könnte und sagen Milliardenschäden besser da.
Es kostet uns zu wenig. Wir geben so viel für unsinnige Marketingaktionen aus.
Was kostet so wenig wie viel für unsinnige Marketingaktionen aus. Das würde doch reichen für mich.
Das würde doch gar nicht ins Gewicht fallen. Was wenn es noch so eine andere Dimension eigentlich dahinter gibt dass man genau dieses Ungleichgewicht braucht das wenn man jetzt diese Frauen aus Indien beispielsweise.
Was wenn es nach so einer anderen Dimension eigentlich dahinter liegt dass man genau dieses Ungleichgewicht braucht das wenn man jetzt diese Frauen aus Indien beispielsweise.
Ein bisschen besser entlohnt so dass sie solche Absicherungen für indische Verhältnisse genießen wie wir sie hier in Europa genießen dass sie auf die Idee kommen könnten.
Ein bisschen besser entlohnt so dass sie solche Absicherungen für indische Verhältnisse in Europa genießen dass sie auf die Idee kommen könnten.
Ich mache mir jetzt hier keine Ernte mehr doch wird es hier nicht mehr zwölf Stunden rum.
Ich verkaufe selber über Amazon.
Ich kaufe hier verkaufe selber bei Amazon Versuche selbst irgendetwas zu machen das heißt wir,
machen das was ja der doppelt freie Lohnarbeiter ist bei Marx dass man sagt man ist zum einen frei seine,
Man man man ist frei in der Form dass man immer entlassen werden kann oder will oder was auch immer. Man ist auch frei in dem was man tut.
Ab einem gewissen Niveau kommt man eben in die Situation dass man sagt Nö ich mache jetzt mal für mich selbst das ist ja etwas,
was der Journalismus gerade zu spüren bekommt sehr interessant Wir sind ja quasi zwei Beispiele.
Man konnte jahrelang immer schlechtere Tarife für Journalisten machen. überhaupt haben die meisten Zeitungen sich von Tarifen verabschiedet.
Man hat echt extrem prekär bezahlt man hat überstunden ohne ende gewollt Sontags Dienste Zuständigkeiten für Volontäre die hier eigentlich nicht machen darf.
Also Schluss Dienste und all solche Dinge sollen dann Volontäre machen und jetzt erlebt man gerade das zum Beispiel durch Podcasts oder andere Dinge sich Menschen für Journalismus nach wie vor interessieren.
Aber sagen Na ich gehe doch jetzt nicht in eine Zeitungsredaktion und setze mich diesem Druck aus und verdiene noch so wenig und lasse mir noch vorschreiben was ich tue.
Ich versuche jetzt mit ein bisschen Mut irgendwie selbst etwas anzuschieben.
Man sagt sich dann werde ich auch nicht reich dadurch aber ich kann wesentlich freier arbeiten das machen was ich will und ich benötige nicht die Zeitung dafür.
Das heißt diese Emanzipation also das Herausziehen sich selbst aus einem Abhängigkeitsverhältnis das ist etwas was der Kapitalismus auch mitunter vermeiden will.
Es gibt auf der anderen Seite diese ganzen tausend Gründer Podcast wo immer ich habe mich selbst verwirklicht.
Aber dabei wird ein bisschen vernachlässigt die Sache Irgendjemand muss diese Produkte von Paris Hilton herstellen und das ist wahrscheinlich kein Vergnügen.
Genauso wie diese Teebeutel irgendwie entstehen müssen. Und diese Abhängigkeit die schafft man eben ganz durch.
Dadurch dass man sie in eine so prekäre Lage bringt dass sie nicht anders können wir haben ja sogar im,
Handel mit neuen Formen der Sklaverei zu tun insofern als Menschen versuchen aus Fenstern zu springen um ihrem Arbeitgeber zu entkommen.
In arabischen Staaten oder so..
Ja das hat mir auch bei der Produktion in China woraufhin Steve Jobs damals sehr bestürzt darüber war intern wie man heute weiß und dann auch sehr viel gemacht hat um da irgendwie Abhilfe zu ermöglichen.
Zu dieser Dimension gehört auch dass man als europäisches Land und großer Lobbyist darauf aus ist die,
politische Landschaft in Ländern wie Bangladesch und so weiter zu zerstören also wirklich zu zertrümmern sodass dort gar keine Rahmenbedingungen geschaffen wird.
Rechtssicherheit Versicherung und so weiter um so Stricker aus dem man sich dann aus den Fabriken zieht muss man aus dem Fenster springen und die Sklaverei Gerd Müller.
Wirklich schade dass er geht. Viele andere CSU-Politiker machen ja bis 70 und weiter. Warum nicht Gerd Müller eigentlich.
Denn er hat hier auch den Sklaven kommt hier in seinem Appell für faire Lieferketten noch einmal vor.
Fairer Handel in globalen Lieferketten ist der Schlüssel für die Entwicklung von Arbeitsplätzen und den Erhalt der Umwelt in den Entwicklungsländern. Das ist das Entscheidende.
Das Problem ist dass wir Industrieländer External passierten.
Wir lagern Produktionsketten aus in Entwicklungsländer und unterlaufen Standards für unsere Produkte in unserer Wohlstandsgesellschaft soziale und ökologische Standards die bei uns selbstverständlich sind.
Wir akzeptieren und zementieren damit die Ausbeutung von Mensch und Natur in Entwicklungsländern und wir tolerieren im großen Stile Kinderarbeit,
eine Bayreuther Wissenschaftler hat nachgewiesen dass unser Lebensstandard,
unser Lebensstandard hier in Deutschland Konsum wie wir leben dass es dafür im Durchschnitt 50 Sklaven arbeiten.
Das meint er tatsächlich ganz direkt. Sie stehen halt nicht am Bett die Schuhe an.
Aber es sind fünfzig Sklaven pro Menschen Konsumenten in der westlichen Hemisphäre.
Und wenn man das so sieht da stehen zwei Bundesminister machen eine Pressekonferenz mit einem Statement Warum kommt das in keiner Nachrichtensendung vor. Fragt man sich wirklich was ist da los.
Ich habe es auch nicht mitbekommen. Ich habe es nicht mitbekommen.
Das ist im Juli als man noch frohen Mutes war dass man im August mit Peter Altmaier dem Wirtschaftsminister so weit ist dass man dann ein Gesetz vorlegen kann.
Na ja die Lösung von all diesen Problemen die hier angesprochen worden ist also dieses Lieferketten gesetzt wir haben ja auch schon so besprochen das ist eigentlich klar.
Konzeptionell ist das alles klar man muss ein paar Gewinnmargen weg streichen und das als Lohn auszahlen dann hätte man schon ganz schön viele Probleme gelöst.
Und Gerd Müller kommt ja nochmal auf den grünen Knopf zu sprechen denn nicht nur ist konzeptionell alles klar sondern es ist auch schon in praktischer Umsetzung.
Es gibt nur noch kein allgemeines Gesetz.
Wir laden die Wirtschaft ein mitzumachen mitzugestalten.
Mitzumachen mitzugestalten Es wird sich herausstellen dass viele der Vorurteile die ganz bewusst darauf gestreut wurden entkräftet werden.
Und es wird sich herausstellen dass viele der Vorurteile die ganz bewusst auch gestreut wurden entkräftet werden können.
Es geht. Es ist machbar und die Blaupause ist das deutsche Textil Bündnis gründeten.
Also Der grüne Knopf Jeans hergestellt hat er uns schon erklärt hat.
Jetzt wurde dieses Gesetz in mehreren Etappen geplant ausgehend von Kofi Annan und diesen großen Anliegen.
Man sagt ja gut dann können wir ja erst mal auf die Freiwilligkeit der Wirtschaft setzen.
Dieser Prozess lief bis zum Jahreswechsel. Der ist jetzt schon klar es Corona dazwischen und so weiter. Das entschuldigt natürlich für viele Sachen die da liegen blieben. Aber wir blicken hier kurz in den Februar 2020.
Eva-Maria Schreiber von der Linken verkündet mal die Ergebnisse der Auswertung hinsichtlich.
Wie sieht es die Wirtschaft mit der Freiwilligkeit beim Thema Sorgfaltspflicht.
Um die Freiwilligkeit weiter beizubehalten mussten 50 Prozent der Antworten positiv ausfallen.
Geantwortet haben 465 unternehmen.
Geantwortet haben 465 Unternehmen Davon erfüllten 20 Prozent also drei und neunzig Unternehmen die Anforderungen das sind zwei komma acht Prozent der.
Davon erfüllten 20 Prozent also drei und neunzig Unternehmen die Anforderungen das sind 2,8 Prozent der Angeschriebenen.
Jetzt soll noch ein zweiter Durchgang erfolgen. Glauben Sie wirklich dass im Juni plötzlich über 50 Prozent der Unternehmen die Anforderungen erfüllen werden ich nicht.
Ab
September. Wir wissen jetzt schon Bescheid.
Eine unglaubliche Fars.
Man hat die Vorschläge der CDU Ja es stand auch schon im Koalitionsvertrag 2000 der vorhergehender 13. 2013.
Damals hat man versucht jetzt hat man zumindest diese Freiwilligkeit dass man meine Datenerhebung macht zum Thema Wie weit ist denn die Wirtschaft.
Sie hat gesagt Im ersten Durchlauf waren es 2,8 Prozent und es gibt einen zweiten Durchlauf Es könnte ja durchaus sein dass noch 50 Prozent der Unternehmen sagen ja doch jetzt schon.
Und das hat ja im für Juni angekündigt Wir können also in den Juli springen und hören hier Hubertus Heil.
Die Bundesregierung und der Kollege Müller als eben beschrieben hat im Rahmen des Nationalen Aktionsplans untersucht inwieweit deutsche Unternehmen Menschenrechte in globalen Wertschöpfungsketten mit Menschenrechten umgehen.
Ich muss feststellen dass das Finale Monitoring das heute vorliegt.
Es gab ja eine Zwischenstufe im Dezember tatsächlich deutlich macht dass nicht mehr allein auf Freiwilligkeit setzen können.
Die Bundesregierung hat deshalb einen klaren Handlungs Auftrag.
Wir werden jetzt gemeinsam an Eckpunkten für eine Regelung unternehmerischer Sorgfaltspflicht und Lieferketten zur Stärkung von Menschenrechten arbeiten.
Unser Ziel ist dass wir das im August im Kabinett beschließen können und dann unmittelbar in die Gesetzgebung für ein Lieferketten Gesetz eintreten können.
Da ist der Koalitionsvertrag ganz klar.
Der Koalitionsvertrag ist klar Wir haben September Wir wissen im August ist nichts passiert es gab keinen Kabinettsbeschluss zum Thema Lieferketten.
Trotzdem hat er im Juli antizipieren schon mal den Druck entsprechend gemacht.
Wenn zu wenig Unternehmen auf dem freiwilligen Wege diesen Weg gehen wie auch über gesetzgeberische Verpflichtung nicht nur reden sondern noch in dieser Legislaturperiode zu einem Gesetz kommen.
Das ist die Geschäftsgrundlage dieser Regierung und deshalb nochmal Wir machen das sorgfältig das wird nicht irgendein handwerklicher Pfusch Wir können es Gesetze machen,
und wir werden das verhältnismäßig ausgestalten aber an einer gesetzgeberischen Verantwortung geht jetzt kein Weg mehr vorbei. Das ist das klare Signal.
Das klare Signal Die CDU hat damals im Juli auch schon erklärt.
Deshalb ist der Weg über Eckpunkte des Kabinetts eine Grundlage für Gesetzgebung.
Aber die wird nicht auf Ewigkeiten geschoben sondern August soll das sein und dann wird man die Gesetze.
Eckpunkte im Hinterkopf. Das ist nämlich die zweite Stufe macht die Freiwilligkeit Erhebung je nachdem.
Wenn die dann alle sagen Nähe keine Lust Wir werden uns nicht mal gibt's Eckpunkte die gemeinsam verhandelt werden dann kommt ein Gesetzesvorschlag und dann kommt es zu einem Koalitions Beschluss und dann kommt das Gesetz im Bundestag.
Wir wissen jetzt sehr lange ist die Bundesregierung nicht mehr im Amt.
Sind die Lobbyisten dann immer wieder da.
Genau die funkt natürlich überall rein und es sind nicht mehr viel Zeit.
Wahlkampf beginnt jetzt bald und so weiter.
Deswegen jetzt im September. Ich springe jetzt nach den August. Hubertus Heil ist ja schon ein bisschen ernüchtert klingt aber noch ganz Meuer.
Es gibt eine gute Nachricht und es gibt noch eine anstrengende Nachricht die gute Nachricht ist wir war noch nie so dicht dran ein Lieferketten Gesetz für Menschenrechtliche Sorgfaltspflichten in Deutschland zu bekommen wie anstrengend.
So..
Dazu komme ich gleich noch wir sind noch nicht durch. Wir müssen weiterverhandeln.
Wie funktioniert die Blockade. Was ist wenn wir so ins Bergische Bundesminister haben und zwar gleich zwei der eine mit dem größten Haushalt und der andere mit der größten Weitsicht Gerd Müller und Hubertus Heil.
Woran hakt es. Diese kleine funktionale Analyse gibt uns hier Hubertus Heil jetzt mal im September.
Man muss ein bisschen auch wissen dass ich jetzt mal aus der Tasche geplaudert. Das ist nicht nur unterschiedliche Interessen gibt es Zugänge sondern auch unterschiedliche Kompetenzen was so ein Ministerium kann.
So sehr ich es schätze wie der Kollege Müller sich engagiert.
Das BMZ ist wer sich auskennt in der Regel kein Gesetzgebungen Ministerium sondern es ist eher ein Ministerium mit sehr viel Mitteln auch Gott sei Dank.
Das Bundesministerium für Arbeit und Soziales ist traditionell gar kein fördern. Ministerium.
Wir können nicht so richtig gut Förderprogramme Wir können in der Regel Leistungs Gesetze deutschen Sozialstaat oder Gesetze.
Und da Ministerium die Kompetenz hat für das Thema von Corporate Social Responsibility also von unternehmerischer Verantwortung und um den Weg von Corporate Social Responsibility zu Diligence.
Jetzt habe ich es schön englisch ausgedrückt ergibt also zur rechtlichen Verpflichtung von der Freiwilligkeit sind wir diejenigen die da eine wichtige Zuständigkeit haben.
In der Koalition ist vereinbart dass wir jetzt für die Eckpunkte die Federführung zwischen Wirtschaftsministerium Entwicklung und Arbeit haben wir haben die technische. Wir versuchen das zusammenzuführen.
Und wenn die Eckpunkte durch sind werden wir die Federführung im Bundesministerium für Arbeit und Soziales haben den Gesetzentwurf aus.
Also es gibt eine Federführung bei ihm.
Er könnte das einfach machen. Eine Beschlussvorlage Koalitionsausschuß Er droht dann später auch nochmal eine Veranstaltung mit.
Das kann man dann nochmal zum Thema des Koalitionsausschuss setzen.
Das ist dann immer ein bisschen knifflig weil die Nachrichten kümmern sich auch darum nicht besonders.
Aber es wird dann trotzdem mal in dieser Live-Schaltung typischerweise ab 22 Uhr live bei Wind und Wetter vor dem Kanzleramt da drin sitzen Sie gerade. Da werden die Themen zumindest mal genannt.
Und das will man nicht als CDU dass es wenn auch nur die überschrift mal kurz genannt wird aber diese Federführung fällt erst seit dem Ministerium vollständig zu nachdem mit,
Peter Altmaier im Wirtschaftsministerium die Eckpunkte geklärt wurden.
Und solange die Eckpunkte nicht geklärt wurden kann er noch nicht das Gesetz ausarbeiten.
Also immer wenn Peter Altmaier morgens aufwacht und sieht im Kalender heute Termin mit Hubertus Heil zum Thema Eckpunkte Lieferketten Gesetz kommt ihm irgendwas dazwischen verschiebt sich das doch wieder weil sich irgendwas mit Coruna Nothilfe und ein bisschen verzögert.
Coruna ist wirklich toll. Es ist die Ausrede für alles hatte Harald Schmidt kürzlich auch gesagt dass er Coruña eigentlich liebt weil man alles auf Coruna schieben kann.
Große Dankbarkeit.
Es ist ganz ganz großartig Kona hilft hier Peter Altmaier.
Gut so jetzt kommen wir zu den ganz seltenen wenigen Clips aus der CDU zum Thema von Altmaier nichts zum Thema Lieferketten Gesetze also falls jemand etwas findet schickt mir gerne.
So jetzt kommen wir zu den ganz seltenen wenigen Clips aus der CDU zum Thema von Altmaier nichts.
Es interessiert mich schon ob Peter Altmaier mal irgendwann etwas dazu gesagt hat.
Er hat doch damals bei Jung und live bei Thilo im Gespräch gesagt angesprochen auf China und sonstige Verhältnisse dass sie ihm immer die Menschenrechte sehr wichtig sind dass er das natürlich unter vier Augen anspricht.
Aber das ist ja schön man blickt ja jetzt Wir kommen ja heute noch zu China.
Wir blicken ja auf China und die Springer-Presse ist ja sehr dabei uns ständig zu erzählen wie schlimm eigentlich China ist und wie sehr wir bald von denen okkupiert sein werden,
ohne China zu marginalisieren finde ich doch sehr interessant dass man da gerne auf jede Menschenrechtsverletzung extremst hinweist während solche Dinge,
nicht in der Springer-Presse zum großen Thema werden denn hier werden durch uns permanent Menschenrechte verletzt.
Springer möchte es nicht thematisieren. Schon allein weil es keine Vorlage Anlässe gibt.
Dadurch dass die CDU dazu nicht sagt Wir haben von Peter Altmaier als Wirtschaftsminister nichts zum Thema Lieferketten jemals gehört Wir haben von Horst Seehofer als Bauminister niemals etwas zum Thema Bauen und Mieten und so gehört es ist einfach da wird einfach geschwiegen.
Es gibt allerdings trotzdem einen in der CDU. Matthias Zimmer der Stand im Bundestag im Februar eine der ganz wenigen Ausschnitte die CDU äußert sich mal zum Thema Lieferketten Gesetz ist mehr so humoristisch eingestreut.
Der erste Word Beitrag von ihm ist dieser.
Besonders beeindruckt hat mich damals die Idee dass man die Ethik der Nächstenliebe durch eine Ethik der fernsten Liebe ersetzen müsse die eine ferne Verantwortung beinhalte.
Das klingt ja gut oder.
Schön Ich finde man hört ja die CDU durchaus manchmal über so etwas wie die verketten Gesetz sprechen und zwar bei Kirchentagen.
Da haben Sie dann immer so ein paar Abgeordnete die sagen nicht Lieferketten Gesetz sondern die sagen dass man Mitmenschlichkeit doch für alle gelten lassen muss und dass das auch christliche Nächstenliebe und so weiter und so fort ist.
Na
Ja ich verstehe auch dass er total fasziniert ist von Nächstenliebe. Alles klar.
Das wäre doch eigentlich so ein schöner neuer Buchtitel für Markus Gabriel Nächstenliebe und fernsten Liebe. Wenn die das vielleicht auch gemeinsam schreiben können.
Da hat er so einen Dualismus da kann er über die Gewichtung des Dualismus schreiben wie es jetzt umschlägt.
Herr Professor Herr Zimmerer Herr Zimmer.
Wir lesen es dann im Salon.
Matthias Zimmer hat noch ein super.
Gewinne ohne Gewissen das geht nicht.
Gewissen das geht nicht.
Nein das gibt's ja im Kapitalismus im Prinzip gar nicht.
Nur mit Gewissen. Aber.
Ich habe gesagt Wir haben also noch nicht noch keinen Anlass ein solches Gesetz zu beschließen denn wir haben uns im Koalitionsvertrag verpflichtet zunächst einmal die überprüfung des Nationalen Aktionsplan abzuwarten wenn.
Die.
Im Koalitionsvertrag steht auch Stufe eins Freiwilligkeit kommen wir erst mal abwarten.
Europäische.
Sich dabei herausstellt dass die freiwillige Verpflichtung der Unternehmen nicht ausreichend ist. Dann müssen wir tätig werden nicht nur als nationaler Gesetzgeber sondern auch im europäischen Rahmen. Und da glaubt.
Die europäische Lösung. Wer mag sie nicht durchdiskutiert Was bedeutet die europäische Lösung.
Sie nicht.
Universal Ausrede. Das müssen irgendwann in Brüssel klären.
Ganz großartig von der CDU.
Ich dass die deutsche Ratspräsidentschaft im zweiten Halbjahr eine gute Chance ist auch dieses Thema anzustoßen.
Das Thema anstoßen. Dann können wir in 20 Jahren wieder hier sitzen dann kannst du nochmal die Kofi Annan Rede uns vorspielen und dann möglicherweise ist das schon mal ein Anstoß dann gekommen.
Nochmal angestoßen.
Wir wissen ja wir sind jetzt Ratspräsident in Europa allerdings wurde diese Woche geplante EU-Gipfel verschoben auf nächste Woche warum wegen Kona Charles Michel in Quarantäne weil man kann ja nicht über Video einzuschalten.
Es muss alles verschoben werden.
Naja Mützenich der Fraktionsvorsitzender der SPD im September jetzt gerade Februar sind viele Monate ins Land wir haben sie gerade schon ein bisschen begutachtet.
Im September sagt Mützenich und das ist dann wieder diese Veranstaltung die erstens niemand besucht hat wegen Coruña da müssen ja alle Plätze frei bleiben und die auf YouTube dann 300 Leute sagen,
obwohl der Minister und der Fraktionschef da war hat sich niemand dafür interessiert aber Mützenich wurde ein bisschen deutlich.
Wir hätten es gerne bereits in der letzten Legislaturperiode auf den Weg gebracht.
Da hatten wir es im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart und,
ich hatte Gelegenheit mit Kolleginnen und Kollegen immer mal wieder auch mit der Unionsfraktion die ja bereits damals unser Koalitionspartner war,
das eine oder andere zu besprechen und habe auf den letzten Metern gemerkt wie das wiederholt sich aus meiner Sicht heute also täglich grüßt das Murmeltier.
Am Ende einer Legislaturperiode versuchen noch einige wieder dieses Gesetz zu hintertreibt.
Naja stimmt das ein bisschen ausführen können finde ich die Mechanik aufzeigen wie es genau funktioniert. Hubertus Heil jedenfalls in Engels Geduld steht da bei gleicher Veranstaltung im September da und wird auf den Wirtschaftsminister angesprochen.
Eine Frage von Dieter Keller von der Südwest Presse Warum ist Wirtschaftsminister Peter Altmaier nicht bei der PK.
Wie wollen Sie ein Gesetz ohne ihn machen und durch das Kabinett bringen. Wie wollen Sie ihn einfangen.
Erstens geht es darum dass von dieser Regierung konstruktiv zusammenarbeiten verschiedene fachliche sichten und Positionen einbauen.
Und das betrifft den Bundeswirtschaftsministers betrifft aber auch den Außenminister und viele Ressorts die beteiligt sein werden.
Dass der Wirtschaftsminister der Entwicklungsminister und der Arbeitsminister nicht immer gleich eine Pressekonferenz zusammen machen ist kein Zeichen dafür dass wir nicht gemeinsam zu Lösungen kommen können.
Es gibt unterschiedliche äußerungen dazu und auch Interessen zu vertreten.
Aber unsere gemeinsame Geschäftsgrundlage und ich glaube das wird Peter Altmaier genauso wenig in Frage stellen wie wir das beide tun. Ist der Koalitionsvertrag.
Mit anderen Worten Peter Altmaier ist das scheißegal was die da machen und er möchte auf keinen Fall da irgendeinen Schritt in diese Richtung tun.
Man fragt sich warum was passiert im Hintergrund dass man das so vehement verhindert denn man könnte auch sagen Naja würde jetzt verketten Gesetz kommen,
würde man sich eigentlich mal so in der Großen Koalition gegenseitig auf die Schulter klopfen können könnte auch ein bisschen den Grünen,
den Linken abnehmen.
Guckt mal hier wir haben es auf den Weg gebracht hat zwar ein bisschen gedauert aber das finden wir jetzt ganz toll ist jetzt gerade ein Thema das gut läuft welche Kräfte walten da im Hintergrund die dafür sorgen dass man auf keinen Fall dieses Gesetz haben will.
Das kann ja nicht einfach nur mit so einem Argument zu erklären sein naja sind alle ein bisschen korrupt und haben irgendwie Geld bekommen.
Tatsächlich ein ganz großes Mysterium aus der CDU wissen wir alle ließen sich so ganz rauszuhalten.
Da kommt jetzt auch Brinkhaus als Fraktionschef der jetzt wieder sagt jetzt erst mal die Wirtschaft in Ruhe lassen Wirtschafts und Pulse setzen bloß nicht einmischen.
Ich frage mich auch wir haben hier auf der einen Seite auf Konsumenten sei der angeblich zu überprüfen aber auch wenn es nur Nuancen da ist eine große Welle.
Leute wollen wissen was sie essen wo kommt das her und so weiter. Wenn man den erklärten die Jeans kostet zwei Euro mehr für dich wenn die Lieferketten nicht darauf verzichten wollen die Zwischenhändler dann zwei Euro mehr Wirths Bist du bereit aber dann,
mit dem Bewusstsein und das kann man ja auch zur Marke machen an den grünen Knopf einfach unten einen Hosenbund ran und dann sieht okay da kümmert sich.
Das könne man ja durchaus zum Thema machen und ich finde es gibt eben auch diese politische Dimension.
Wir haben jetzt fünf Jahre Wir schaffen das. Fluchtursachen bekämpfen und so weiter.
Dieses ganze Warum gibt es keinen wirklich programmatischen Unterbau um wirklich zu sagen Wir schaffen das.
Dann gibt's natürlich nur diese Dimension dass man sagt Leute wir haben ja keine.
Es droht keine Gefahr durch die muslimische übernahme des Abendlandes.
Vielmehr ist unser Projekt die christlichen Werte die uns in Europa so weit gebracht haben jetzt auch in die Herkunftsländer unserer Klamotten zu bringen könne man ja auch mal unter Bewahrung der Schöpfung und so weiter Kinderarbeit thematisieren,
wird nicht aufgegriffen. Es ist mir auch schleierhaft.
Die CDU hat hier mal wieder jemanden in den Bundestag geschickt Stefan Hoff und das ist so absurd wie die großen gesellschaftlichen fast religiösen Dimension mal dargestellt haben.
Und jetzt kämpft Stefan Rosenhof heldenhaft für wen wissen wir immer noch nicht so genau. Wo ist der Antrieb.
Denn es gibt ja kein Dogma jetzt also wir haben ja manchmal bei den Konservativen gewisse Dogmen wenn es um Fragen der Abtreibung zum Beispiel geht wo.
Genau.
Man es durchaus finden kann dass jetzt ein Unionsabgeordnete aus seinem christlichen Weltbild heraus argumentiert.
Da kann man durchaus mal rote Linien ziehen.
Das ist meine rote Linie und das kann ich nicht machen.
Solch einen Fall haben wir hierher eigentlich nicht.
Es müsste eigentlich höchstens im Sinne von Glaubensfragen sein.
Es ist ganz merkwürdig weshalb wir uns nicht darüber wundern dass wir von der CDU im Bundestag als Gegenargumente gegen dieses Gesetz nur das sie angeboten bekommen.
Hören Sie zu. Im Bundesarbeitsministerium ist heute eine Person maßgeblich an der Umsetzung des Nationalen Aktionsplans beteiligt die kurz zuvor noch Angestellte einer NGO war.
Die kurz zuvor noch.
In dieser früheren Funktion hat sie in dieser frühen Funktion hat sie maßgeblich an einer Studie zu einem Lieferketten Gesetz mitgewirkt und wenn das nicht genug ist.
In dieser früheren Funktion hat sie sich in dieser frühen Funktion hat sie maßgeblich an einer Studie zu Anneliese.
In dieser früheren Funktion hat sie in dieser Funktion kann sie maßgeblich an einer Studie zu einem und wenn das nicht genug ist.
Die Studie hat gleich auch noch einen Gesetzentwurf mitgeliefert.
Die Studie hat gleich auch noch eingesetzt.
Gesetzt.
Ich sag an der Stelle nur bei einem Wirtschaftsvertreter wären die Grünen sofort hier aufgesprungen.
Ich sage.
Diese Art des Laga Denkens ist so unterkomplex dass man sich fragte Klamauk.
Er hat jetzt gesagt da ist im Ministerium eine die hat auch schon mal bei einer NGO gearbeitet.
Das geht ja nicht. Wenn dann geht es vielleicht eine CDU dass man die Seiten wechselt und einen Gesetzentwurf gleich mitbringt aber nicht auf der Seite.
Er hat noch einen zweiten Wortspenden Angebot. Es wird ein bisschen politischer aber nicht besser.
Auch wir von der Unionsfraktion haben einen klaren Wunsch die Menschenrechtslage und Umweltsituation in Schwellen und Entwicklungsländern zu verbessern.
Ein Lieferketten gesetzt wie sie sich vorstellen wird das Gegenteil von dem bewirken.
Es wird unsere unseren deutschen Mittelstand verunsichern.
In Schwellen und Entwicklungsländern zu investieren wird unsere Unternehmer vermehrt davon abhalten Zwischenprodukte aus diesen Ländern zu beziehen.
Und es wird in den Ländern ausgerechnet jene Unternehmen etwa aus China oder Russland stärken die in ihren Handels und Investitions Beziehungen weit niedrigere Standards ansetzen.
Das kann man immer sagen aber es ist zumindest mein Argument Nur kann man genau dieses nehmen und dem widersprechen.
Dann muss man aber auch sagen Der Mittelstand in Deutschland da muss man es aber auch mal wirklich positiv formulieren und sagen Der Mittelstand in Deutschland ist angewiesen auf Menschenrechtsverletzungen,
und nicht wie hier sein Kollege im Februar erzählt was war das. Gewinne aber nicht ohne Gewissen.
Ich.
Gewinne nicht aber.
Dann muss man das einfach weglassen dann muss man sagen Wir machen das hier so Wir sind da im knallharten Kampf und sobald das noch irgendjemand billiger und schlechter handhabt dann müssen wir da mitziehen.
Dann kann man sagen Dann kann man sich von jedem christlichen Weltbild und auch von einer europäischen Idee vollkommen verabschieden @Scaver machen.
Aber dann sollte man es doch bitte so positiv formulieren.
Das muss man dann schon auch ehrlich sagen. Nur gibt es hier tatsächlich eine ökonomische Logik die versteht man auch die muss argumentiert werden doch die,
Logik von der CDU. Wir müssen uns mal lieber nicht eine Einmischung,
nachsteuern. Was da passiert. Vielleicht gibt es ja auch wenn der Gerd Müller sagt die Jeans würde nur zwei Euro teurer das finden wir so unglaubwürdig dass wir vermuten da steckt noch was dahinter.
Wenn ja Gerd Müller sagt die Jeans würde nur zwei Euro teurer. Das finden wir so unglaubwürdig dass wir vermuten da steckt noch was dahinter.
Und mit dem wollen wir uns erst gar nicht befassen weil das ist so dass wir einfach prinzipiell ab.
Mit dem wollen wir uns das gar nicht so das Leben. Prinzipiell ja.
Na ja es gibt jedenfalls bei den Grünen auch große Anstrengungen für dieses Gesetz deswegen ist Schwarz-Grün gar nicht so schlecht.
Naja es gibt jedenfalls bei den Grünen auch große Anstrengungen für dieses Gesetz deswegen ist Schwarz-Grün gar nicht so schlecht.
Es gibt ja der.
Es gibt ja aber du glaubst doch nicht dass das dann durchkommt.
Gerth der Georg Streiter der für die CDU lange BBK gemacht hat hat bei Lanz letztens dieses Argument gemacht CDU und Grüne passen eigentlich ganz gut zusammen weil die einen sagen halt Umweltpolitik Klima keine Ahnung die Bewahrung der Schöpfung.
Und da gibt's eine große Passgenauigkeit Es geht nur um die Anfrage die Ansprache an den Wähler die einsprechen hat die 70jährigen an Bewahrung der Schöpfung und die anderen sagen Umweltschutz für die Kinder und die Grünen.
Aber eigentlich passt das ganz gut und wenn die zusammen eine große Erzählung herstellen hinsichtlich zwei Euro mehr in Jeans und haben die Welt gerettet.
Das produziert ja auch politische Unterstützung weil man es richtig macht.
Es ist ja wirklich ein Rätsel warum man diesen Elfmeter nicht einfach mal verwandelt weil wenn es am Ende wirklich nur um zwei Euro geht kann man es ja machen.
Und dahinter allerdings es tatsächlich eine Logik die die Grünen jetzt auch schon mal vorbereiten.
Auch hinsichtlich Wir kennen das ja wir müssen den Klimawandel jetzt ernst nehmen um den Wohlstand zu erhalten damit nicht alle ökologischen Gewinne Tesla und so weiter also ökologisch alle Gewinne die den schifft mitmachen nicht in Deutschland landen.
Und da ist Uwe kecker Riz der Ansprechpartner bei den Grünen der hier dieses Argument von Stefan Rosenhof.
Das verunsichert ja den Mittelstand genau umdreht.
Viele deutsche Unternehmen haben bereits selbst hohe soziale ökologische Standards gesetzt.
Und deshalb fordern sie zu Recht von der Regierung,
dass diese einen verbindlichen Rechtsrahmen setzt damit weitgehend ein level playing field also annähernd gleiche Produktions und Marktbedingungen für alle Unternehmen geschaffen werden.
Dafür ist Regierung auch da.
Das ist eigentlich das kapitalistische Argument,
gestalten hier einen Markt auf dem kann man sich aber nicht verlassen.
Man darf nicht rechts überholen und da die Nachhaltigkeit denn diese kleinen Gewinne durch externe Kosten und so weiter mit sich bringt das ist eigentlich das Argument kann sich.
Das ist das marktwirtschaftliche Argument das davon ausgeht dass man so einen Wettbewerb schaffen kann.
Dadurch dass man eben ein Reglement schafft das dafür sorgt dass diese kleinen Unternehmen sich nicht nur daran halten sondern auch die ganz ganz großen Konzerne wenngleich hier von kleinen Unternehmen reden doch.
Oder.
Auch.
Schon meinen Mittelstand ist ja jetzt nicht.
Umgedreht. Dass sich die Großen daran halten und die Kleinen müssen was sie nicht schaffen was wieder gut ist für die Großen das kennen wir auch von Mark Zuckerberg der so viel Regulierung will und so weiter.
Da gibt's ja auch gleich noch eine schöne Pointe aber es gibt hier sehr viele Argumente die eigentlich bei der CDU sehr leicht verständlich sein müssten und die auch anschlussfähig sein müssten.
Hubertus Heil hat es auch nochmal betont.
Wir müssen auch über fairen Wettbewerb reden. Es kann nicht sein dass die Unternehmen die sich kümmern die sich um ihre Sorgfaltspflichten Mühen und das sind inzwischen viele Unternehmen aber auch recht bekannte Marken wie inzwischen zum Beispiel Ritter Sport und Schiavo.
Es kann nicht sein dass die Unternehmen die sich kümmern ihre Sorgfaltspflichten.
Das sind inzwischen viele Unternehmen aber auch bekannte Marken die inzwischen zum Beispiel Wiederspruch.
Im Wettbewerb gegenüber denjenigen die sich nicht kümmern benachteiligt.
Qualitätsstandards können auch einen Markt Schließmechanismus sein der denjenigen denen die Qualität der Standards einhalten und die breit geteilt werden die breite Unterstützung erfahren denen zugute kommt weil dann einfach die Newcomer von unten es ein bisschen schwerer haben.
Bisher hat die CDU gehört unter der Maxime ja gut keiner Wollen Sie vielleicht ein bisschen irgendwie Angst wir haben uns nicht getraut zu sagen Die sind einfach doof die wissen einfach nicht worum es geht Die ist einfach bescheuert das können wir natürlich bei der AfD machen.
Weshalb wir jetzt mal ein Gegenargument im Bundestag hören von Markus Homeyer von dem wir wirklich sagen können Das ist einfach doof und es wird auch danach nochmal inhaltlich aufgelöst ist ganz interessant aber diese Haltung hier dieser verdorrte.
Die deutsche Wirtschaft pfeift aus dem letzten Loch.
Und jetzt fordert der Kollege Kicker Ritts von den Grünen auch noch ein Lieferketten Gesetz Lieferketten Gesetz.
Was heißt es eigentlich in der Theorie würde ein Lieferketten Gesetz deutsche Unternehmen dazu verpflichten,
lückenlos alle Bestandteile ihrer Lieferkette zu kontrollieren und auf die Einhaltung von ökologischen und sozialen Standards zu prüfen.
Was heißt das aber in der Praxis.
Nehmen Sie einen beliebigen Hersteller zum Beispiel Daimler. Laut BDI haben Hersteller wie Daimler bis zu 100 000 Zulieferer.
So nehmen Sie einen beliebigen Hersteller wie Daimler sagt Na ja nur Daimler.
Das sind ja diese ganz kleinen mittelständischen Unternehmen.
Da hat er sich wirklich vertan.
Daimler macht das.
Daimler schon das haben wir ja von Frank Schwabe der auf von der SPD hier mal anfordert.
Wir haben Unternehmen zahlreiche Unternehmen und ich weiß gar nicht wie sie auf die Idee kommen hier Daimler zu zitieren weil Daimler genau eines der Unternehmen ist das sich für eine gesetzliche Regelung einsetzen sollte einfach mal informieren.
Unternehmen.
Zitiert war eines Unternehmen für ein Problem.
Da ist man auf der richtigen Seite.
So abscheulich blöde. Was da von sich gegeben wird dass man dann noch nicht einmal eine Pointe die man setzen will die ohnehin schon idiotisch ist.
So
Idiotisch,
funktioniert dass man.
Man sagt ja wie sollen die da 10 000 Teile nachprüfen dass man diese Pointe dann auch noch so versemmelt indem man ein Unternehmen raus fischt das exakt das schon macht.
Daimler die haben.
Aber wir sehen hier eigentlich so einen fließenden übergang. Das war jetzt mächtig blöde aber wir haben ja auch von der CDU extrem blödes gehört.
Und wenn ich jetzt an die Anhörungen denke im Kongress wie die Republikaner sich da verhalten haben gegenüber der Silicon Valley,
dann ist da doch eine gewisse Parallele zu sehen und man könnte sich jetzt vorstellen wenn es ganz dumm kommt in welche Richtung das noch gehen könnte.
Denn wenn man sich das Personal jetzt bei der CDU ansieht dann muss man ja sagen da ist eigentlich noch gut dass wir eine Rentner Republik haben es könnte ja eher noch schlimmer werden was da kommt nichts Gutes nach.
Typen wie Philipp am Tor haben Null Ahnung davon. 0.
Oder wie heißt er der früh alt gewordene Junge Unions Mensch.
Mißfelder ist jetzt der neue.
Mit Tillman Kuban. Mit solchen Leuten dann kannst du auch gleich die Republikaner bitten hier die Politik zu übernehmen das wäre kein Unterschied.
Tillman Kuban. Null Ahnung davon.
Tillman Kuban Philipp Ganz intuitiv in die Sache rein.
Ein Gesetz das die Wirtschaft irgendwie war. Nee nee jetzt habe ich das Problem Wir können ja Pi mal Daumen durchrechnen.
Würde mich interessieren ob das mir immer gemacht hat aber wir haben es gehört.
Mercedes hat Zehntausende Zulieferer.
Die einen sagen intuitiv die wollen das nicht weil es zu viel arbeiten kann sagt der Schwabe fragen uns wann das Gesetz endlich kommt.
Wenn die zehntausend Zulieferer haben wir wissen Die brauchen diese ganzen Erze und so weiter weil die haben ja viel Technik im Auto die brauchen das Metall Zeug.
Da ist wirklich viel Strom erforderlich.
Dann haben Sie noch irgendwie Ledersitze und der ganze Kram.
Wenn man jetzt in 140 000 Euro S-Klasse mal durchkalkuliert haben will legen überall diese 2 Euro diesen einen Cent noch obendrauf.
Dann kostet sie 5000 Euro mehr und entspricht damit Standards die wenn sie für alle gelten für die anderen die neu in den Markt kommen ganz schwer zu machen sind weil so Lieferketten aufzubauen ist noch schwieriger als eine S-Klasse zu designen.
Das war ja immer bei Apple das alle mal alle dachten Steve Jobs so der geniale Typ der baut so das Gerät.
Und Tim Cook im Hintergrund hat dann immer die Lieferketten mit eine Million Menschen die in China zusammenbauen damit es dann sofort ab Verkaufstag so lange geheim gehalten und plötzlich waren 100 Millionen iPhones da die sofort verkauft werden konnten.
Und dann hat ja Tim Cook Apple übernommen und alle dachten So jetzt ist die Genialität verschwunden.
Dabei kam die Genialität erst rein dass man nämlich das Gerät komplett auf die Produktion hin optimiert hat und sagt Wir machen hier Massenproduktion.
Sie ist nicht der einzelne Prototyp den Steve Jobs entwickelt hat sondern dass tatsächlich das fertige Gerät in der Hand des Kunden und es kommt auf diese Lieferketten an und die müssen designt werden.
Es interessiert zwar niemanden und da kann man auch kein Werbefilm machen aber so macht mans.
Und genau das gleiche Problem hat ja Mercedes auch denen geht es ja nicht darum super geiles Auto zu bauen das sich besser fährt als eine S-Klasse sondern davon 3000 pro Monat zu verkaufen für 150 000 Euro.
Das ist ja das Ziel und das schaffen die natürlich viel besser wenn sie den Markt einfach komplett unter Kontrolle haben indem sie einfach jeden raus klagen können der da versucht über kleine Preisvorteile.
Oder sonstiges Umgehungen von solchen Standards dann irgendwie auf sich auf den Markt breitzumachen.
In der Hinsicht ist dieses Mercedes Beispiel das müsste man eigentlich viel mehr ausarbeiten.
Hubertus Heil müsste eigentlich nicht mit Gerd Müller eine Pressekonferenz machen sondern mit den ganzen Dax Leuten denen ihr Markt so wichtig ist und um so mehr Produktion da drin ist umso wichtiger wären dann auch die Argumente Wohlstand Erhaltung und so weiter.
Wenn man die deutschen Autobauer schützen will dann macht man das am besten indem man Standards einführt da wo sich alle auf dem Markt breitmachen und da will man dann eben nicht mehr diesen Frühkapitalismus sondern da will man es geregelt haben und nachvollziehbar und dann hat man da auch Vorteile die man nutzen kann.
Denn das ist ein wenig Augenwischerei zu sagen Es ist ja alles dereguliert.
Man hat jetzt durch den Neoliberalismus eine große Deregulierung geschaffen.
Naja diese nicht Regulative die dafür sorgen dass wir eben nicht soziale haben nicht ökologisch haben sind ja auch wieder Regeln in anderer Art Regeln die dafür sorgen dass das eben geht.
Und jetzt kann man das Ganze umdrehen was man bekommt nicht in dem Sinne mehr Regeln sondern bekommt andere Regeln und die kann man auch anders wieder für sich ausnutzen und wir wissen dass Konzerne mit großen Anwaltskanzleien im Hintergrund,
haben da jede Möglichkeit bei jedem neuen Regeln auch wieder versuchen.
Sie können versuchen Markt Vorteile zu erlangen dadurch dass sie Leute raus klagen oder so.
Ich verstehe auch gar nicht dass es offenbar,
nur noch anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären ist wie du sagst es ist so ein intuitiver Zugang ist ach wir sind ja gegen Regulierungen und deswegen müssen wir jetzt auch dagegen sein.
Man erkennt gar nicht dass man selbstverständlich auch das was man jetzt deregulierten Neoliberalismus nennt auch reguliert hat.
Das ist ja ein großes auch im übrigen globales System von Gesetzen auch das Unternehmen Staaten verklagen können wenn dies und das nicht eingehalten werden wenn da irgendjemand mit Subventionen übervorteilt wird. Das sind ja alles regeln.
Da ist ja nichts Regel los. Es gibt da keine herrschaftsfreien Raum kein Raum wie die Piraten auf dem Meer können die sich verhalten sondern die halten sich schon an Regeln und da sind immer Anwaltskanzleien alles involviert.
Die Frage ist nur Wie verändert man die Regeln.
Der ganze Erfolg von Tesla ist ja nicht weil er sich auf dem freien Markt zu teuren Batterien und so weiter sondern weil er diese Regulierung mitgestaltet hat die ihm die Vorteile brachte bis hin zu diese Subvention gibts jetzt alle sehen kann man auch überlegen,
wenn ein Lieferketten Gesetz geschrieben wird.
Da stehen natürlich 300 Corporate Loja bei Mercedes stramm und haben endlich mal wieder etwas zu tun.
Wir werden ja im Salon solche Jobs nochmal lesen.
Diese Unternehmens Anwälte haben eigentlich nichts zu tun die ganze Zeit die machen ja wirklich nur Bullshit Job im klassischen Sinne also eine riesige Horde an Services und Dienstleistungen um sie herum,
und für diesen Moment werden sie gebraucht wenn hier einfach mal ein neuer Markt kreiert wird und sei es jetzt neue Menschenrechte und so,
dass man da dann auch nicht eingreift und es zu seinem Sinne umbaut.
Die CDU setzt hier eigentlich aufs falsche Pferd.
Die haben zu wenig Kontakt zu der Wirtschaft die müssen sich eigentlich mal mit ihnen ins Benehmen setzen und da hören was da gesagt wird.
Hubertus Heil Das ist ja der Einzige von dem wir hier hören hat im Juli nochmal die drei Säulen die ihm wichtig sind für das Verketten Gesetz vorgestellt.
Lieferketten Gesetz muss aus unserer überzeugung drei Ziele verfolgen Erstens muss die Rechte der Menschen schützen die Waren für den deutschen Markt produzieren.
Erstens muss die Rechte der Menschen schützen die Waren für den deutschen Markt müssen wir in Deutschland sicher sein können dass die Produkte im Einkaufswagen nicht in Sklavenarbeit oder Kinderarbeit.
Wir müssen hier in Deutschland sicher sein können dass die Produkte in Einkaufswagen nicht in Sklavenarbeit oder in Kinderarbeit hergestellt werden,
sondern einem Beispiel zu sagen Wir können nicht nur einfach wünschen dass die Schokolade die in Deutschland konsumiert wird fair produziert ist Wir müssen sichergehen dass das so ist wenn wir erleben dass gerade in diesem Bereich beispielsweise Kinderarbeit ein großes Problem ist.
Sondern einem Beispiel zu sagen Wir können nicht nur einfach wünschen dass die Schokolade die in Deutschland konsumiert wird produziert.
Wir müssen sichergehen dass das so ist. Wir erleben das gerade in diesem Bereich.
So dass es diese moralische Dimension. Das ist aber nur die eine Säule ist nur die erste Menschenrechte darüber könnte man eine tolle Unterstützer der Kampagne fahren mit der deutschen Bevölkerung weil der ist ja so etwas wichtig.
Die anderen Punkte muss die CDU mal überlegen ob sie nicht doch noch mal die Seite wechseln will.
Wir müssen wenn wir jetzt den Weg Richtung Elektromobilität neue Antriebe gehen sicherstellen dass die Rohstoffe wie beispielsweise Coltan und andere seltene Erden fair gefördert werden und nicht unter unmenschlichen.
Heißt hier nicht nur gegenüber denjenigen die tatsächlich fair zwischen den Unternehmen fair muss es zugehen damit nicht einfach nur das Recht des Stärkeren gilt.
Ich hatte auf der Hinfahrt hier einen Podcast gehört da wurde Tobias Lüdtke interviewt der,
Gründer von Schopfe dem jetzt teuersten Unternehmen Kanadas,
heißt das Unternehmen das für all die kleineren Händler aber auch Influencer diese Shops zur Verfügung stellt und er wurde ganz kurz angesprochen auf Elon Musk mit dem er auch mal Kontakt hatte hin und wieder.
Auf die deutsche Autoindustrie und dann sagte er Ja man glaubt ja gar nicht wenn man als Deutscher jetzt seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr in Deutschland vorwiegend lebt sondern in Kanada.
Welch hohes Ansehen die Autoindustrie die deutsche genießt und dass er das doch,
mit Tränen in den Augen eigentlich beobachtet wie sehr die deutsche Autoindustrie das verschlafen hat mit der E-Mobilität dass sie angetrieben wird nun von Elon Musk und anderen.
Das ist sicherlich noch nicht zu spät ist aber er sagt Das ist das Problem dass diese Bumann Generation einfach nicht mehr diese Flexibilität mitbringen möchte um darüber nachzudenken wie könnte es anders sein denn,
fest steht ja wir haben ja die beste Ausgangslage für Autoproduktion Ich bin sehr skeptisch was dieser E-Mobilität anbelangt in Form von.
Damit wird unser klimaneutral. Aber jetzt mal als Maack Markt Eroberung haben wir da die beste Ausgangslage eigentlich gehabt also das in den Sand zu setzen.
Und da hat man ja schon einiges getan. Das ist ja richtig schwierig erst mal dass man das verschlafen hat und ähnlich verhält sich jetzt oder vielleicht dann noch lahmer weil sich die Politik,
Wir haben es mit Menschenrechten als die große Erzählung und dann fair geschrieben.
Wir haben es mit Menschenrechten als die große Erzählung Fähr.
Menschlichen Arbeitsbedingungen. Zweitens Wir wollen mit dem Gesetz dafür sorgen dass deutsche Unternehmen rechts und Handlungs Sicherheit haben und Rechtssicherheit auch bekommen insbesondere wenn sie in Ländern mit unsicherer Menschenrechtslage.
Zweitens Wir wollen mit dem Gesetz dafür sorgen dass deutsche Unternehmen Rechts und Planungssicherheit und Rechtssicherheit bekommen insbesondere wenn sie in Ländern mit unsicherer Menschenrechtslage.
Zweitens Wir wollen mit dem Gesetz dafür sorgen dass deutsche Unternehmen rechts und Handlungsebene Rechtssicherheit bekommen insbesondere wenn sie in Ländern mit unsicherer.
Diese Planungssicherheit.
Planungssicherheit. Da ist beispielsweise Tesla jetzt wirklich davongefahren weil Tesla hat diese Batterie Produktion herausgeholt aus diesen Ländern und macht das hier,
und muss sich mit diesen ganzen Klimafragen nicht beschäftigen sondern auch mit vielen von diesen wie geht er denn in diesen Ländern um weil jeder sieht jetzt auf YouTube diese Videos wie sie über Brandenburg mit der Drohne fliegen um den Fortschritt zu dokumentieren und nicht irgendwo in Bangladesch oder.
Weshalb auch Investoren ganz verunsichert sind.
Was macht man jetzt eigentlich mit Blick auf die E-Mobilität mit Lithium wird sich das durchsetzen wird man eine alternative Technik haben,
viele Investoren und Spekulanten haben ja jetzt keine Probleme damit in etwas zu investieren wo man weiß da sind die Kinder da unten und versuchen,
die Ressource zu gewinnen.
Das ist nicht das Problem für diese Leute aber die sagen sich,
Wenn jetzt so große Unternehmen plötzlich anfangen und das selbst als Problem zu erkennen und sagen Wir wollen das aber eigentlich nicht wir wollen nicht dass unsere Firma mit irgendwelchen Minen und den Kindern die dort arbeiten in Verbindung gebracht wird.
Dann hätte ja unser Investment ein großes Problem.
Dann würde nämlich diese Lithium Gewinnung plötzlich nicht irgendwann den Börsenboom ergeben.
Deswegen ist man da sehr sehr zögerlich war im Handelsblatt ein schöner Artikel darüber dass man momentan irgendwie sieht ja eigentlich müsste er das ganz große Ding sein.
Kann auch sein dass es in fünf Jahren so ist. Aber gerade jetzt ist man noch sehr sehr skeptisch ob man da nicht in einen Markt investiert der am Ende doch nicht lukrativ ist weil Unternehmen sich anders ausrüsten ökologischer.
Das Problem dass in Deutschland so eine doch ganz raffinierte Batterie Forschung hinsichtlich Mahle Stoffe durch,
alle setzen eigentlich auf den großen Technologiesprung in denen man dann rein investiert und jedes Jahr dass man weiter wartet verpasst man eigentlich diesen Silizium Zug der ja rollt und auf dem auch Tesla fährt und so weiter.
Und da der VW dann auch gesagt Wir produzieren nicht selbst produzieren ich selbst und wir kaufen das zu und da müssen Sie jetzt abhängig von der Verfügbarkeit und so weiter.
Als Tesla als großer Einkäufer natürlich mit ein paar Vorteilen ausgestattet und Hubertus Heil hat hier noch diesen dritten Punkt und das ist so der größte Widerspruch zur CDU da will die CDU nicht mitmachen.
Drittens Wir müssen dafür sorgen dass es ein wirkungsvolles Gesetz ist. Deshalb brauche es eine Durchsetzung Mechanismus.
Wir wollen kein Alibi Gesetz und deshalb geht es auch um zivilrechtliche Haftung.
Zivilrechtlich Verhaftung. Dass man sagt Niemand muss ins Gefängnis. Aber es könnte Geld kosten.
Das ist ein Problem weil das Geld wird dann auch in Tagessätzen eingerechnet.
Es gibt schon so ein Lieferketten Gesetz für Rohstoffe da geht es um Rohstoffe das ist schon durch den Bundestag durch 50 000 Dollar am Tag.
Nur wenn du das nicht abgestelltes morgen nochmal 50000 zahlen nochmal nochmal bis es da sind wirklich wirkungsmächtig.
Dabei hat man natürlich Angst vor. Aber da bleibt Hubertus Heil ganz streng.
Die Frage von Frank Cappellini Hallo lieber Kollege ist ist die zivilrechtlich einklagbare Haftung Voraussetzung für die Zustimmung der SPD zum Lieferketten Gesetz.
Oder sind sie gedrängelt. Die Verhandlungsposition offenzulegen könnte der Krume Kompromiss auch in der Verdrängung von Bußgeldern liegen wie Teile der Union fordern.
Herr Caplan ist für uns zentral.
Reicht das. Ich glaube sie müssen es nochmal deutlicher sagen statt sie lieber Frank Caplan herzlichen Gruß an den Deutschlandfunk.
Haftung ist für die Sozialdemokratie beim Lieferketten zentral.
Okay haben wir verstanden. Also Haftung ist nur der ganze Sinn dieses Gesetzes wie bei so vielen Gesetzen.
Am Ende muss die Sanktion sein.
Wir haben ja schon mal so ein großes Haftungs Gespenst gehabt bei der Datenschutzgrundverordnung.
Und die ist jetzt seit zwei Jahren in Kraft. Wir haben gesehen wohin es führt.
Niemand wurde jemals wegen seinem Block irgendwie verklagt da muss ja irgendwie 50 000.
Dieses Haftungs Ding da werden sie noch viel dran Knust müssen und da gibt's auch noch Streit Wer muss denn haften für wen gilt denn das Gesetz.
Wir legen Wert darauf dass es nicht um kleine mittelständische Unternehmen gibt ja irgendwo erzielt worden von Verbänden jetzt müsse jeder Handwerker sein Kupferkabel kennen und wissen unter welchen Bedingungen es produziert wird das ausdrücklich nicht. Das wäre unverhältnismäßig.
Erzielt worden und verwenden jetzt müsse jeder Handwerker sein vorbeikamen kennen und wissen welche das sind und was nicht. Das wäre undweil.
Sondern wir reden und das werden wir den Eckpunkten miteinander zu besprechen haben von Unternehmen mit wahrscheinlich ab 500 Beschäftigten in der Zahl dessen was jetzt im Monitoring untersucht wurden reden wir über 7000 deutsche Unternehmen die das ungefähr betrifft.
Viele.
Und ich will nochmal darauf hinweisen dass viele Unternehmen das auch von uns fordern weil sie sich jetzt schon kümmern.
Forderns schon Er möchte dass für alle ab fünf Mitarbeiter die CDU 5.000.
Das hieße Hubertus Heils Planung wären 7000 Unternehmen betroffen. In der CDU bleiben dann nur noch 300 Euro.
Aber das ist der große Streitpunkt da muss sie sich mit Altmaier über diese Haftungsfrage. Und wer haftet und so weiter.
Das wollen wir einmal ausklammern. Wir steigen aus dem Thema aus mit ein bisschen Geplänkel in der Debatte zum Rohstoff Lieferketten Gesetz das es jetzt schon gibt. Diese vier Rohstoffe kann sie nicht auswendig.
Aber es gibt Rohstoffe da hat man sich besonders in der Mine mit Kinderarbeit schmaler Stollen und so weiter. Da hat man sich gekümmert. Und da kommt dieses.
Da kommt die FDP mit Olaf in der BEK nochmal mit diesem Europa Dimension.
Gemeinsame europäische Lösungen sind effizienter und zielführender als 27 nationale Lieferketten Gesetze.
An. Das ist natürlich ein großes Argument diese europäische Lösung deswegen haben wir ja nochmal Hubertus Heil zum Thema erster Aufschlag.
Wenn man etwas nicht will verweist man auf Europa. Europa ist eine der großen Ausreden von Menschen die vieles verhindern wollen entweder mit dem Hinweis dass dieses oder jenes nicht Europa rechtskonform sein.
Oder indem man sagt Ja das ist ja eigentlich eine gute Sache aber das müssen wir ganz europäisch machen sonst haben wir ein Problem mit dem Level Playing Field. Das ist so das Standardargument.
Die FDP ist die erste Partei.
Die FDP ist die erste Partei wenn das europäisch durchgesetzt würde in Brüssel dann zu sagen Da sieht man wieder wie die armen deutschen Unternehmen unter.
Da sieht man wieder.
Dem Joch von Europa zu leiden haben dass uns alles ausgepresst wird wie schon mit der schlimmen EZB die das ganze Geld druckt und und und.
Genau,
entweder soll Europa mal was machen aber wenn sie etwas gemacht hat dann ist es natürlich ganz schlimm das wieder was aus Europa gekommen ist das wir gar nicht wollen.
Diese europäische Dimension wäre Hubertus Heil aber nicht geringschätzen oder runter spielen sondern er will einfach nur in den guten Ablauf bringen.
Diese europäische Dimension wird Hubertus Heil aber nicht geringschätzen oder herunterspielen sondern er will einfach nur den guten Ablauf Lammrücken Interesse an europäischen Regeln.
Wir haben ein Interesse an einer europäischen Regelung und wir sind beide sehr froh dass der Kommissar Reinders angekündigt hat dass die Europäische Union dazu im nächsten Jahr auch Vorschläge machen will.
Wir sind beide sehr froh dass der Reinders angekündigt hat dass die Europäische Union im nächsten Jahr auch vorschweben eine europäische aber keine Schivelbusch keine Ausflüge jetzt mit in Deutschland anderswohin.
So dass der Randers angekündigt wird dass die Europäische Union ja auch vorschrieben eine europäische Regenwassers aber keine Schuhkauf keine Ausrede jetzt mit dem Deutschland das zu tun was notwendig ist anders unwillkürlichen.
Eine europäische Regelung ist aber keine Skiba Verfügung und keine Ausrede jetzt nicht in Deutschland das zu tun was notwendig ist. Andersherum wird ein Schuh draus.
Es gibt europäische Länder wir haben bereits Regelungen und es ist wichtig dass die größte Volkswirtschaft in Europa die im übrigen gerade die europäische Ratspräsidentschaft innehat mit gutem Beispiel vorangeht.
Mit gutem Beispiel vorangehen. Also erst mal eine deutsche Lösung und dann sie europäisieren.
Man muss dazu sagen auch Leute aus seiner Partei beziehen sich selbstverständlich sehr gerne auf Europa zum Klimaschutz beispielsweise geht.
Jeder Politiker macht das eigentlich Finanztransaktionssteuer ein ganz klassisches Beispiel hier und da muss man auch nochmal die Dominanz von Europa klarmachen Deutschland klarmachen in Europa das ist sehr schön wenn man hier das erlebt.
Wenn diese Argumentation kommt ja wenn wir das alleine machen bringt das gar nichts.
Wir sind die Exportweltmeister und wir sind so mächtig.
Wenn es aber dann ein bisschen heikel werden könnte das diese Macht auch Verantwortung bedeutet dann reibt man sich wieder so ein Wir sind halt da eines dieser vielen Mitgliedsstaaten und wir wollen da nicht.
Wir sind ja wir sind ja nur einer unter vielen und zu unbedeutend für jede andere.
Und Gerd Müller möchte es nochmal auf die Spitze treiben. Brauchen ein deutsches Lieferketten Gesetz eine EU-Verordnung und noch etwas Drittes in petto oder müssen wir uns einfach überlegen.
Brauchen ein deutsches Lieferketten Gesetz eine EU-Verordnung.
Noch etwas Drittes in petto oder müssen wir einfach überlegen. Kofi Annan vor mehr als 20 Jahren damit wir jetzt mal zu einem deutschen Gesetz eventuell kommen wenn man Peter Altmaier noch umbringen alten Gerd Müller in Rente.
Kofi Annan vor mehr als 20 Jahren damit wir jetzt mal zu einem deutschen Gesetz eventuell kommen wenn man Peter Altmaier noch umbringt.
Jetzt geht Gerd Müller in Rente und jetzt müssen wir uns überlegen jetzt brauchen wir eigentlich eine neue Politikergeneration die folgendes Projekt in Angriff nimmt.
Brauchen wir eigentlich eine neue Politikergeneration. Folgendes Projekt ein notwendiger Schritt eine neue Welt.
Ein dritter notwendiger Schritt eine neue WTO für freien nicht freien sondern für fairen Welthandel.
Nein nicht für Frieden sondern für fairen.
Neue WTO für fairen Welthandel Ich meine die WTO wurde gerade in Trümmer gelegt.
Interessant.
Donald Trump wird kann man sagen als Antwort auf Trump machen wir mal eine neue WTO und dann haben wir den fairen Handel damit rein.
Ja
ja
Kofi Annans Senne.
Ich finde wir sollten das im Hinterkopf behalten deshalb weil wir zwar bei Trump erlebt haben wie er auf die WTO schlägt aber wir haben ja.
Da kommen wir dann gleich mit China jemanden der nochmal die WTO ganz hochgehalten hat nämlich Präsident Xi Jinping.
Der Kicker. Das müssen wir unbedingt noch kurz behandeln denn es gibt noch so eine wie soll man sagen Nebenfolgen Diskussion roten Faden so ein Strang.
Wir hören noch einmal Markus Meyer aus der AfD.
Verantwortlich für die Verbesserung der Lebensverhältnisse sind Marktöffnung und der Abbau von Handelshemmnissen Direktinvestitionen und technologischer Transfer.
Das ist eine direkte Ansprache an Bangladesch. Ihr braucht kein tolles Gesetz Wir brauchen auch keine tolle eigene Regierung oder sonst irgendwie wie jemand der euch Rechtssicherheit garantiert. Die braucht einfach nur einen funktionierenden freien Markt.
Und darauf gibt natürlich viele Antworten zum Beispiel von Christoph Hoffmann von der FDP.
Der ist ein bisschen Ultra libertär. Die FDP schränkt so ein bisschen ein.
Wir dürfen die Nationalstaaten auch in den Entwicklungsländern nicht aus ihrer Verantwortung entlassen und das ist wichtig.
Wir haben Landwirte zum Beispiel sich aus der Armut befreit indem sie sich zusammengeschlossen haben zu Genossenschaften um ihre Produkte im Angebot zu bündeln und damit Presse bessere Preise zu erzielen.
So war es auch im Markt der verlangt meine Heimat da gibt's die Winzergenossenschaft und das war eine Lösung für die Bauern.
Und genau so wird es im Süden auch laufen.
Für einen genossenschaftlichen Modell hier plädiert was ist hier los Sozialismus etwa.
Genau das ist ja irgendwo anders auf der Welt. Eine Utopie für die anderen.
Oder so ein schöner Winzer verwandt da geht es dann auch noch.
Oder so was genau so romantisch. Eine Küche betreibt obwohl man drei Weinberge hat.
Na ja er stellt ja dieses Modell vor.
Er stellte dieses Modell vor Wir bräuchten ja gar keine Lieferketten besetzt.
Wir bräuchten ja gar kein Lieferketten. Wir bräuchten ja gar keine X kein Export von Standards die eingehalten werden wenn es vor Ort Recht. Standards gäbe.
Wir bräuchten ja gar keine X kein Export von rechts Standards die eingehalten werden wenn es vor Ort rechts Standards gäbe.
Wir kämen nicht auf die Gedanken in Norwegen Lieferketten Gesetz einzuführen weil wir wissen ja die Norweger kennen es schon selber regeln und am Ende kostet das halt mehr die Unternehmen kommen nicht drum rum.
Wir kämen nicht auf die genannten in Norwegen hätten wir bisher die Norweger können es schon selber regeln.
Am Ende kostet das halt mehr die Unternehmen oder kommen die nicht drum rum.
So also müssen die diese Märkte oder die Politik um die Märkte zertrümmern was er gemacht hat.
Also müssen die diese Märkte oder die Politik um die Märkte zertrümmern was ja gemacht wird weshalb es zwar irgendwie dann doch niedlich ist Wenn Newtopia nach Genossenschaften ruft aber wohl wissend Es wird da keine Genossenschaften geben mit Bangladescher die.
Deshalb ist zwar irgendwie dann doch niedlich ist wenn man nach Genossenschaften ruft aber wohl wissend Es wird da keine Genossenschaften geben mit Bangladescher die Hersteller von Gesichtsmasken tut sich nicht zusammen.
Hersteller von Gesichtsmasken tun sich jetzt nicht zusammen und machen da.
Wir machen da ein Kartell Preis drauf für Bangladesh Gesichtswasser.
Ein Kartell Preis drauf für Bangladesch Gesichtsmasken oder so. Und daraufhin.
Und wenn Sie so etwas tun würden dann kann man davon ausgehen dass der eine oder andere mächtige Konzern genau dagegen klagen wird und das Verhindern wird mit allen Mitteln.
Dass sich so etwas dort durchsetzt ist ja der Witz wenn man vom freien Markt spricht dass man damit auch meint dass es ein Hauen und Stechen ist das muss man sich wie ein Roggenkamp vorstellen.
Und es ist keineswegs so dass man dann bei diesen,
Kartellen die sich da bilden wirklich,
ein Winzer verband der hier in Deutschland sagt Na ja wir versuchen jetzt mal zu sagen unter fünf Euro gibt's keinen Riesling sondern wir haben es hier mit Kräfteverhältnissen zu tun die ja so weit gehen dass sie Menschenrechte,
ignorieren dass sie Menschenrechte mit Füßen treten und dann glaubt man jetzt dass man es auf diesem Wege durchsetzen kann.
Zudem dann noch in politisch instabilen Systemen.
Warum haben wir denn das in Bangladesch diesen Fall Warum müssen wir dann überhaupt bei diesen Ländern so Lieferketten Gesetz machen das ist eigentlich eine gute Frage denn wir machen das ja bei Norwegen oder Großbritannien würden wir das nicht machen.
Da einfach noch eine Auswirkung aus dem Kolonialismus dass man solche instabilen Regionen sehr gut brauchen kann weil man instabile Regionen immer besser ausbeuten kann als stabile Länder.
Wenn alle Volkswirtschaften so wie Deutschland funktionieren würden dann könnte es diese Hierarchien gar nicht geben von denen aber Deutschland extrem profitiert.
Du hast Hauen und Stechen gesagt Wir kennen auch die Geschichten der Dax-Unternehmen die dann in die Länder Schlägertrupps schicken und sagen Ihr habt.
Ich möchte auf eine Sache Hinweisen auf eine Studie oder auf mehrere Studien vielmehr auf eine Wissenschaftlerin Historikerin und Soziologin Heide Gerstenberg die so um die 80 inzwischen publiziert.
Geschlagen.
Ist zum einen Fachfrau für,
Seefahrt Recht und für die Seefahrt was dort alles geschieht auf diesen Schiffen nicht nur Piraterie sondern sehr viel mehr und auch für,
die internationalen Arbeitsbedingungen sie hat sehr große Studien dazu vorgelegt und man kann auch ein paar Vorträge,
von ihr bei Youtube finden und sie zeigt sehr schön mit welchen,
Mitteln dort Konzerne,
ihren Profit erwirtschaften und dass genau solche Dinge dann passieren und dass es keine Seltenheit ist dass wir da noch einen Kapitalismus erleben wo das Gesetz der Faust entscheidend ist.
Da kann es durchaus mal einen Wandel geben sei es nur durch glückliche Zufälle politische Ereignisse oder einfach das Aufkommen von Personen die dann doch ein Unterschied machen wollen,
berichtet Hubertus Heil aus Begegnungen oder Erfahrungen mit,
Ahmed aus äthiopien.
Wir haben ja damals in äthiopien auch den dortigen Ministerpräsidenten Abu Ahmed getroffen.
Ein Friedensnobelpreisträger. Der hat inzwischen innenpolitisch auch Riesenprobleme weil er eine sehr junge Bevölkerung hat im Altersschnitt sind die Menschen äthiopien 18 Jahre alt und Deutschland das weiß ich als Rentmeister 47 das ist mein Alter.
Das heißt eine junge und ungeduldige Bevölkerung in einem bitterarmen Land.
Und wenn wir nicht Stück für Stück mithelfen dass die Verhältnisse da vorankommen dann wird ein Hoffnungsträger wie Abu Ahmed der Reformen einführte ein Mann des Friedens ist innenpolitisch und sozial scheitern.
Und dann haben wir Probleme die wollen wir gar nicht haben die haben wir auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent in vielen Bereichen das weiß der Kollege Müller besser als ich.
Es ist auch eine Frage sozusagen am Ende des Tages von europäischer Sicherheit und Friedenspolitik dass wir uns um die Lebensgrundlagen kümmern und das fängt mit anständigen Arbeitsbedingungen an..
Lebensgrundlagen sind Fluchtursachen damit gemeint und man kann tatsächlich das liegt auf der Hand.
Ich meine da muss man jetzt braucht man keine große Studie wenn man die Löhne anhebt sorgt man für bessere Möglichkeiten sich vor Ort zu organisieren,
Lohnarbeit so lukrativ zu machen dass man das Leben gestalten kann dass man eine gewisse Landschaftspfleger hat die dann Fluchtursachen mindert.
Es gibt natürlich diese Studie die sagt Fluchtursachen steigt ein bisschen mit dem Gehalt.
Man muss sich flocht auch leisten können nur wenn man das nicht der einzelne stößt mit seinem Gehalt hinaus und möchte dann sozusagen die Flucht weil er es geschafft hat weil man den ganzen,
Playing wie man so schön sagt gemeinsam anhebt dann finde ich dann tatsächlich in ihrer eigenen Nachbarschaft wohler als jetzt irgendwo,
wo sie glauben sie haben es geschafft in so einem fremden Land wo sie über Jahre und mittlerweile auch in Zelten leben müssen.
Hubertus Heil gibt hier der CDU nochmal Argumente an die Hand Sicherheit ganz ganz wichtiger Begriff für die Union aber wird dann auch überhört. Und es stimmt ja.
Eigentlich schon.
Das Sein bestimmt das Bewusstsein sei sagt Marx. Also,
vorausgesetzt dass man jetzt dieses Gesetz auf den Weg bringt wird zum Beispiel in äthiopien eine Situation geschaffen in der Menschen,
ein besseres sein Erleben und das formt ihr Bewusstsein insofern als sie,
eher nicht anfällig werden für Radikalisierung.
In welcher Art auch immer. Sondern sehen. Es gibt einen gesellschaftlichen Fortschritt der auch dann zu einer zivilisierten Politik führen kann da bestimmt eben dieser alte Satz von Marx ganz ganz genau.
Und ja es liegt alles auf der Hand. Eigentlich besser kann man es nicht ausbreiten.
Uwe Kiekert ist zuversichtlich. Allerdings wissen wir nicht genau warum er sagt vielleicht auch so ein bisschen trotzig im Bundestag.
Zuversichtlich.
Sind.
Am Ende werden wir Regelungen verabschieden die den Schutz von Mensch und Umwelt in Lieferketten ernst nehmen. Minister Altmaier wird nicht in der Lage sein dies auf Dauer zu verhindern.
Wir.
Nicht.
Allerdings Je länger diese Regierung wartet desto mehr trägt sie zur sozialen und ökologischen Destabilisierung betroffener Länder bei. Mit allen negativen Konsequenzen für das Land selbst für die Region aber auch für uns.
Ganz.
Während er sprach haben wir ein ganz süffisant bis eklig grinsenden Peter Altmaier auf der Regierungsbank gesehen der sich hier richtig lustig macht darüber dass die Grünen mal wieder scheitern mit einem Anliegen ganz blöd.
Furchtbar.
Und er macht sich über die Thematik lustig ist es doch.
Na ja es spricht für sich sagen wir es so dass ein Unionspolitiker wenn das Thema Menschenrechte angesprochen wird anfängt zu feixen und zu grinsen auf der Regierungsbank statt.
Na
Wenigstens da noch ein angemessenes Gesicht zu machen wenn man schon inhaltlich nicht hinter der Sache steht.
Ja das kann Olaf Scholz besser. In solchen Momenten einfach mal ernst gucken und die Sache nicht ernst nehmen.
Ich finde jedenfalls diese Dimension. Ich habe es schon mal angesprochen Wir hören hier Jörg Tetzlaff der ist irgendwie so ein Verbandsvertreter von Juwelier Unternehmerverbandes Keine Ahnung aber der stellt ja nochmal diese Ehring Problematik dar,
von der ich glaube in dieser Instagram Story Narrative irgendetwas keine Ahnung Influencer WELT Steckt da irgendwie Potenzial drin wenn man es ein bisschen organisiert ist das auch.
Für die Juweliere selbst spielt das auch eine große Rolle. In erster Linie übrigens bei den Heringen das heißt bei anderem Schmuck ist man da.
Was die Kundenseite betrifft schon etwas etwas entspannter und ich habe eben noch den Investment Bereich angesprochen. Da lässt sich das überhaupt nicht durchsetzen. Da schauen die Leute auf die Rendite und sind Goldbarren relativ gleich.
Da gibt's bis auf die Gravur keine keine Unterschiede.
So
das gilt doch eigentlich für alles.
Markus Krall wird das sicherlich egal sein wo das Gold herkommt.
Genau egal. Aber das gilt doch eigentlich für alles.
Aber das geht ja eigentlich.
Wir kaufen doch immer Sachen nicht der Rendite wegen sondern weil da irgendwie was dran hängen.
Nicht. Sondern weil er.
Story Ansehens Gewinnung durch andere.
Ansehens die Bindung durch andere noch coolere ist.
Und es müsste sich doch einbauen lassen.
Man müsste es festmachen denke ich an einzelne Gegenstände.
Wenn man jetzt tatsächlich im Modus des Marketings denkt wäre das sicherlich sehr gut die heiraten ja alle laufend.
Eta hat gerade geheiratet eine ganz bekannte Influenzaviren.
Und da wäre so etwas selbstverständlich richtig gut machbar dass man das miteinander verknüpft dass,
die Juweliere auch die Chance haben sich damit zu bewerben das hat alles Grenzen nämlich dort wo das Alltägliche ankommt wo es um die normale Schokolade geht,
um die Unterhose die Socken und so weiter.
Da ist das dann auch nicht mehr so schick.
Es wird ja auch bei Zalando mitunter von Luxus Herstellern angeboten.
Nachhaltigkeit Mode die dann noch ein bisschen teurer in der Regel ist.
Ich bezahle aber da indem ich die kaufe nicht mit dass die jetzt besser hergestellt wurde sondern man hat jetzt da nochmal einen eigenen Marketing Trey und deswegen kostet die Hose oder der Anzug 30 Euro mehr.
Das ist mit solchen Dingen sicherlich machbar und der Eheringe ist ja prädestiniert dafür da funktioniert das Storytelling.
Aber das wäre ja immerhin ein Ansatz mit dem man in guter Weise Populismus betreiben könnte.
Man könnte die CDU die ja noch sehr viel Wert auf die Ehe legt sehr schön mit einer geschickten Kampagne unter Druck setzen.
Ich komme ja noch mal auf den öko Populismus zu sprechen weil er fehlt weil er komplett fehlt.
Unglaublich was die Frau auf der Straße liegen lassen.
Dieses Thema bleibt jedenfalls in den Zwanzigern jetzt erhalten wir hören hier zum Abschluss Armin Page. Aber auch bei dieser Veranstaltung mit eingeladen.
Ich habe jetzt gar nicht notiert wo er herkommt. Aber falls jemand googeln will P A CH und er kommt auch noch so ein bisschen mit Naja ich habe mal einen optimistischen Zeitplan.
Zunächst einmal nehme ich Hubertus Heil und Gerd Müller beim Wort. Die haben bei einer Pressekonferenz gesagt Das Gesetz soll im Januar nächsten Jahres verabschiedet werden. Das fände ich sehr gut und es ist auch wichtig auf nationaler Ebene auf nationaler Ebene.
Dann wird es natürlich eine übergangsfrist geben.
Wir würden uns ein oder zwei Jahre wünschen wenn es drei Jahre werden möglicherweise auch noch akzeptabel auf EU Ebene glaube ich dass das noch ein paar Jahre länger dauern wird fürchte ich zumindest bis es dann wirklich wirkt.
Bei den Menschen vor Ort werden auch wenn man jetzt schnell vorangeht in Deutschland und in der EU wird das mit Sicherheit noch sechs sieben Jahre dauern.
Hieße aber 2030 mal gucken.
Er hat jetzt im Januar soll das Gesetz weit im Bundestag sein.
Das wird dann eine Bilanz des Jahrzehnts für uns sein. Blicken darauf ob das noch.
Im Januar,
jedenfalls auf der einen Seite der Sonne. Eine Sache die völlig unter dem Radar läuft was ich schade finde denn er liest bei mir auch.
Aber dadurch dass man das so cool mit den Preisen nennen kann einfach.
Dann haben wir ja sozusagen kognitiven moralischen Anker Kinderarbeiter und so weiter herunterbrechen auf echte Probleme bis hin zu Wir bräuchten eine neue Sozialdemokratie und so weiter.
Deswegen hat man das mal gegründet denn jetzt müssen wir sie exportieren.
Die CDU hat einfach nur Angst vor kleinen Haftungsfragen und so ist nicht mal strafrechtlich so eine zivile Haft da könnte man sogar Unternehmer abschreiben oder sowas ja irgendwo in die Bilanz schreiben wie Donald Trump seine Frisur oder sowas.
Und dann sagen Ok das am Ende doch mehr Probleme sind und dass diese PR-Maschine den Ehering Ja das fand ich,
wirklich instruktiv Man will nicht einen Ehering haben bei dem die Diamanten irgendwie aus einer Kinderarbeiter Grube sind.
Das müsste man doch so wie man Gesundheit zum Thema macht müsste man das eigentlich auch so mit Schleifen.
Hollywoodstars haben das mal ein bisschen probiert Leonardo DiCaprio Black Diamond ist auch ein Film der davon handelt.
Es war schon mal Thema und ich erinnere mich auch an noch ein paar andere Stars die das mal aufgegriffen haben aber es war dann auch wieder gut oder man hat es auch nicht geschafft es dann zu verknüpfen mit dem Gesamtzusammenhang.
Man sagt dann Okay wir kümmern uns jetzt hier um Gold und sonst aber nichts da nur um Diamanten und man erkennt dann nicht na ja das gilt dann für alles das muss man als Aufhänger begreifen.
Es geht nicht darum dass man sagt damit die Eheringe endlich fair sind und sonst können wir alles so lassen wie es ist das ist glaube ich das Problem das wir beim Influenza Marketing haben dass man so ein Ding herauspickt.
Wer schon mal ein Ansatz.
Da hat man auch gleich noch so ein unique selling point.
Und dann interessiert man sich für den Rest nicht mehr.
Naja würde ich sagen.
Wir blicken nach China würde ich sagen Auch da ist vieles in diesem Monat unter dem Radar zumindest der deutschen öffentlichkeit gelaufen und wenn man sich bei YouTube dann die Klickzahlen ansieht von Videos zum Beispiel,
der Rede die Präsident Xi Jinping vor der UN gehalten wird dann ist man auch erstaunt da kommen dann mehrere Applaus Zusammen ist man vielleicht bei 100 120 000 Aufrufen.
Da denkt man naja es müsste ja eigentlich ein paar Milliarden interessieren.
Aber nein es ist sehr sehr viel kleiner die Gruppe aber wir werfen jetzt einen Blick drauf.
Videobotschaften hat gar nicht miteinander gesprochen sondern nur.
Ich glaube das war sehr gut denn es hat eine schöne Klarheit reingebracht.
Leider.
Kann.
Dort der charmante Staat Wiemers Waza,
Saschas gab die Valmont die weit Striker Popel Balance von Gouvernante an der Market Markert Anti Fisch und sehr groß ein Inc.
Distribution Anteil Naji träumend.
Selbstverständlich hören wir hier die englische übersetzung. Sie hat selbstverständlich nicht Englisch gesprochen.
Was er hier nochmal ganz klar macht Globalisierung läuft.
Wir sind angekommen und wir lassen uns jetzt nicht von den Amerikanern unsere Globalisierung kaputtmachen sondern wir haben da noch Ziele und er geht dann nochmal weiter darauf ein.
Opern die Wahl Rehman kann Media to Biotin an open world economy ein abhaut lateral Trading Regime World Trade Organisation Aster Kohlenstaub,
Lúcio Juni Alltagsszenen Sam,
der Steibl ein Smiley auf Kobo in Rio anzupeilen.
Ja das ist so grandios verlogen. Es ist einfach Ich meine die,
Mechanismen in Amerika gehen so weit dass sie quasi keinen westlichen Dienst im Internet zulassen sondern lieber 80000 Leute installieren die da irgendwie rum filtern.
Und wenn dann mal tick tack angedroht wird vielleicht in Amerika nicht mehr runterladen zu sein ist das gleich in der westlichen Welt so mega diese Dimension wie China das macht wird überhaupt nicht verstanden.
Und dann das es seit 20 Jahren keine Investitionen in China gibt bei der ein Unternehmen für sich dort tätig sein kann sondern das man immer ne chinesische Seite an die Hand bekommt als Stakeholder als Mitentscheidung Management.
Wie Trump das jetzt vorschlägt für die USA. Da kommen wir gleich.
Protektionismus ist aber nicht so gut das ist einfach so verlogener. Die Chinesen sind wirklich.
Aber er versucht es jetzt richtig gut gegen Trump sich zu positionieren und zu sagen Ich bin hier der Kämpfer für die Werte der WTO beigetreten Wann war es 2001 und damals noch auf Drängen der USA.
Entleiher.
Man dachte wenn die kommen dann werden die sich unserem Modell anpassen Für uns ist das ganz toll.
Aber wir sehen ja die Worte stimmen zwar die Taten sind andere aber jetzt mit den Klimazielen.
Das war eigentlich der entscheidende Satz der da so in diesen Minuten mal fällt da geht auch gar nicht mehr darauf ein sondern einfach.
We have see you speak BVE and Archiv Koerper New Shale die iPhone 6.
Sehr.
25 anschiebt haben die 25 6.
Cabot Neutralität vor 2060 und.
Wasseradern für 2030.
2030 nur noch mal reinhören.
We HFC Orozco Emissions Pipifax.
Ja
Archiv Koerper New Schale die iPhone 6.
Genau der Peak ist dann da. Man hatte mal,
2025 versprochen hatte ihn jetzt ein bisschen verschoben aber Adam hat sich damit auseinandergesetzt und findet das ganz fantastisch wenn man ihm glauben darf man muss sagen,
was schon immer mal wieder in der Vergangenheit so dass er hehre Klimaziele versprach die dann nicht so ganz eingehalten,
nicht ganz verwirklicht haben oder ließen.
Er sagt mit etwa 28 Prozent der weltweiten Gesamtmenge ist das in China produzierte Kohlendioxid etwa so viel wie das von den Vereinigten Staaten der Europäischen Union und Indien zusammen produzierte,
pro Kopf Emissionen Chinas sind heute höher als die der EU.
Wenn man die Kohlendioxid-Emissionen auf der Grundlage der Produktion und nicht auf der Grundlage des Verbrauchs betrachtet das heißt wenn man jetzt das miteinander vergleicht und nur pro Kopf einfach sich anschaut.
Wie verrückt aber die verbrauchen das nicht sondern die produzieren eben sehr sehr viel für uns.
So ist es dann das hier noch ganz deutlich darauf hinweist dass die Pro-Kopf Emissionen Chinas weniger als halb so hoch sind wie die in den Vereinigten Staaten.
Aber was die künftigen Emissionen betrifft so hängt alles von China ab.
Bei der Produktion aber auch weil der Lebensstandard sich für die Chinesen immer weiter verbessert.
Jetzt hat man ja doch schon wieder eine relativ gute Wachstumsprognose.
Trotz dieses herben Corona Knicks und das bedeutet selbstverständlich wenn der Wohlstand wächst dann wachsen auch erst einmal die Emissionen und die These von jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen gewagt ist aber doch interessant.
Er sieht jetzt in dieser Rede doch nicht so sehr dass da jemand einfach schöne Worte macht sondern dass hier China einen Weg weist den wir auch in Europa sehen können mit dem Green Deal.
Und sein Fazit ist der letzte Satz in diesem Text.
China und Europa pflegen China und Europa entkoppeln sich von den USA. Klar von wem sonst.
Ist das damit gemeint. Die Kupplung ist ja auch das Wort was benutzt wird für Wirtschaftswachstum und Umweltzerstörung Verschmutzung. Das ist auch die Linke.
Ich denke schon.
Ja das Entkoppeln eigentlich von dem das man gar nicht mehr auf die USA blickt.
Es geht dann auch darauf ein dass zwar jetzt wenn beiden kommen sollte,
das nochmal ein bisschen anders dann wieder geführt wird aber eigentlich hat schon Obama doch sehr gebremst dann nachher mit viel viel,
Wärme in das Thema reingegangen und dann doch sehr gebremst und er ist eigentlich jetzt so dass man sagt Du hast sicherlich recht.
Dieses entkoppeln meint auch genau das aber ist es auch ein entkoppeln von China und Europa finden jetzt einen eigenen Weg und dann müssen mal die USA gucken was sie sind was sie machen. Sie sind aber dann eher in der Bringschuld.
Genau das geht Hand in Hand.
Wir haben noch die Rede von State of the Union. Das war eigentlich eine reine Klimaretter Es ging fast nur um Klima Einsatz zu Migration und so.
Und da macht sie auch diesen Punkt.
Da kann man es auch wieder zwischen den Zeilen rausholen die Kupplung ist zweigleisig ist denn wenn man eine europäische Stahlproduktion die CO2 neutral ist haben möchte kriegt man das über eine Förderung die.
Den ganzen Investitionskosten Apparat weg von der Kohle hin zum Wasserstoff als Grenze Anpassungs Mechanismus.
Das heißt ja nicht mehr Zoll sondern man legt jetzt 80 Prozent Anpassungs Mechanismus also Klimagesetz Anpassung des Mechanismus da oben drauf und das geht natürlich einher mit einer Entkopplung von Weltmärkten.
Man wird dann selbst abfischen wie man so schön sagt man muss es dann aus eigener Kraft machen was in solchen Wirtschaftsräumen Natürlich geht.
Amerika Europa China. Es gibt keinen Grund da den Weltmarkt für Milch Stahl oder sonstiges sondern das Rohstoffe die sind überall verfügbar sind alle Klimazonen vertreten in diesen Wirtschaftsregionen da kann man das alles machen.
Und da bin ich auch mal gespannt ob wir dann so eine Separierung 2060 von allein sagt 2050.
Da sind nun diese Zeithorizonte die wir dann alle noch erleben ob wir dann so separiert formell eingemauert also virtuell formell jedenfalls so in die neuen juristischen Rahmen neuen.
Horizonten einfach.
Wird dann auch zu sehen sein. Wie ist denn hier China als ein Vorreiter als gutes Beispiel Wir hatten es bei den Lieferketten mit Blick auf Deutschland wenn da jetzt was kommt dann wird man.
Wie wird das bei China sein wenn die jetzt doch eine Zeit lang eigentlich mit Indien viel blockiert haben früher noch Indien sich erst mal aus diesen ökologischen Fragen viel stärker raushält.
Wird das China sein wenn wir jetzt doch.
Sind die jetzt auch plötzlich im Zugzwang da verlieren wir Investitions chancen oder Wir sind nicht mehr der Boden auf dem man investieren will.
Bei.
Das heißt wir müssen auf China Indien in den nächsten Monaten blicken.
China man nicht unterschätzen darf ist diese Verbindung aus Umwelt und Klimaschutz.
CO2 korrespondiert ja immer mit allen möglichen Sachen die man nicht in seiner Stadt haben will.
Legendär wie vergiftet Peking war und so Dieser Smog Bilder und sehr viel Klimaschutz geht dann einfach huckepack mit Wir wollen E-Autos damit die Städte nicht mehr so Smog sind und dann hat man gleichzeitig Klimaschutz,
nach außen hin als Klimaschutz verkauft ist doch schon mehr dieser Umweltschutz der dann auch ein bisschen den Treiber sieht der zugkräftige ist als einfach nur eine globale Klimaschutz Debatte.
Peking und die Flüsse müssen sauber werden.
Der Lebensstandard erfordert es dann auch dass man die Leute auch unzufrieden wenn sie nicht mehr baden gehen könnten. Das muss man einfach auch sehen in China.
Wenig überraschend aber hat diese Ankündigung von Präsident Xi Jinping nicht so viel Widerhall in den deutschen Medien erfahren.
Interessiert man sich irgendwie nicht viel Man denkt eigentlich sitzen doch jetzt alle.
Zuhause können YouTube gucken können Sie sich das ansehen. Machen sie aber nicht wird auch dann nicht die Twitter Debatte sondern China war aber großes Thema doch mit etwas anderem Man könnte sagen mit etwas vaginalen im Vergleich.
Und zwar Es werden wahrscheinlich fast alle mitbekommen haben es war so dass man bei Facebook einen Post fand von einer Sinologen die war bei Thalia in der Buchhandlung.
Ich weiß gar nicht wo welcher gerade und sah Ach da stehen ja ganz viele Bücher über China und China Wochen und dann schaute sie und dann war sie etwas verwundert über die Auswahl.
Da sind dann die Reden von Präsident Xie China regieren auf Deutsch übersetzt und andere sehr pro chinesische Bücher.
Es gab dann auch noch in einem anderen Regal etwas weiter entfernt dann,
kritische Bücher wie zum Beispiel smarte Diktatur von Kai Strittmatter den hatten wir mal in Frankfurt erlebt oder das Buch von Theo Sommer und einiges andere aber man war ob dieser merkwürdigen großen.
Präsentation doch etwas überrascht.
Und dann stellte sich heraus Ja Thalia arbeitet zusammen mit China Book Trading GmbH.
Das ist eine Firma die auch einen Sitz in Deutschland hat und das ist ein Verlag der natürlich verknüpft ist mit China mit der Kommunistischen Partei.
Und die übersetzen nicht nur die Reden von Xie Jinping sondern auch Literatur aus China.
Aber auch andere Texte von Forschern alles Mögliche.
Das ist selbstverständlich ein Verlag der verknüpft ist mit dieser mit diesem Staat.
Aber man fand das jetzt so unglaublich empörend dass Thalia damit zusammenarbeitet wo man erst einmal sagen muss Ja die machen das mit allen verlangen das war vielen Leuten gar nicht so geläufig dass man sich.
Denn die machen es mit allen verlagere.
Regalmeter oder dass man sich Präsentationsfläche in ein Geschäft wie Thalia oder auch in anderen Buchhandelsketten mieten kann.
Stefan Schulz schreibt die Rentenrecht Rentner Republik. Der Verlag sagt oder Du sagst selbst jetzt müssen wir mal richtig hartes Marketing,
10000 auf den Tisch und dann wird es so sein dass man den Thalia Buchhandlung geht und als erstes mal über dein Buch stolpern sagt Oh das muss das Wichtigste sein denn davon haben die 1000 Exemplare hier liegt ganz vorne.
Das ist das Konzept Wir kennen das bei Amazon mit den Empfehlungen die kann man auch sich sponsern lassen.
Man war da sehr sehr empört. Ruprecht Polenz hat sich da aufgeregt als alter Transatlantiker Norbert Röttgen und so weiter machen alle mit.
Man hatte im Deutschlandradio sich auch dazu geäußert aber dann ein bisschen moderater.
Das Ganze hier haben wir mal einen Auszug daraus.
Wird Talia damit durchkommen glauben sie oder muss man da doch irgendwie sagen wir lassen es wieder.
Auf Twitter regt man sich vor allem darüber auf dass die Buchhandlung nicht deutlich macht dass diese Titel ausgewählt worden sind von China. Das könnte man machen.
Ansonsten finde ich es nicht so erstaunlich ist es so dass an der Kasse sowieso auch Titel ausgelegt werden für die extra bezahlt wird von den Verlagen ob deutschen oder anderen Verlagen.
Und das ist bereits Usus so schlimm es ist aber ist die Freiheit des Kaufmanns das zu tun.
Ich glaube man ist nicht so gut angesehen als Buchhändler wenn man jetzt einfach unkritisch.
Sagen wir diese oder jene Schriften auslegt dass sie da sind dass sie Erwerber sind ist vollkommen richtig. Das finde ich auch gar nicht problematisch.
Um Gottes Willen ich glaube da müssen auch die deutschen Verlage aufpassen dass sich im Buchhandel nicht dieser Verkauf von Regalmeter breitmacht und dann eventuell natürlich kleinere,
mittlere nicht so finanzstarke Verlage ins Hintertreffen geraten.
Ich glaube aber auch nicht dass Internet-Handel es mit den Algorithmen immer so verläuft dass tatsächlich diejenigen die dieses Buch angesehen haben auch diese anderen Titel die wir ihnen jetzt gleich vorschlagen nur ausgewählt werden.
Ich glaube dahinter hinter den Algorithmen stecken auch kaufmännische überlegungen auch Geld.
Jörg Plath war das aber kann man sagen Das ist ja alles so und.
Es nervt mich wenn eine pseudo Aufklärung über den Kapitalismus.
Es ist ja auch so dass Klein kleine Verlage ohnehin wenig Chancen haben in Buchhandlungen stattzufinden das kann man einfach sehen,
geht man Eigentümer geführte Buchhandlung die wirklich sagt wir machen tolle Literatur hier dann wird man Verlage entdecken die,
irgendwie über den Grossisten schon schwer zu bestellen seien wenn man im Thalia ist und wenn auch nur zu bestellen und die liegen nicht irgendwo rum.
Das war ja auch immer das besonders Scheinheilige.
Wenn man sich gegen Amazon empört hat diese Buchhandelsketten.
Man sagte Ja genau das gemacht. Amazon hat es nochmal besser hinbekommen. Aber eigentlich seid hier genauso.
Grundsätzlich der Umgang mit Verkaufsflächen sei es eine Drogerie ein Supermarkt ein super Kaufhaus oder sonstiges wird halt so organisiert.
Nicht ohne Grund war Obamas Wahlkampf Chef vorher dafür bekannt bei der Einrichtung von Supermärkten zu sein.
Kurze Wege schnelle Ansprache wie so etwas funktioniert.
Diese Aufregung über Tarja macht es ja so funktioniert dieser Verkauf.
Und zu glauben dass jetzt der große chinesische,
Einfluss dadurch generiert wird dass man dort Bücher ausliegen hat mit Reden von Präsident Xi Jinping.
Das finde ich doch ganz verrückt. Ich habe aber das Ganze zum Anlass genommen und habe mir gesagt Dann lese ich das doch toll dass die alle auf Deutsch übersetzen.
Das hat man doch dann endlich mal hier.
Da muss man nicht immer rum Rätseln und man muss nicht immer sich den Vorwurf gefallen lassen Naja Man redet über China aber nur aus Korrespondenten Sicht Was sagen die denn eigentlich das wissen wir nicht wir können ja die Sprache.
Und so denke ich prima dass es einen Verlag gibt der uns das anbietet.
Man kann das ja auch kritisch lesen und genau so sollte man das auch tun aber das brauche ich auch gar nicht dazu zu sagen Ich muss also nicht nochmal so ein Framing extra machen.
Ich müsste vielmehr man Framing machen wie oft dann irgendwelche transatlantische.
Thinktanks und Geldgeber dafür sorgen dass er einmal wieder eine Madeleine Albright oder ein Henry Kissinger dazu aufrufen kann dass wir jetzt unbedingt nochmal mit aller Gewalt die westlichen Werte in ein armes Land bringen.
Ein sehr guter Punkt diese chinesische Propaganda ist gefährlich und sie mischt sich auch in so Sachen ein wo es wirklich kritisch wird wenn nämlich beispielsweise das,
muss man ja mal wieder betonen chinesische Studenten hier nicht frei leben können sondern immer in der Gefahr stehen dass sie da,
drangsaliert werden und ihre Familie dann irgendwie zuhause und so weiter.
Diese große dieses große Misstrauen der eigenen Bevölkerung im Ausland gegenüber aber in dem Buchladen die Reden des eigenen Präsidenten auszustellen so wie sie gehalten wurden als Dokumente sich diesen Platz zu kaufen,
da ist die Kritik die ich anbringen könnte ja da nimmt man halt jemand anderem diese Regalmeter weg.
Es gibt bestimmt ein paar Autoren die hätten das irgendwie gut gefallen wie sie da gestanden hätten.
Fitzek Es ist unglaublich dumme.
Aber es ist unglaublich dumme Propaganda in der Rede des Präsidenten die nun mal einschläfernd ist.
Und Stefan. Ich habe das Buch jetzt nicht. Ich habe die beiden Bände nicht dabei es gibt ja jetzt sogar noch den dritten Mann ich habe zwei Bände Du öffnest die schwere schwere Bände.
Du öffnest wie schwer es mehrere Bildteil an Präsident Obama mal mit jungen mit Tieren und so weiter.
Dann gibt es mehrere Bildzeile.
Präsident Xi Jinping mit Obama mit seiner Mutter mit alten mit Jungen mit Tieren und so weiter.
Also immer solche Teile die ich aber auch nicht als Propaganda hier markieren muss sagen jeder.
Also immer solche Propaganda Teile die ich aber auch nicht als Propaganda jetzt nochmal hier markieren muss.
Ich würde sagen jeder erwachsene Mensch in Deutschland würde in der Lage sein das irgendwie einzuschätzen und wird nicht sagen Ach das ist ja herrlich.
Mensch in Deutschland würde in der Lage sein das irgendwie einzusetzen und würde nicht sagen dass es egal ist was es dann noch gibt.
Was es dann noch gibt. Im ersten Band ist ein Nachwort in der Form dass es ein Porträt ist über Präsident Xi Jinping und wenn man das liest dass auch keinen Autor hat dieses Porträt.
Im ersten Band ist ein Nachwort in der Form das ist ein Porträt.
Wenn man das liest das Autor hat.
Dann liest man dort erst einmal von dem chinesischen Sozialismus.
Aber auch Präsident Xi Jinping ist ein Familienmensch und er ist aber auch ein Sportler.
Aber dann ist ein Familienmensch natürlich auch ein Sportler.
Er mag besonders Fußball und er lacht herzlich darüber und darüber und darüber ja das sind solche äußerungen.
Er mag besonders weil er lacht ein Mensch das sind solche äußerungen.
Darauf kann ich nur noch reinfallen Wer Paris Hilton Doku für bare Münze nimmt würde ich sagen Dem muss man sowas machen.
Darauf kann wirklich nur noch einfallen.
Aber ich finde es wahnsinnig erhellend. Wir gucken uns jetzt gleich die Rede an. Ich würde gern eines noch dazwischen schieben damit wir es nur abgedeckt haben nämlich tick tack.
Aber ich finde es wahnsinnig erhellend. Wir gucken uns jetzt gleich noch dazwischen schieben damit abgedeckt haben wir nicht.
Wir haben hier eine ganz gute Zusammenfassung für Protector von der Tagesschau. Die passen jetzt mal zusammen wie Tack Tack von der Tagesschau.
Wir haben hier eine ganz gute Zusammenfassung Es gibt einen Text von der Tagesschau die fassen jetzt mal zusammen Wie ist das jetzt mit diesem von der Tagesschau und das ist ein Podcast 110 Minuten etwa.
Die sprechen dann über Neuigkeiten sehr affirmativ zum Teil was neue Techniken anbelangt.
Aber hier geht es einfach mal darum Na ja der Trump hat jetzt da seinen Tick Tock Deal und ist das jetzt so wahnsinnig gut hat er da wieder was richtig Gutes geleisteten.
Was steckt nun hinter diesem Deal. Es ist ein wenig kompliziert Oracle soll Technologie Partner für das Geschäft in den USA werden das alle Daten in den USA wandern auf Oracle Server.
Es wird ein neues Unternehmen gegründet mit Namen Think Tank Global Oracle soll daran zwölf komma fünf Prozent halten und auch der Supermarket Gigant Walmart steigt mit 7,5 Prozent ein.
Den Rest hält die Mutter aber als eine Art passiver Anteilseigner also so um die 80 Prozent und ein passiver Anteilseigner.
Ob das so richtig zusammen geht das zumindest sagt US-Aussenminister Pompeius.
Außerdem stellt.
So werden diese jetzt in China gemacht. Klei ist bleibt VW aber wir sitzen hier mit drin und bestimmen auch wo was so passiert.
Beistands den Thinktank SOS Code das Programm hinter Thinktank Oracle zur Verfügung damit Oracle prüfen kann,
ob es Hintertüren gibt durch die Daten an den chinesischen Staat abfließen und dieses Recht gilt auch für künftige Tic Tac Updates.
Auf.
Zwölf Milliarden Dollar so viel kostet der Deal Walmart und Oracle angeblich und sie legen noch eines drauf um die Trump Administration milde zu stimmen.
10000 Jobs will tektonisch in den USA schaffen wie ursprünglich angeboten sondern gleich 25 000 Björks und zwar.
Da gibts sehr lustigen Running Gag in einem Podcast,
wurde ja auch so viel Technik Beobachtung machen Huawei hat es ja auch versprochen dass man in Amerika investiert,
um Huawei dran arbeiten und seit Monaten bewegt sich da nichts sondern es wächst wieder zu und überhaupt niemand hat mir versprechen.
Bei Huawei beraten haben beraten haben gesagt haben Macht das mal so bauen wir mal eine Halle. Aber.
Auch alle.
Jobs irgendwo eingerichtet.
Was sollen das auch für Jobs sein. Was brauchen tick tock jetzt 25 000.
Nicht in Kalifornien wo die ganzen Tech-Unternehmen ihren Sitz haben in Los Angeles zum Beispiel sitzt ja Think-Tanks sondern in Texas das ist republikanisch regiert. Und dann.
Aber in Texas gibt's im Osten auch komplette Demokratie.
Demokratie die Demokratische Partei gar nicht so ungewöhnlich.
Gibt's auch noch Geld. Donald Trump hatte ja eine Art Vermittlungsgebühr für diesen Deal gefordert für die US-Regierung.
Das hatten zunächst alle für vollkommen absurd gehalten aber nun legen Amerikas Walmart und Thinktank einen fünf Milliarden Dollar Bildungsfonds für die USA auf.
Die Mutter hatte von diesem Fonds zunächst nichts gehört hat dann aber doch bestätigt zeigt aber dass die chinesische tickte Mutter mit dem Deal vielleicht noch nicht ganz warm geworden ist.
Aber mit seiner Hauptforderungen dass der Algorithmus nicht den Besitzer wechselt hat Peking sich offenbar durchgesetzt.
Trump dagegen hat sich mit den meisten seiner Forderungen nicht durchsetzen können.
Tick tack bleibt fest in chinesischer Hand.
Was Trump erreicht hat ist ein gutes Investment für den Konzern eines alten Bekannten.
Im Hintergrund soll nämlich Larry Ellison der Oracle Gründer die Fäden gezogen haben bei diesem Deal.
Und Ellison ist einer der wenigen im Silicon Valley der Trump finanziell im Wahlkampf nachhaltig unterstützt hat.
Klingt für mich nach einer soliden chinesischen Lösung für ein chinesisches Unternehmen.
Ich denke auch die haben sich gesagt mal gucken ob der noch Präsident ist im nächsten Jahr wird das nochmal ganz neu aufgeteilt und ob da irgendein Bildungsfonds kommt oder nicht.
In
Der Langstrecke gespielt internationalen Geldflüssen.
Da kann man ja mit internationalen Geldflüssen viel rum spielen und das kann am Ende noch helfen die Vormachtstellung in den USA auszubauen.
Auszubauen.
Wenn die Damen mit diesem Bildungsfonds dann noch eigene Leute unterkriegen.
Ich denke die haben sehr gewonnen jetzt weiß auch wirklich jeder und wird sich vielleicht mal runterladen.
Wir haben sehr gewonnen. Sind jetzt wieder.
Ich denke mal vielleicht ein bisschen Geld an Trump spenden wenn er gerade in so einer schwierigen Lage ist gut.
Mal ein bisschen Geld,
in die Hotel 1.
Aber zurück zu Präsident Xi Jinping. Ich habe mir reden durchgelesen und es sind reden die Ende 2012 2013.
Das sind hauptsächlich die Reden und das ist sehr schön. Da hat man nämlich mal so diese Grundlage von wo geht er dann überhaupt aus.
In Erinnerung gab Mao dann die öffnung die chinesische.
Und jetzt muss man eben schauen wie legt man dann dieses Land neu an und ich will erst mal einen Blick weil wir das jetzt auch schon mal hatten auf die Presse werfen was erwartet eigentlich ein KP Vorsitzender von der Presse.
Wir sollten eine Mannschaft von Medienschaffenden aufbauen.
Wir sollten eine Mannschaft von Medienschaffenden aufbauen die mit festen politischen überzeugungen.
Die mit festen politischen überzeugungen guter Qualifikation und vorzüglicher Arbeitseinstellung ausgestattet sind und auf die sich die Partei und das Volk verlassen können.
Unter Qualifikation und vorzüglicher Arbeitseinstellung ausgestattet sind und auf die sich die Partei und das Volk verlassen können.
Die Medienschaffenden müssen politisch denken ihre Position im Dienste an den Gesamtinteresse des Landes finden sich ihrer gesellschaftlichen Verantwortung bewusst sein und sich immer wieder daran erinnern.
Wem sie dienen auf wen sie sich stützen und wer sie sind.
Die Führung der Nachrichtenmedien durch die Partei zu verstärken und zu verbessern ist die fundamentale Garantie für eine solide und gesunde Entwicklung unserer Medien und öffentlichkeitsarbeit.
Ja
Eine gelenkte Presse möchte man selbstverständlich haben.
Es gibt ja auch so ein Test. Jeder Journalist muss ja so ein Test bestehen der von der Partei aus kommt.
Ja ja genau denn die Presse wird hier auch nur als ein Diener des Volkes gesehen und die Interessen sind widergespiegelt in der Kommunistischen Partei. Das ist die Idee.
Es ist das Volk der Partei hat da die Armee der Partei das Volk der Partei die Wirtschaft der Partei also auch die Presse der Partei über Romney.
Wie sieht es denn mit dem Internet aus das haben wir schon gesprochen zum Cyberspace äußert sich Ping auch schon vor vielen Jahren und sagt folgendes.
Das Cyberspace ist das gemeinsame virtuelle Zuhause von Millionen Menschen,
eine saubere und gesunde online Umgebung ist im besten Interesse aller User eine schmutzige und verpestete hingegen läuft im Interesse der User zuwider.
Niemand ist gern bereit in einem Raum voller Lügen Betrug Attacken beleidigender Verleumdungen Terror Pornografie und Gewalt zu leben.
Das Internet ist kein gesetzlose Ort.
Die Nutzung des Internets zu den folgenden Zwecken die Menschen zum Sturz der politischen Macht oder zum religiösen Extremismus anzustiften,
ihnen Separatismus zu predigen oder sie zu Terror und Gewalttaten zu verleiten muss entschieden bekämpft und bestraft werden.
Im Geist der Verantwortung gegenüber der Gesellschaft und dem Volk und im gesetzlichen Rahmen müssen wir die Verwaltung des Cyberspace verstärken.
Bessere Online-Inhalte anbieten und die positive Berichterstattung im Internet intensivieren um eine positive gesunde und aufrechte Netzkultur ins Leben zu rufen.
Es ist ganz transparent. Was gibt es Besseres als diese Reden mal direkt lesen zu können.
Aber wenn ich meinen Tick Thinktank aufmache sobald ich ein Auto sehe denke ich da stirbt gleich jemand eine Brücke runter.
Ha
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Das macht ein Unfall in dieser Gewaltsamkeit gewaltsames der Möglichkeit wieder Alltag. Unterbrochen werden kann.
Und du siehst wenn du in Deutschland tick tack öffnest auch das was jemand der in Peking tick tock öffnet sieht oder haben wir noch einmal andere Inhalte können wir chinesische tickte Hooker genauso verfolgen. Ne.
Das andere,
chinesische nicht. Ich habe da noch nie was chinesisches drin gesehen.
Ich nämlich nicht. Ich habe so ein bisschen geschaut. Osteuropa ist doch relativ stark vertreten.
Man weiß ja noch nicht so richtig wo kommen Sie her. Es ist immer so,
ein bisschen aber.
Chinesischer Content ist mir auch nicht aufgefallen und das ist ja meistens was ohne Sprache auskommt. Eigentlich muss das funktionieren.
Das ist ja.
Auch die Welt.
Man sieht ja auch die Welt ist aufgeteilt aber was Ping hier sagt ist ja ganz klar dass es kein freies Netz geben wird und es gibt es ja auch selbstverständlich nicht viel viel weniger noch als das hier der Fall ist.
Aber.
Wir sollten.
Wir sollten nicht immer so ein Relativismus verfallen und sagen Na ja bei uns gibts ja auch den Fall Snowden und Assange.
Sie auch.
Aber man sollte mit Blick auf China genau deshalb so ein Fall wie Assange Snowden besonders ernst nehmen weil man eben sehen kann wie unfrei das Internet.
Man sollte China.
Besonders ernst nehmen.
Werden kann und dass es eben auf einem Wege dorthin ist.
Und das ist.
Deshalb sind das nach wie vor finde ich die Heroen unserer Zeit.
Nur so ein Ausschnitt wie ein Wahlprogramm der CDU auf Seite 57 ein fehlst.
Naja positive Inhalte gegen Pornografie oder das ja.
Ich glaube auch und gerade diese Idee des Positiven die man.
Ja auch so die Zwischentöne. Die einen stellen sie sicher nicht ernst gemeint und bemalen Einsatz gegen so etwas wie Hetze im Netz.
In den Zwischentönen finden kann Die einen stellen sich sicherlich ernst gemeint und aus einem humanen Einsatz gegen so etwas wie Hetze im Netz.
Aber es gibt doch sehr viele die springen auf diesen Zug auf und wollen damit eigentlich eine Zensur im Netz haben insofern als man dann,
nicht mehr sowas hat Wir haben doch die Reaktion damals von Acar noch im Ohr als das Rizzo Video veröffentlicht wurde und sie sagte Na ja da wollen wir doch mal gucken.
Welche Regeln gelten hier ja oder nein.
Wenn man das so liest es ist auch sehr viel,
muss man denn erst herausarbeiten. So ganz implizit. Ja wir greifen da ein Ja wir machen das so gestalten dass wir handeln. Wir machen,
in Deutschland auch noch so eine hohe Affinität für Ja das muss man mal machen da muss man sich mal drum kümmern.
Da sind andere Länder anders drauf Amerika zum Beispiel.
Ich habe dann richtig Lust bekommen nachdem ich schon viele viele Reden gelesen hatte.
Jetzt müsste man noch einen weiteren Blick auf China werfen auch nochmal aus chinesischer Perspektive.
Und dann ist mir Wei Wei untergekommen der hat drei Bücher geschrieben die Bestseller waren in China und die aber auch ins Englische übersetzt wurden auf Deutsch gibt's sie leider nicht.
Das eine Buch heißt es ist das dritte China Horizon Glory and Dream of Zivilisationsmüll state.
Vielleicht kann man sagen Weiwei Herfried Münkler Chinas beschreiben.
Er ist sehr einflussreich in China hat gute Kontakte zur KP ist Bestsellerautor und er ist so Think Tank wie geht das jetzt mit China weiter.
Das Interessante an diesem Buch ist dass er sich vor allem am Westen abarbeitet. Er bringt gar nicht so viel wie jetzt mit China geht.
Er ruft da nur ein paar Dinge auf die man auch bei Reden sehen kann was ihm vor allem wichtig ist zu sagen Wir müssen uns jetzt gar nicht mehr am Westen orientieren denn wir können eigentlich doch sehen dass wir selbst,
ganz ganz stark sind und das liegt einfach daran dass der Westen,
oder sein System viel mehr genetische Defekte hat und auf diese genetischen Defekte geht ja jetzt mal ein.
Was sind die genetischen Defekte des westlichen politischen Systems.
Meiner Meinung nach sind die drei Annahmen die der Demokratie in vielen Teilen der heutigen Welt zugrunde liegen vielleicht die drei genetischen Defekte.
Erstens Die Menschen sind rational. Zweitens Die Rechte sind absolut.
Und drittens Die Verfahren sind Omnipotenz.
Die Annahme des rationalen Menschen geht davon aus dass Menschen bei der Stimmabgabe ihre Vernunft anwenden und rationale Entscheidungen treffen können.
Bislang haben alle Sozialstudie bewiesen dass Menschen sowohl rational als auch irrational und sogar Ultra irrational sein können.
Mit dem Aufkommen der neuen Medien könnte die irrationale Seite des Menschen leichter hochgespielt werden.
So neigen viele Politiker dazu die Irrationalität der Wähler auszunutzen und die populistische Karte auszuspielen um Stimmen und persönliche Vorteile zu gewinnen.
In der Vergangenheit kam Adolf Hitler auf diese Weise an die Macht.
Ja das ist so. Dieser Panoramablick von außen der Jahrzehnte überspannt und dann so ein allgemeines Argument trifft immer ins Schwarze.
Aber es ist halt auch leicht zu widersprechen nur nicht in einem Monolog der dann in einem Buch einfach vorgelegt wird.
Es ist ein extrem redundanten Monolog.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Man hat eigentlich nach zehn Seiten alles begriffen was er sagen will aber dann doch auf 180 Seiten was erstaunlich ist dass es ein Buch das noch in der obama ära entstanden ist.
Er meint mit Populismus hier auch noch nicht Trump.
Und was er für ein Argument hier macht ist für mich ganz entscheidend dass er sagt in der Vergangenheit kam Adolf Hitler so zur Macht.
Das ist ein Argument das findet man bei sehr Konservativen oder Rechten Schriftstellern mitunter nach 45.
Jemand wie Ernst Jünger sagt nach 45.
Da sieht man mal wohin das mit der Demokratie geführt hat nämlich zu Hitler.
Deswegen kommt man eigentlich zu einem Schluss nie mehr Demokratie.
Carl Schmitt hat auch so eine eigenartige Demokratie. Auffassung so eine identitäre die sagt Die volonté générale die kann ja dann am Ende auch von einem einzigen verkörpert werden.
Also ist die Diktatur für ihn kein Gegensatz zur Demokratie sondern auch eine Form der Demokratie sein das ist dieser Diskurs den wir hier in Deutschland durchaus auch haben.
Und er versucht das jetzt nochmal dieses Argument zu stützen darauf dass es dann,
viele viele Studien darüber gibt wie irrational sich Menschen in gewissen Situationen verhalten und deswegen kann man darauf schließen dass sie das immer irrational tun oder meistens sogar und deswegen kann ein demokratisches System gar nicht vernünftig funktionieren.
Zudem dieser Verweis auf die Rechte die als absolut gedacht werden das ist selbstverständlich ein eine Abkehr von so etwas wie Menschenrechte von Universalismus.
Da kommen wir jetzt auch gleich nochmal zu dieser Erklärung.
Habe ich mir diese Abklärung dass wir diese Abklärung des neoklassischen Rationalität Phantasmen dass man alle irgendwie so die allwissenden Marktteilnehmer sind die sich schon das gleiche wünschen.
Die allwissenden Marktteilnehmer sind das kann man natürlich leicht kritisieren weil man dann zu Hitler kommen muss während man selber an Propaganda statt lebt der ohne Probleme Konzentrationslager aufbaut und so in dem Moment wo er das Schreiter.
Das kann man natürlich leicht kritisieren warum man dann zu Hitler kommen muss während man selber an Propaganda starrt lebt der ohne Probleme Konzentrationslager aufbaut und so in dem Moment wo er das schreibt.
Das ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen. Solche Leute sollten dann auch mal auf internationale Konferenzen und sich sozusagen die Wiederspruch.
Immer wieder in den USA aber er schildert dann die USA.
Darum geht es in Amerika vielleicht nicht ganz unrecht als er sagt Es gibt natürlich die New Yorker denen es irgendwie ganz gut geht und da sind alle reich wohlhabend schön und sind auch,
sensibilisiert für alle möglichen Themen und dann gibt es noch so eine zweite Schicht die hat es schon wesentlich schwieriger.
Die hat aber noch einigermaßen Einkommen und vielleicht auch Erbe im Rücken.
Und dann gibt es so Die Drogenabhängigkeit da ist sozialer Abstieg also etwas was Steve Benson nicht viel anders formulieren würde.
Das gibt es auch im Buch aber es ist auf jeden Fall zu sehen bei einer solchen Lektüre. Mit welcher,
neuen Art man auf sich selbst blickt und auf den Westen blickt weil wir ja immer noch glauben wir sind so ein leuchtendes Vorbild dann doch irgendwie das haben wir schon,
in ihrem Buch das Licht erlosch vor einigen Monaten geschildert.
Wir sind nicht mehr das Modell das man so nachahmt das kann man auch mit Blick auf Russland nicht behaupten dass wir da noch länger nachgeahmt werden.
Und das ist erst mal so sehr erhellend für einen selbst Man liest das und denkt es erstaunlich mit welchem Selbstbewusstsein das von dort aus geschrieben wird weil das eigentlich auch immer so Unsere Haltung ist.
So schreiben wir ja gerne über ein anderes politisches System.
Ja und wir wollen natürlich sehr bestärkt davon dass alle Länder die ein bisschen Wohlstand geschafft haben dann so Metamorphose,
zu einem westlichen Werte und Verfahrens und institutions System geschafft haben im Sinne von genau die haben dann eigentlich schon so.
Zu dem westlichen.
Wandel durch Handel.
Dass sie sich so deutlich äußern gegen das Rationale und gegen die offene Brust Omnipotenz verfahren.
Das ist eigentlich das überraschende weil üblicherweise kennen wir das aus was weiß ich von afrikanischen Diktatoren die dann schon versuchen darzustellen sind jetzt auch rational Wir haben jetzt auch Verfahren die wir,
das Recht beispielsweise das über allem steht und so die lügen dann halten.
Aber dass die jetzt einfach kommen und sagen Ihr seid ja verrückt mit euren rechtsstaatlichen Verfahren und die kommen einfach und machen mit demselben Selbstbewusstsein ein anderes Modell das es schon das gab es vorher noch nicht.
Ist denn China frei von Populismus fragt man sich da und,
muss dran denken dass Präsident Xi Jinping vor allem etwas ganz stark gemacht hat was vorher nicht in der Regierungspolitik so wichtig war bei seinen Vorgängern,
Konfuzius fiel viel stärker eingeführt ein Verweis viel stärker auf die nationale Tradition und auch dazu äußert sich Xie Jinping in seinen Reden schon sehr früh.
Um den chinesischen Traum zu verwirklichen müssen wir den chinesischen Weg gehen.
Dabei handelt es sich um den sozialistischen Weg chinesischer Prägung.
Dieser Weg war in der Vergangenheit keineswegs ein leichter beschritten worden ist er in über 30 Jahren großartiger Praxis der Reform und öffnung,
in über 60 Jahren nachhaltiger suche seit Gründung der Volksrepublik China,
nach einer gründlichen Zusammenfassung eines mehr als hundert 70 Jahre dauernden Entwicklungsprozesses,
des chinesischen Volkes seit der Moderne und durch die übernahme und Weitergabe der über 5000 Jahre alten Zivilisation des chinesischen Volkes.
Er hat Tiefe Ursprünge in der Geschichte und breite Grundlagen in der Realität.
Das chinesische Volk verfügt über eine außerordentliche Kreativität.
Wir haben die großartige chinesische Zivilisation erschaffen und so werden wir auch in der Lage sein einen zu den nationalen Bedingungen Chinas passenden Entwicklungsweg für die Zukunft zu ebnen und diesen zu bestimmen.
Zur Verwirklichung des chinesischen Traums muss das chinesische Nationalgefühl gefordert werden.
Dies ist ein nationaler Geist mit patriotischem Kern und ein Zeitgeist mit einem Kern aus Reform und Innovation.
Dieses Gefühl und dieser Geist sind die integrative Seele zur Witalij Vierung und Stärkung unseres Landes.
Patriotismus wird immer eine Geisteskraft bleiben die den Zusammenhalt des chinesischen Volkes stärkt.
Deswegen gründen wir jetzt ein chinesisches Hollywood. Das passt wieder ganz gut.
Genau das macht man noch ein bisschen wie macht das Hollywood eigentlich.
Aber dann setzt man ganz stark auf die eigene Identität man setzt auch Hollywood unter Druck indem man ihnen klarmacht Wir brauchen euch vielleicht bald gar nicht mehr so.
Zwar seid ihr momentan noch in den Kinocharts ordentlich vertreten aber wir bauen hier sehr eigenes auf oder ihr macht das nach unseren Regeln.
Das macht.
Das war auch noch ein Aufreger in diesem Monat nämlich der Fall Mulan.
Dass man es da mit einem chinesischen Film eigentlich zu tun hat insofern als Disney sich da ordentlich reinreden lassen.
Nichts.
Aber das ist einfach ein langweiliger Film.
Unglaublich langweilig hat nicht funktioniert funktioniert im übrigen auch in den chinesischen Kinos nicht.
Schon.
Es gibt ein Rezept das noch ein bisschen magisch ist. So etwas hat man noch nicht kopiert.
Ja genau. Also ich hab mir ja einige dieser chinesischen Blockbuster auch schon angesehen und die sind jetzt mal von der Ideologie ganz abgesehen.
Keine guten Filme das ist kein Top-Mann Moment dabei.
Wie ist denn das jetzt. Jetzt haben wir schon mal gehört. Sozialismus chinesischer Prägung Was meint denn das da eigentlich.
Ehrlich gesagt Wenn man jetzt ein bisschen marxistisch geschult ist und das so liest es sind sehr schlichte Gedanken die da geäußert werden ist kein Dialektiker in irgendeiner Weise.
Man hat eher den Eindruck er bezieht sich auf den Marxismus so wie das diese Herrschaften von der CDU tun wenn es ums Christentum geht also recht ausgehöhlt aber,
es geht hier immer um das Volk mit Patriotismus meint man da schon weiter zu kommen da gibts einen wichtigen Begriff,
in der KP auch schon bei Mao ist das ein ganz wichtiger Begriff die Massen Linie. Wenn man da rein.
Was die Massen Linie letztlich verkörpert ist der marxistische Grundsatz wonach das Volk der Schöpfer der Geschichte ist.
Nur wenn wir an diesem Grundsatz festhalten können wir die grundlegende Gesetzmäßigkeit des geschichtlichen Fortschritts erfassen.
Nur wenn wir nach historischen Gesetzmäßigkeiten handeln werden wir überall erfolgreich sein.
Die Geschichte hat wiederholt bewiesen dass das Volk die treibende Kraft der historischen Entwicklung und des sozialen Fortschritts ist.
Genau wie Mao Zedong einst sagte Sobald das chinesische Volk die Geschicke Chinas in seine eigenen Hände genommen hat wird China,
genauso wie die im Osten aufgehende Sonne die ganze Erde in seinem Glanz erstrahlen lassen.
Während der Massen Linie festhält sieht das Volk als die Kraft die wesentlich über unser zukünftiges Schicksal entscheidet.
An der zentralen Stellung des Volks festzuhalten und die Aktivität des Volkes voll zu entfalten bildet ein starkes Fundament mit dem unsere Partei nie auf verlorenem Posten stehen wird.
Vor dem Volk werden wir immer Grundschüler sein wir müssen das Volk wie einen Lehrer verehren und die fähigen und weisen um Rat ersuchen.
Das heißt wir haben es mit der Idee zu tun dass die Kommunistische Partei,
Diener des Volkes ist sich als solche verstehend,
immer wieder bemühen muss zu hören was das Volk will beziehungsweise aus ihm Leute für die KP zu rekrutieren und sich selbst in eine,
Position begeben muss um das Volk als Lehrer zu empfangen denn das ist ja ganz entscheidend.
Man muss das Volk als das historische Subjekt erkennen dass überhaupt eine Revolution zum Beispiel möglich ist durch dass der Weg durch den Sozialismus hin zum Kommunismus möglich ist denn das ist immer der Horizont der bei der ganzen Sache.
Erst einmal geht es jetzt darum diesen chinesischen Traum zu verwirklichen natürlich angelehnt an den American Dream.
Wie sieht der aus. Das ist der chinesische Traum eines bescheidenen Wohlstands.
So nennt es Jinping das die jetzt gerade als Wanderarbeiter unterwegs sind 200 bis 300 Millionen und viele viele andere noch in prekären Verhältnissen,
in einen bescheidenen Wohlstand kommen und dass daraufhin man die nächste Entwicklung einleiten kann aber immer mit totaler Abstimmung des Volkes also was man nicht signalisieren möchte hier ist der.
Diktator der irgendwo im Elfenbeinturm sitzt oder in seinem Palast und was macht.
Man muss sagen Wir haben es bei China mit einem Land zu tun das ein bisschen größer ist als Deutschland 1,3 1,4 Milliarden Chinesen gibt es ist durch diese Region auch ganz anders regiert.
Sicherlich ist es auch vermessen zu sagen Ja dann macht doch mal unser System hier Föderalismus und dann klappt das schon alles.
Das heißt Es ist extrem schwierig dieses Land zu regieren und was man versucht ist so eine Abstimmung herzustellen und man führt ja sehr viele Umfragen,
oder Tests durch wie zufrieden die Menschen in China sind und dieser,
wachsende Wohlstand sorgt dafür dass trotz dieser ganzen Repressionen die uns extrem erschrecken natürlich wenn,
man eine hohe Zufriedenheit hat bei sehr vielen.
Es korreliert so ein bisschen solange es nach oben geht. Das ist dann ganz schnell gefährlich. Ich meine diese Strategie ist natürlich auch.
In Europa hat man ja über dieses ganze positive Recht und so weiter eine gute Strategie gefunden.
Einzelne Ansinnen wirklich zu isolieren und dann auch mitzuteilen über den Richterspruch Du bist jetzt hier alleine im Namen des Volkes haben wir gegen dich entschieden.
In Amerika hat man ja schon wenn man jetzt auf Trump schaut einfach sagt Ich zahle keine Steuern warum denn ich hab doch soviel Verluste dass das so als individuelle Raffinesse bewundert wird.
Möchte man hier ein geben das man immer sagt Solche Extravaganzen kannst du dir nicht erlauben. Das Volk hat anderes vorher.
Der amerikanische Traum ist ja ein individueller du alleine sollst vom Tellerwäscher zum Millionär werden.
Das gibts nun in China nicht sondern das ist einfach der kollektive Traum an den man sich am besten an. Ansonsten ist man da schnell draußen.
Überdies ist die Korruption ein ganz großes Problem und da kämpft man hart gegen an zum Teil auch sehr erfolgreich durch diese überwachungs Politik muss man hinzufügen.
Na ja genau.
Man hat grundsätzlich dieses große Misstrauen untereinander das man sich da wirklich nicht traut nicht über den Weg traut.
Noch gut findet wenn dann mal der Big Brother sozusagen für alle gleich drüber schaut und Korruptionsbekämpfer.
Wenn,
wir alle gleich.
Und wenn er dann jedes einhegen eines.
Versuchs ein privates persönliches individuelles Anliegen loszuwerden immer einhegen kann ich entscheide ja nicht sondern das Volk hat gesagt das ist die Linie.
Versuch's ein Privates Persönliches wie auch immer politisch individuelles Anliegen loszuwerden immer einigen kann. Ich entscheide ja nicht sondern das Volk hat gesagt.
Es ist super wirkmächtig da China dieses ganze Konstrukt.
Nochmal ein positiver Bezug auf Mao ist ist keineswegs so dass man jetzt in China sagt der Mao der hat ja unglaublich viel Leid angerichtet.
Das war ja eine Weile so. Aber das wird jetzt gerade wieder restauriert.
Das sieht man in diesen Reden durchweg positiv.
Na ja ich bin jetzt in dieser Marroni Form auch aufgetreten kürzlich bei der letzten Parade da die Queen Corona ohne Publikum wo sie alle nur übers Fernsehen.
Das hat tatsächlich in diesem Auto kennt man ja stehend ohne Dach und es hat man diese Mauer uniforme Wei weiterkomme noch einmal vorsorglich zurück.
Wang.
Wei Wei kommen wir noch einmal kurz auf ihn zurück. Der zeigt jetzt nochmal ganz brachial wie selbstbewusst China zu sein hat denn.
Der zeigt jetzt nochmal ganz brachial wie selbstbewusst China zu sein hat wenn.
Wir haben ja als Europäer doch immer gedacht Na ja wir haben noch ein paar schöne Dinge hervorgebracht z.B.
Wir als Europäer gedacht schon so schöne Dinge hervorgebracht die.
Die Kunst der Renaissance oder auch die Aufklärung Kant und co.
Schlösser am Rhein zum Beispiel die Aufklärung auch wenn wir.
Hören wir mal was er dazu sagt in.
In den vergangenen drei Jahrzehnten hat der Westen viele falsche Prognosen über China gemacht.
In den vergangenen drei Jahrzehnten hat der Westen viele falsche Prognosen über China gemacht die Hauptursache dafür ist die tief verwurzelte kulturelle und ideologische vor allem.
China.
Die Hauptursache dafür ist die tief verwurzelte kulturelle und ideologische Voreingenommenheit.
Tief verwurzelt,
vor.
Insbesondere der Eurozentrismus und das Gefühl einer angeblich übermächtigen westlichen Zivilisation und die Mentalität des Endes der Geschichte um diese A.
Insbesondere der Eurozentrismus und das Gefühl einer angeblich übermächtigen westlichen Zivilisation.
Einer angeblich übermächtigen westlichen Zivilisation und Mentalität in der Geschichte.
Die Mentalität der Geschichte.
Diese Art Mensch ist aber auch da nimmt sich ja wirklich unsere Wunden Punkte her.
Stocherte hat am Rand des westlichen Diskurses zu konstruieren.
Des westlichen Diskurses zu dekonstruieren habe ich die Erkenntnisse und Schlussfolgerungen vieler Wissenschaftler aus China und übersee zusammengefasst. Zunächst einmal.
Des westlichen.
Aber die Erkenntnisse und Schlussfolgerungen vieler Wissenschaftler aus China sind zusammengefasst.
Wissenschaftler.
So ist es ja. Denkt man jetzt Zaster da hat er tausend Studien.
Zunächst denkt man jetzt da so stellt man sich Virologen wie Drosten vor da geht jetzt alles durch neue Ergebnisse und dort wird doch nicht nur so übertragen.
So stellt man sich Virologen wie Drosten vor da geht jetzt alles durch neue Ergebnisse Infektionen geschehen da und dort wird doch nicht nur so übertragen Schmier Infektion plötzlich wichtiger so stellt man sich jetzt das vor.
Plötzlich wichtiger so stellt man sich es gibt neue Erkenntnisse zur Hegeler.
Popup positivistische Wissenschaft ja so saß da jetzt da und jetzt kommt diese unglaubliche Schlussfolgerung nachdem man diese Studien jetzt durchgearbeitet.
War China dem Westen in den meisten Fällen in den vergangenen zwei Jahrtausenden voraus.
Zweitens kam eine der Haupt Triebkräfte der europäischen Renaissance im 16.
Jahrhundert aus dem Osten.
Drittens war China im 17.
Und 18. Jahrhundert eine wichtige Ideen Quelle für die europäische Aufklärung.
Viertens haben einige der zentralen Konzepte und institutionellen Arrangements des Westens von heute wie das lasse fair und das System des öffentlichen Dienstes ihren Ursprung in China,
Eurozentrismus und die angebliche überlegenheit der westlichen Zivilisation sind einfach unhaltbar.
Und Thomas von Aquin hat einen Vater der hieß John.
Ja genau. Selbstverständlich gab's da hin und wieder mal Einflüsse aber mir ist diese besondere Geschichte der Aufklärung vor allem fremd jetzt wird vielleicht der eine oder andere sagen da gabs mal den Austausch und außerdem hat Voltaire damals Ja das mag alles sein.
Man könnte das vermutlich auch mit Indien hinbekommen.
Diese Argumentation ja. Es gab nie vollkommen abgeschottete schottete Kulturräume aber tatsächlich ist der europäische Geist doch ein besonderer.
Was nicht heißt dass er dem anderen überlegen sein muss.
Aber jetzt zu behaupten dass das eigentlich alles made in China ist ist doch sehr sehr absurd.
Passt aber sehr gut dazu wie man sich dann entsprechend versteht wenn man dann sagt Okay,
wir brauchen jetzt den Eurozentrismus nicht worum es da eigentlich geht es selbstverstãndlich den Universalismus dass man sagt Menschenrechte.
Da haben wir jetzt drüber gesprochen.
Menschenrechte sind universell gültig sind eben keine positiven Rechte.
Da kann man nicht sagen na ja da müssen wir nochmal irgendwie gucken dass man ein bisschen was ändern kann.
Wir machen da jetzt positives Recht bei den Lieferketten gesetzt.
Man versucht jetzt ein Gesetz zu etablieren dass Firmen sich an etwas halten müssen was dem aber zu Grunde liegt ist ein Natur.
Rechtlicher Zusammenhang nämlich das Menschenrecht. Das ist nicht positiv da kann man nicht sagen Ja.
Da ist halt Vergewaltigung erlaubt oder verboten oder da kann man auch Kinder mit 7 Jahren arbeiten lassen nein da sagt man Das sind universelle Rechte die haben absolute Gültigkeit.
Das kommt unter anderem von jemanden wie Immanuel Kant und vielen anderen französischen und deutschen und britischen Denkern.
Aber genau das möchte man jetzt nicht mehr. Man hat natürlich damit viel Schindluder getrieben.
Denken wir an die imperialen Kriege die wir hatten seitens der USA oder auch koloniale Eroberungen seitens Europas.
Jetzt aber möchte man das alles über Bord werfen und möchte eigentlich sagen wie jeder so wie er denkt und wir deshalb noch einmal zu dieser Souveränität Thematik Praesident.
Wir müssen das Recht jedes Volkes auf die eigenständige Wahl seines Entwicklungsweg respektieren,
werden anderen keinesfalls unseren Willen aufzwingen und es auch keinesfalls dulden dass irgend jemand dem chinesischen Volk seinen Willen aufzwingt.
Wir befürworten die Lösung internationaler Konflikte mit friedlichen Mitteln,
stellen uns gegen jede Form von Hegemonie und Machtpolitik und werden uns niemals als hegemonial oder Expansions Macht begreifen.
Entschieden werden wir die nationale Souveränität Sicherheit und unsere Entwicklungs Interessen schützen.
Kein anderes Land sollte damit rechnen dass wir über die eigenen Kern Interessen mit uns verhandeln lassen und ebenso wenig damit,
dass wir in den sauren Apfel beißen wenn unsere Souveränität Sicherheit und entwicklungs Interessen gefährdet sind.
Der große Unterschied zwischen der westlichen Welt und China was vorgestellt wird ist die grenzenlose Dummheit von Donald Trump.
Denn er ist ja programmatisch auch so reingegangen. Nur was dann leider an seiner Inkompetenz gescheitert wäre ein echtes aufeinandertreffen gewesen wenn da ein bisschen Intelligenz dahinter gewesen wäre.
Aber ansonsten China First.
Sehr interessant ja aber es lohnt sich doch sich mal mit China aus dieser,
Blickrichtung direkt zu beschäftigen und das nicht immer nur vermittelt zu bekommen von Korrespondenten sondern einfach auch mal zu hören was dort gesagt werden.
Das ist das Schöne bei Präsident sie ist es unglaublich transparent und nachvollziehbar und man braucht gar nicht so groß herumreisen sondern die haben das da ganz klar gesagt dass die nicht mit sich reden lassen und dass sie keine Einmischung eines anderen Staates dulden.
Was hier nochmal gesagt wird dass sie nicht expansiv sind nicht hegemonial sind das ist ja schönes reden wir wissen dass man durch Wirtschaft sehr wohl expansiv und hegemonial sein kann.
In Afrika ist das zu erleben in Osteuropa ist das zu erleben.
Der ungarische Präsident und viele andere haben ja China schon Tür und Tor geöffnet und selbstverständlich finden damit Einflussnahmen statt schon deshalb gar nicht nur um irgendeinen,
Crypto sozialistischen Weg durchzudrücken sondern schon deshalb weil man sich.
Verbündete schaffen will gegen die andere Weltmacht gegen die USA die auch versucht sich da durchzusetzen.
Wir brauchen jetzt nicht das Spiel zu spielen.
In welchen Fällen genau schlimmer. Aber ich glaube was hier deutlich wird.
Wir brauchen eigentlich eine eigenständige europäische Lösung die sich sowohl von Peking möglichst unabhängig macht als auch mehr von Washington löst.
Wobei die europäische ist zu wenig militärisch unterfüttert.
Deswegen glaube ich es wird eine ganz große Renaissance geben wenn Trump abgewählt ist.
Ich vermute auch.
Zwischen beiden und,
Trump wird abgewählt. Das wird eine Party für sich. Aber auch diese Antrittsbesuche in Europa.
Für sich diese Antrittsbesuche in Europa. Europa hat nochmal ein bisschen Fokus rücken wegen China und Russland China dieses pazifische Jahrzehnt.
Ich glaube Europa wird nochmal ein bisschen in den Fokus rücken wegen China und Russland natürlich aber vor allem China.
Denn dieses pazifische Jahrzehnt wurde ja schon ausgerufen. Hillary Clinton hätte das ja schon alles eingeläutet und da auch mit Intelligenz gearbeitet. Vielleicht ist das auch alles große Vorbereitung. Weil die haben so was ja auch im Blick.
Alles eingeläutet. Intelligenz Gegengerade. Vielleicht ist das auch alles Reisevorbereitungen.
In solchen Dekaden Horizonten um so etwas zu machen.
Wenngleich ich befürchte dass Europa sehr verlieren wird wenn wir da so einen harten Washingtoner Kurs mittragen und dann nicht nur Militäretat zu erhöhen sondern uns auch in Kriege involvieren lassen die wir nicht involviert sein wollen.
Das ist ja immer so..
Ja das wird nochmal ein bisschen brutal. Guckt man doch mal nach Europa.
Louisa Neubauer hat er aufgerufen zum Klima Streik. Vergangenen Freitag war das um den anzukündigen ist sie zu der Bild-Zeitung gegangen um dort nochmal zu sagen was geplant ist. Nun kann man sagen Ja klar man kann ja auch zur Bild gehen. Warum nicht.
Wenn sie gerade in Berlin ist findet sie dann noch Publikum.
Allerdings wird sie hier auch gefragt Was fordert ihr denn nun.
Die Antwort war so schlaff Wir hören das erst mal im Original was hat sich in diesem Jahr bewegt und was fordert ihr noch.
Was hat sich in diesem Jahr bewegt und was fordert ihr noch.
Genau genommen ist es sogar der sechste globale Klima Streik. Letztes Jahr hatten wir dieses Jahr hatten wir im April seine Coruña Version im Netz und jetzt gehen wir das erste Mal seit Corona wieder richtig auf die Straße wir rufen auch weltweit.
Das erste Mal.
Die Entscheidung muss uns überhaupt nicht leicht gefallen denn es ist eine wahnsinnige Herausforderung und Belastung für alle Beteiligten aber gezwungen.
Überbelastet. Man muss jetzt Maske tragen oder ein bisschen. Ich habe es eigentlich ganz verstanden.
Ich habe eher den Eindruck die Leute sind froh.
Hatte ich auch das Happening stand an. Ich glaube nicht dass jemand wegen das ist.
Aber ich mache trotzdem genau das Gegenteil aber gut. Sie hat jetzt ein weinerliche Art Es muss noch mal ergründet werden wir hören ja die inhaltliche Dimension Sie wurde ja gefragt Was fordert ihr jetzt 2020.
Durch die anhaltende Ignoranz mit der die Klimakrise politisch behandelt wird und,
durch steigende Emissionen weltweit und damit auch durch die steigende Gefahr für Menschen überall auf der Erde insbesondere in bedrohten Regionen und in zukünftigen Generationen durch die Klimakrise,
und damit auch die Forderung klar Wir fordern von der Regierung weltweit auch in Deutschland das Abkommen was sie selbst verhandelt haben das Pariser Abkommen einhalten,
und alles dafür tun um das in die Wege zu leiten um es umzusetzen und das natürlich gerecht nachhaltig und wirkungsvoll aber eben,
um so das Mindeste zu tun was man tun muss um,
die Lebensgrundlagen der Menschen zu bewahren und ganz direkt den Menschen vor unvorstellbarem Leid zu befahren bewahren wovon wir auch schon heute sehen wie das aussehen könnte Wir müssen gar nicht weit gucken um zu sehen wie die Klimakrise aussieht.
Wir sehen die Klimakrise Siesta und die Forderung das Pariser Abkommen einzuhalten.
Und ich meine wir haben ja so etwas ist ganz wichtig und das Mindeste.
Gerecht nachhaltig. Ja aber das Mindeste soll getan werden und das ist ja schon verräterisch wenn man als Aktivist sagt das Mindeste dann ist man ja schon ganz in der Verhandlung runtergegangen.
Es ist ganz komisch nicht nur ist man in der Dimension runtergegangen ist er als Minister sondern man hat auch keine einzige inhaltliche Forderung.
Während in Italien jetzt der Staat zu hundert Prozent Solaranlagen auf privaten Hausdächern fördert und via Paris jetzt wirklich autofrei bekommen und sogar in London einiges los ist ist das hier in Deutschland irgendwie so..
Ja Merkel regiert. Damit sind wir unzufrieden weil die Emissionen steigen das muss man überprüfen ob das überhaupt stimmt,
und man fordert jetzt wie schon vor anderthalb Jahren so das Pariser Abkommen einzuhalten von dem wir eigentlich damals schon sagten Es ist wirklich das Mindeste nicht einmal das schaffen wir.
Also irgendwo müsste doch eigentlich so eine inhaltliche Dimension nachgebaut werden auch auf der Forderung Seite um zum Beispiel mich zu mobilisieren.
Das wäre auch ein bisschen arrogant von mir sagen ja sie überzeugt mich nicht deswegen weil ich nicht zur Demo.
Aber darum gehts ja eigentlich zu mobilisieren und es ist aber alles so demobilisiert und ich habe dann doch interessiert diese Rede gehört denn wie gesagt das war dann doch so eine reine Klimaretter.
Klar sie muss sich ein Thema raussuchen bei dem nicht alle Länder sich ihren Kopf gemacht haben gesagt haben.
Migrationen machen wir nicht.
Dann ist da Migrationsdebatte halt alle Länder die wollen dürfen abschieben.
Das ist der Deal. Ich möchte mich ja nicht mehr hier gibt's politisch nichts zu gewinnen.
Beim Klima ist das ein bisschen anders denn wir haben wie beim Lieferketten Gesetze auch diese vertrackte Logik.
Unternehmen wollen Planungssicherheit.
Und sie wissen Irgendwann ist der Druck da. Irgendwann ist es nicht nur Tesla sondern dann kommen die Sachen aus Amerika und aus China und dann sind wir einfach verloren.
Dann haben wir zu wenig Zeit und irgendwelche neuen Gegebenheiten anzupassen das sollte lieber jetzt so langsam gebaut werden.
Und wenn Louisa Neubauer die ja auch mit von der Leyen und mit Merkel durchaus in Kontakt ist treffen sich die telefonieren wahrscheinlich auch immer mal wieder.
Also ich glaube schon dass es da so ein bisschen Auseinandersetzung gibt und.
Na ja sonst hätte es auch dieses Treffen im Kanzleramt nicht gegeben. Da schreibt man ja nicht einen Brief und sagt dürfen wir irgendwann mal kommen.
Genau sowas wird ja vorbereitet und geplant und genau 90 Minuten freigeräumt und bei dem Anliegen Wir sollten jetzt mal Paris einhalten das Pariser Abkommen sagt sich von alleine einfach nichts leichter als das.
Und jetzt müssen wir mal überprüfen wie viel Rhetorik ist hier drin oder wieviel echte Substanz.
Wir hören mal drei Minuten 49 am Stück aus ihrer Rede zur Lage der Nation.
Das erste Drittel kann man abhaken unter l'amour Kalender Sprecher und so weiter können wir irgendwie.
Danach wird es aber ein kleiner Umschwung da und ich frage mich warum Louisa Neubauer als Rädelsführer der Deutschen Freitas vor Futuro,
und Argumente gewinnt und sagt Wenn die von allein das vorschlägt liebe CDU dann solltet ihr das auch mal oder so Er geht jetzt mal mit Europa mit irgendwas über.
Wir fordern einfach dass Paris eingehalten wird denn diese von allein Rede ist schon sehr deutlich gewesen.
Der European Green Dealers Blueprint to make What Transformation,
Haro with mischen to be the First Climate New York Kontinent in Twenty Fifty,
Impact Assessment Cleary Shows Weed Meeting bis Target Output European Union Chamäleon Track,
Reality bei Twenty Fifty and vom Meeting aus Paris Agreement obligations we have to lead.
Also wenn es einfach nur Gerede gegen Gerede steht dann sagt die eine Seite Wir fordern von euch dass Einheiten kommen sollen sagt sie. Ja das ist das Programm mir. Sie sagen einfach kein Problem machen wir.
Come back to the Carbon wurde just mit Macan desolater we have good for the good for Business and good Fasolt.
Diesen Zusammenhang haben wir schon ein paarmal dargestellt. Die New York Times Text über wie sich das Credit Gebaren da verändert. Blob von Rock.
Wir hatten das schon.
Meeting bis New Target Energieimporte sie.
USA Energieimporte sie.
Extra Jobs HFF Pollution Together we have to start.
Polo-Shirt.
Mein Ex Samui Valerie weiss auf Arc Leihmüttern Gislason Levels of consumption Materie Energie Warthe Food and Land Jews is not sustainable.
1:1 einen Satz von weiles war Future unser derzeitiges Level auf Consumption ist nicht nachhaltig. Es geht um Rohstoffe Nahrungsmittel Bodennutzung Energie alles ist sozusagen 1:1 übernommen.
Veni to have Treat Nature Usern Konsum Hove Levent Work,
Travel Transport sowie World Hackel Sink vom Halse des Chemicals Tour de Force Station to Pollution fertig.
Seven present auf Next Generation you will bis direkt die European Green Deal Adjektivs.
So 37 Prozent von Next Generation EU das ist diese 750 Milliardenprogramm das sind zwei hundert acht und siebzig Milliarden Euro die sie ja gerade versprochen hat das wird in die Klimaziele gesteckt die formuliert sind.
Und gegen diese Klimaziele die sind nicht verlogen oder so einfach zu fordern was man so machen muss.
Und da finde ich 278 Milliarden die dann zusätzlich noch als Schulden aufgenommen werden.
Also werden wir auch in der Bundespressekonferenz Altmaier oder Olaf Scholz als Finanzminister immer noch drangsaliert mit der Frage opfern sie die schwarze Null die fürs Klima. Und dann sagt Scholz irgendwas keine Ahnung.
Dabei ist das schon längst Geschichte. Also wir haben schon längst die schwarze Null geopfert sowohl in Deutschland als auch.
Die haben ja nicht einfach nur eine schwarze Null geopfert sondern die EU macht überhaupt das erste Mal Schulden und steckt dann 278 Milliarden davon direkt in Klima Sachen. Das ist wirklich eine substanzielle Veränderung.
Waren schon bei der Tagescreme Financing to the next level We Leaders in Green Feierns Ricardo Lagos ichwar Green Bonds Worldwide.
Siedet.
Und dieser Verweis auf kreditfinanzierten Green Bonds ist dieser Destillerie Fitness-Programm,
Investitionen macht dann teilen wir das jetzt auf in Green Bonds das heißt ein Unternehmen macht weniger als 25 Prozent Umsatz mit Kohleverstromung.
Und das heißt programmatisch alles schon festgezurrt und es geht halt hier darüber hinaus zu sagen Wir machen Verbote Gebote keine Ahnung irgendwie politisch entscheiden sondern wir sorgen für ein Finanzierungsfrage in der Privatwirtschaft der das ermöglicht,
die ganze Wirtschaft nicht nur einzelne Sektoren oder irgendwas programmatisch ausgesuchtes sondern das ganze Wirtschaftssystem einmal rüber zu hieven.
Und dann muss man überlegen was Green dann genau bedeutet. Dann gibts auch wieder fundamentalistische Ansichten oder wie auch immer. Aber es ist zumindest grüner als vorher.
Via Leading the way in die Wala Pinger real Liebhaber Green Bonds Standard namens Today,
Target auf 40 Prozent auf Next Generation US 705 billion euros to be Race to Green Bonds.
Auf Next Generation Handelssysteme Nehrus Tobey.
Diese Green Bonds sind diese Standards dieses Social ein irgendwas was wir da besprochen haben.
Ist hier programmatisch eingebaut. 30 Prozent der Refinanzierung läuft über diese Green Bonds und dann wird sie ganz konkret indem sie hier nach Schweden.
Tomic Going Sweden Unique Fazil Free Stil Pirat Gentest Operations Price Dugin Tupfern just clean Stier,
Depot Hemmstoff Jian Support Industry clean Leysen tu Apparat.
In Schweden wird jetzt testweise der erste Hochofen mit Wasserstoff der klimaneutralen Stahl. Das sieht man bis vor fünf Jahren für völlig unmöglich.
Man braucht so viel Energie so viel Hitze ich schon immer mal wieder dieses in Essen gibt's das Stahlwerk das ein Prozent des ganzen deutschen Stroms und so weiter. Darum gehts ja und das wird jetzt in Schweden in unserem Test Ding gemacht.
Thyssen die arbeiten alle dran aber auch 2030 38 ist es da so die Zielmarke um sowas dann zu haben.
Second Life and working Buildings.
Lessig.
Svens.
Gebäude Sector angesprochen.
Kalifornien schon ganz wichtig vor vielen vielen Jahren hat man sich gekümmert es gab ja diesen Green Deal Wir brauchen einen Green Deal Artikel,
Thomas Friedman war das damals in der New York Times auf jeden Fall von einem Kolumnisten. Daraufhin hat man sich auch viel stärker in den USA.
Beton ist einer der großen CO2 Treiber und dann natürlich der Betrieb der Gebäude weil die Heizung gekühlt werden und alles Mögliche.
Und da hat sie hier ein ganz interessantes Ziel und sie hat wie soll man sagen fast kulturellen und Unterbau den sie schaffen will.
And we know what der Construction Sektor. Evan BiH turnt vom Karbens Seuss,
in Thur Karbens Sink Ehefrau gerne Golding Mathiaschitz Lockwood ein Smart Technologies Leyk Ajay abhinge just,
finito mexikanisch.
Scheint es stinkt es Detox Tomekk Staubes Sustainability an Why We Will Set up European Bauhaus,
Eco Creation Space Architects Artists Students Engineers Designs work together to make What Happen.
Sehr klug. Das ist natürlich eine tolle Wendung dass man hier schaut was können wir dann noch mit reinbringen was auch sehr sehr deutsch,
ist Bauhaus wenngleich Bauhaus Architektur nicht nur Deutschland meint aber,
doch sehr erheblich deutsch geprägt ist und dass man sich auf Architektur beruft,
die immer schon gesagt hat Nein wir machen hier nicht nur lart pour la sondern wir müssen funktional sein und wir versuchen auch die sozialen Verhältnisse.
Und hier kommen jetzt noch die ökologischen dazu zu verbessern und macht daraus auch noch eine neue oder eine Wiederauflage einer Stilrichtung.
Genau ein Bauhaus können wir anknüpfen das machen auch alle gerne weil der Mythos lebt.
Die Frage ist halt was machen freieres vor Future mit so einer Rede.
Da werden alle Forderungen übererfüllt. Und da wird auch noch intellektuell nachgearbeitet wohl frei vor Future nicht reingegangen sind die Themen also wo einfach nichts da ist an dem man sondern das ist.
Man kann nicht mal richtig sagen Ursula von der Leyen kommt hier einen Wunsch frei.
Oder so. Weil das haben sie ja gar nicht geäußert hat sich nicht ein europäisches Bauhaus zum organischen Bauen Sozial und Klima verträglich gewünscht. Genau das ist ja viel komplexer was da als Forderung im Raum steht.
Die.
Gucken auf 1,5 Grad Ziel und das war's dann irgendwie.
Ich denke es gehen zwei Dinge. Zum einen kann man Forderungen radikalisieren und sagen Naja Einhaltung des Pariser Klimaabkommen ist eigentlich auch sehr brav formuliert.
Man war ja damals schon beim Pariser Abkommen sich einig naja das reicht ja eigentlich nicht.
Ich wundere mich sowieso warum man sich noch vor paar Jahren sagte Ja das ist viel zu wenig.
Jetzt sagt man gut wir wollen das einhalten aber dann muss man viel radikaler vorgehen.
Das ist Augenwischerei. Außerdem werden damit Konzernstrukturen noch verfestigt.
Es gäbe ja sicherlich viele Perspektiven die man hier nämlich einnehmen kann.
Denn eines ist ja klar Ursula von der Leyen hat jetzt nicht ihre soziale Ader insofern sie jetzt sagen Wir werden jetzt voranschreiten und Konzerntöchter oder so zurücktreten drücken.
Müssen dass sie hier alles Masai ernst nehmen und dann sehen wo entstehen hier die Problemfelder bzw.
Wo kann man dann an ganz andere Weise popularisieren so etwas wie das Bauhaus Idee.
Ja man könnte sagen dann hier im Hambacher Forst und so da haben wir schon solche Ideen alle,
kreiert gehabt jetzt bindet das mal richtig ein und man muss ich mal aufhören ständig in dieser netten Dialogue Ebene da zu sein das passt ja dann auch.
Ich sag mal so Natürlich kann man bei Bild sagen Ich mache da ein Interview weil das viele Leute sehen.
Die Frage ist nur ein bisschen wenn man zum Bild eingeladen wird ist das nicht auch schon ein schlechtes Zeichen.
Ich sehe hier auf ganz vielen Ebenen.
Man muss jetzt nicht kritisieren aber ich finde es super.
Nee aber wir betonen Das glaube ich auch hier nochmal ganz deutlich Wir kritisieren die Spitze von Frei Future und die Menschen die wir am meisten im Fernsehen sehen und die in Parteien Einfluss haben die dann irgendwie sagen Hallo.
Wie der Bundestag.
Ich gehe jetzt auch mal in den Bundestag Wir hatten das letzte Mal gehabt.
Es gibt. Ich habe mich auf der Ebene ganz anderer Leute. Also nochmal nochmal sagen.
Es gibt glaube ich auf der Ebene ganz andere Leute. Ich hab das ja schon gesagt dann wird es nochmal nochmal sagen die bei YouTube tief an den Dingen dran sind die nicht zum Bildfolge eingeladen werden.
Die müssen sich jetzt Gehör verschaffen und das schaffen sie nur wenn sie machtpolitisch agieren und sich von gewissen Spitzen in dieser Bewegung lösen.
Genau der Wandel. Ich habe in meiner Diplomarbeit über die EU geschrieben als Neue Demokratie die nicht mehr über den Parlamentarismus.
Üblicherweise läuft ja so man hat irgendwie ein Problem mit der Umwelt.
Also nehmen wir mal Umwelt dann Greenpeace Schiff los und blockiert irgendwie Walfänger das hat man ja vor 20 Jahren oder eine Bohrinsel oder so.
Dann kommt ein Fernsehteam sagt das Gras über das Schiff drüber.
Dann hat man so eine Solidarisierung mit den kleinen Green Peace Schiffen und über diese Solidarisierung mobilisiert man politisch und entscheidet sich bei der Wahl dann anders.
Das ist ja bei der EU ganz anders.
Greenpeace fährt heute nicht mal mit Schiffen draußen rum sondern die haben einfach ein Büro in Brüssel und wenn Ursula von der Leyen sowas macht dann sitzen die mit am Tisch und arbeiten die Beschlussvorlage mit aus. Wir haben ja genau.
Die zweite Variante Verfall des verfugt ist jetzt nur noch als Berater.
Wir haben es genau wir haben es mit so einer Art Lobbyismus zu tun bei dem die EU aber ganz klar sagt Macht euch keine Sorgen nur weil hier 20 000 Lobbyisten rumstehen heisst das nicht dass sie mehr Macht haben als ihr.
Wir nehmen euch hier schon ernst und sehr viele früher über die mediale Schiene gefahrene Organisationen NGOs und so weiter auch im Datenschutz Bereich und so weiter.
Die fühlen sich durchaus ernst genommen Brüssel und die machen das auch mit Inbrunst und die haben ja auch Budgets direkt um das einfach zu unterhalten und die EU will das auch so ein bisschen wie dieses,
chinesische Modell die Partei schickt also 10000 Leute einfach mal so los ins Land und die bringen so Tagebücher zurück und erzählen mir was da los ist.
In der Hinsicht gibt's ja freies auf YouTube verfügte als Organisation hier Anknüpfungspunkte nicht in den Bundestag zu gehen sondern direkt in Brüssel diese Ideen kritisch zu begleiten damit sich nehme ich hier und das ist der große Punkt.
Nicht nur Blackrock durchsetzt weil die das wollen klimaneutrale Hochöfen und so weiter das wissen wir jetzt weil sie damit auch so eine Markt. Kontrolle erregende Markt Schließung ist.
Kommt ja dann auch. Es hat ja eben schon der Cabin Border justament Mechanismus das muss ja alles ausgestaltet werden und in der Hinsicht fehlte eigentlich Kompetenz.
Also ich glaube die Aktivisten mit diesen Demos auf der Straße und so.
Ja das ist ganz cool wenn man dann in der Tagesschau vorkommt aber damit hat man Ursula von der Leyen nicht erreicht so wie Ursula von der Leyen diese Rede da kann ja jeder selber mal überprüfen fand ich das gerade irgendwie überzeugend inhaltlich was sie gesagt hat. Da hab ich das schon woanders gehört.
Die Rede gibt's ja schon zwei Wochen hat man es irgendwo Wanderschuhen gehört diese mediale Schiene die öffentlichkeit zu erreichen.
Das ist weder für Ursula von der Leyen noch für freilässt Vorfluter der richtige Weg sondern die müssen jetzt eigentlich direkt sich begegnen und eben nicht in einem Treffen das man dann so macht sondern irgendwie fehlt.
Aus Bewegung mal ein bisschen Organisation werden Denn Ursula von der Leyen hat hier Ideen und sie hat ja schon angesprochen mit diesem Ich komme gleich nochmal auf diesen,
Anpassungs Mechanismus zurück deswegen springen wir weit vor die Räder und holen das mal nach vorne was sie da sagte.
Carbon must have wie COS Nature cannot Pfadis Price anymore,
justament makellosem Schudt Motive Eyeo Importeurs Torrijos der Kabine Missions Weyland Scheuring level playing field Double Outokumpu.
Herausforderung neuen Zoll einzuführen der nicht eine Ländergrenzen sondern eine Kontinent umfasst.
Trotzdem juristisch wirkt da noch WTO kompatibel ist man bei der Bilder aus Paris hält aber eine neue WTO irgendwie.
Die neue WTO ist.
Es ist als würde ich jetzt programmatische Kritik gefordert und nicht einfach dazu reichen.
Hier ist wirklich programmatische Kritik gefordert und da kann man nicht einfach weiter in Paris wird es dann schon reichen.
Na ja wir gucken ob ich in meiner Rede wirklich nicht schlecht was insgesamt gesagt hat.
Na ja wir gucken mal noch ein bisschen weiter in die Rede. Ich fand das wirklich nicht schlecht was ich insgesamt gesagt hat.
Man kann ist Ursula von der Leyen Wir wissen alle und man muss sich aber wirklich überprüfen wenn ich sie kritisiere.
Man kann es ist Ursula von der Leyen Wir wissen alle umso mehr.
Muss ich aber wenn ich sie kritisiere als Zuhörer.
Als Zuhörer muss ich ja dann lügen unterstellen damit meine Kritik noch funktioniert oder müsste ich eigentlich auch auf einer programmatisch kann ich das ernst nehmen was sie sagt weil ich würde sagen Ja das müssen wir jetzt mal ganz dringend ernst nehmen weil die Investoren stehen dahinter und die Länder auch.
Ich denke wir müssen sie als Strategin wahrnehmen und wir müssen auch Investoren als Strategen wahrnehmen.
Die wollen nicht primär die Welt verbessern sondern sie sehen primär ein neues Geschäftsmodell,
das sich jetzt eben lohnt und dass man auch frühzeitig erkennen muss man hat ja,
gesehen wenn Unternehmen nicht rechtzeitig das Internet sehen als ein Geschäftsfeld sondern viele Zeitungshäuser haben gesagt Jetzt machen wir uns alles kaputt.
Jetzt gibt's da überall Texte zu haben aber wir wollen doch unsere gedruckte Zeitung verkaufen.
Ein bisschen verhalten sich ja auch welche aus der deutschen Autoindustrie so und sagen Jetzt kommt die E-Mobilität.
Wir wollen noch weiter unsere Verbrenner hier verkaufen. Wie kann denn das sein wenn man das tut dann ist man irgendwann so dran wie die deutschen Zeitungshäuser und dann guckt man aufs Internet und es überrascht dass irgendein Blogger,
Hunderttausende Aufrufe stündlich hat und man selbst versucht für 99 Cent einen Artikel zu verkaufen.
Genau wie Eric Schmidt damals sagte das Mediensystem ist nur das erste das hinweggefegt wird.
Die Banken erleben es jetzt gerade und dann ist die Schwerindustrie dran.
Und Blackrock will da nicht dazugehören.
Blackrock will dass die Märkte weiter funktionieren und sei es unter völlig neuen Bedingungen. Und entsprechend wird auch die EU so ein bisschen umgebaut.
Es ist Ursula von der Leyen aber wir nehmen sie jetzt mal richtig ernst. Sie kommt jetzt hier. Es ist der Beginn ihrer Rede. Sie kommt man auf Corona zu sprechen und stellt zum einen das Problem dar. Danach kommt eine Lösung.
Times Greno.
Delikat live can be wer des Systems Limits Model Vallejo Seewolf will den,
Bordin to shape Focus Teri Facility,
Mertingen Glacis Burning Forex global Pandemrix,
The Way EWB He Communicator keeping Arm Set,
Face Mas Show das,
Community of Values really Quick LED kann Kolding du Questions around the world and Event hier Nau Junior.
So Werte gemeinschaft Europa als Wertegemeinschaft.
Das ist eigentlich immer das Distinktionen Merkmal Europas gewesen gegen China gegen Amerika wir sind hier eine Wertegemeinschaft. Bei uns zählen die Werte irgendwie und es brauchte ein Coruña das irgendwie tausend Mal kleiner ist als ein Sandkorn um alles durcheinander zu bringen.
Da kann der deutsche Philosoph Markus Gabriel noch so toll vom moralischen Fortschritt reden am Ende heißt es ja schön ist abgebrannt. Die europäische Lösung funktioniert.
Wir nehmen ja niemanden mehr auf das Zeichen Wir streiten uns ab. Es gibt keinen moralischen Fortschritt.
Wurde jetzt noch einmal ganz eindrücklich widerlegt. In den vergangenen.
Aber ist das wirklich vorbei. Das kann man glaube ich sagen moralischer Fortschritt allein darauf sollte man sich nicht verlassen er korrespondiert höchstens mit irgendwas und mit was eigentlich.
Und dass sie hier einfach sagt das Wertesystem ist zu fragil wie wir jetzt gesehen haben finde ich schon.
Das ist nicht nur ein Kalender Spruch sondern ein Wertesystem war im Grunde das was Europa immer ausgemacht hat worauf sich auch viele deutsche Politiker beziehen wenn sie sich verorten wollen.
Und nochmal sozusagen den Glanz des europäischen Wertesystems.
Wir wissen aber auch wie die Politik bisher oder der strukturelle Wandel bisher in Europa funktioniert hat nämlich und das kennen wir von Barroso einem ihrer Vorgänger.
Wir machen mal so einen Vorschlag dann installieren wir das juristisch und dann kommt eine Krise und dann gucken wir mal wie wir den Mechanismus bestmöglich anwenden können so dass wir dann sagen Jetzt ist es aber Not dass wir eine Europäische Kommission mit so viel Kompetenzen haben.
Und sie möchte dieses ganze Modell einfach mal umdrehen.
Das ist Next Generation you bis es opportunity to make Change hapern bei Design ein Desaster bei Diktats from the World.
Beim Design.
Design bei Desaster war tatsächlich bisher oder Politik beim Desaster das war bisher die Funktionsweise der EU und es haben auch alle dort so gesehen.
Wir haben keine öffentlichkeit Wir kriegen niemanden überzeugt Wir können erst wenn die Krise da ist irgendwas machen und dann einfach hoffen dass es sich auszahlt für uns. Aber wir brauchen eine Krise.
Nicht allzu sehr beschimpft werden für die Maßnahmen ergreifen.
Genau das ist dann immer alles super riskant und so weiter aber so hat es bisher funktioniert und sie ist ein toller Spruch Politik bei Design Politik bei Desaster sehen wir jetzt Politik bei Design.
Und sie.
Und ehrlicherweise hat das auch den ersten Schritt finde ich hat sie schon gemacht.
Passen noch mal schön zum Bauhaus.
Die Verschuldung Europas. Klar es braucht wieder ein Desaster Corona aber diese Verschuldung Europas ist jetzt möglich. Und für die nächste Verschuldung.
Im jährlichen Rhythmus. Brauchen wir jetzt nicht neuen Coronavirus oder so. Sondern das ist jetzt funktioniert.
Die Länder kriegen jetzt ihr Geld und so weiter. Da ist jetzt doch einiges möglich das so ein bisschen und vielleicht deswegen ein kurzer Ausflug zu Ulrike.
Die saß bei Lanz in der Sendung und er hat nochmal.
Hamilton Moment und so weiter. Es gibt ein Bismarck Moment und ich glaube der greift jetzt in Europa K.
Dass wir heute nicht mehr Sachsen und Pfälzer und Preußen sind liegt einfach nur daran dass Bismarck irgendwann mal eine Krankenversicherung für alle eingeführt hat.
Seltsam Preussen sind einfach nur daran dass diesmal.
Natürlich eine schöne deutsche Erinnerung. Und jetzt haben wir das auch hier in Europa nämlich über das Programm.
Bis Ende Juni bis minus Sixteen kann muss die Billion Euros,
Support Workers Companies Kramny Svenja Spahn Pias auf meint Families Wohnideen werden,
pudern Betreiber Otto peile rund eine Million soff Jobs in sind Campanile Quasare Union des,
European Solidarity in Action.
Wir haben uns ja mal gefragt wo ist denn die europäische Arbeitslosenversicherung Wo ist denn die Europäische Krankenversicherung der ganze Kram.
Und dieses Sparprogramm ist 90 Milliarden Euro für Kurzarbeitergeld aus wirklich,
genuin europäisches Geld so 90 Milliarden für Kurzarbeiter beispielsweise bekommt Italien jetzt 27 Milliarden überwiesen das geht zwar wieder als Lohn durch muss man zurückzahlen alle Sowas wird nie zurückzahlen.
Dieses Geld fließt aber doch ausgezahlt es ist zweckgebundenen Kurzarbeit Bewältigung.
Also Italien kriegt 27 Milliarden Belgien 9 Milliarden Polen 11 Milliarden und so gehts die Liste weiter.
Dieser ganze Schutzmechanismus steht jetzt neben dem ESM gleichrangig einfach da nur eben nicht als Reserve könnte man mal und so sondern das ist einfach so ein Durchlauf posten und diese Länder.
Da spielt Deutschland keine Rolle deswegen wird es in Deutschland nie hören dieses Programm.
Aber es hilft doch sehr vielen Ländern jetzt einfach bei der Haushaltsplanung und macht es umso schwerer den Ursprung dieses Geldes nämlich europäische Schulden als genuine Geldquelle mal wieder zurückzudrehen.
Wir haben sie es ja mit Programm zu tun die werden nicht zurückgedreht sondern die sind jetzt so installiert und die werden nachdem das Desaster bewältigt ist in Design umgesetzt.
Das kann man glaube ich sagen und nun mal ein Vergleich.
Wir reden jetzt immer von 8 Jahre und was hat sie gebracht und was müssen wir mal die UN die Vereinten Nationen haben einen Jahresetat von drei Milliarden und es ist so wirkungsvoll was öffentlichkeit und so weiter.
Und hier haben wir 90 Milliarden. Also 30 Mal so viel und es fließt einfach so durch Europa schafft Tatsachen.
Sie verkünde das hier und wir sitzen wieder als Deutsche daneben und enge Europa.
Was solls da denken die in Italien jetzt schon ganz anders drüber. Naja ihr Appell.
Zum Mindestlohn ist nämlich interessant zum Thema Bismarck Moment wie macht man es jetzt.
Kurzarbeitergeld ist das eine das ist ein Desaster und Bewältigung Design Politik bei Design ist ja Mindestlohn europäischer Mindestlohn.
Braucht man das nicht stellt sich ja raus braucht man verkündet sie hier auch.
Und wir hören mal welches Modell sie dafür vorschlägt.
Vorbild Purpose member states of Waggis on Mars Axis.
Must have to Minimum Waggis Collective,
Theremin,
Eselei eines kollektiven Bargel.
Sowohl Fully Respekt nationaler Kompetenz des traditions.
So kollektiv Wageningen das heißt im Grunde Gewerkschaften machen kollektive Initiativen und so weiter.
Sozialpartnerschaft hat sich hier vorgestellt das ist dieses deutsche Modell. Mindestlohn sagt die CDU so nee da soll der Markt man selber machen.
Dann sagt der Markt so Ja wir haben Sozialpartner Arbeitgeber Arbeitnehmer treffen sich ja die können ja nicht nur über Tariflöhne sondern könnten ja auch über den eigenen Tarif Bereich hinaus ein Mindestlohn festlegen,
hat dann natürlich nicht so richtig funktioniert weshalb dann das Arbeitsministerium sagte Wir machen jetzt gemeinsam einen allgemein gesetzlich verbindlichen Mindestlohn der allerdings wird weiter in der Höhe bei der Sozialpartnerschaft gelassen.
Es gibt nämlich die Mindestlohn Kommission die Arbeitgeber Arbeitnehmer aber nicht über Tarife ab begrenze Tarife Tarife erhöhen schließt sondern einfach festlegen wie hoch der allgemeine gesetzliche Mindestlohn ist.
Und wenn das wie in Deutschland funktioniert dann hieße das ja wir haben in vier fünf Jahren oder so nachdem man dann feststellt der zweite dritte freiwillige Forge hat nicht funktioniert haben wir das dann.
Und klar Mindestlöhne gibt's schon in Europa allerdings sind sie in vielen Ländern unter sechs Euro darunter Spanien Portugal Griechenland Polen Tschechien Ungarn Bulgarien und acht weitere.
Also über Mindestlohn kriegt man hier auch eine mega Legitimation Europas wenn es da nicht noch heißt das Kurzarbeitergeld kommt aus Europa sondern auch noch der Mindestlohn.
Da schlägt sie doch ganz schöne Pflöcke ein das muss man mal sagen zum Thema Desaster.
Sie kommt hier mal auf Corona und das Internet zu sprechen und ehrlicherweise muss ich sagen Da fällt dann auf wie sehr Deutschland der Rentner Republik ist.
Denn so hat noch keiner übers Internet gesprochen hier.
Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren Abgeordnete stellen wir uns einen Moment diese Pandemie vor ohne dass digitale,
Quarantäne vollständig isoliert von Familie und Gemeinschaft abgeschnitten von der Arbeitswelt gewaltige Versorgungsprobleme.
So oder so ähnlich muss es wohl vor zehn Jahren bei der letzten Pandemie ausgesehen haben.
Ein Jahrhundert später erlaubt uns moderne Technologie einer Pandemie dass junge Menschen aus der Ferne lernen zuhause Millionen von Menschen von zu Hause aus arbeiten.
Sie ermöglicht Unternehmen die Produktion am Laufenden zu halten und ihre Produkte zu vertreiben.
Danke Internet.
Und wir sehen dabei ein Video eingeblendet von einer Dame die Yoga macht und sich dabei mit einem iPhone filmt.
Sie an einen Salzstreuer angelehnt hat damit es nicht umfällt.
Ein neues Bild von Europa. Wir haben indische Elefanten noch im Hintergrund die wir sehen und dann wird die Yoga Decke ausgebreitet und die Dame nimmt im Yoga Sitz Platz.
Es
Das ist ein ganz neues Europa das sieht eher nach Berlin-Mitte aus.
Ist,
allerdings gezielt ausgewählt das Parlaments Fernsehen das hier punktgenau von der Regie gesteuert diese Bilder einfädelte.
Ja das glaube ich.
Diese Ansprache soll übers Internet die kann man natürlich die müsste man sowieso viel ernster nehmen so viel wie jetzt nicht gespielt wurde und sich Netflix durchgesetzt hat und so weiter Es ist ja dieser Pandemie.
Man sowieso viel ernster nehmen so viel wie jetzt gespielt wurde und sich Netflix durchgesetzt hat und so weiter.
Das sehen wir schon das sind alles keine deutschen Unternehmen also Internetdaten vor allem nicht Europa profitiert.
Und genau deswegen hat sie als Anlass genommen um mal darüber zu reden. Industrie Daten und Daten Wirtschaft.
Also.
Nicht dumm übrigens da ist ja noch ein paar andere Länder im Internet. Wichtig sind was ein wichtiger polnischer Spielehersteller zum Beispiel.
Gerade ein wichtiger Spiele-Hersteller.
Es gibt einfach auch in anderen europäischen Ländern unternehmen die sehr von der Digitalisierung profitieren und die jetzt auch einen kleinen oder größeren Boom durch Coruña erlebt haben.
Genau sie möchte jedenfalls diese Potenziale,
beim Internet. Aber könnte man das nicht auch in diese Politik beideSeiten Ecke rüber drehen.
Und da kommt sich die europäische Cloud.
Google das schaffen die nie. Dabei hätte das vor zehn Jahren schon das Ansinnen sein müssen jetzt darauf zu sprechen und sie macht es einfach mutig Ich sage es mal so.
Die Menge der Industriestaaten in der Welt wird sich in den nächsten fünf Jahren vervierfachen und damit ebenso auch die verbundenen Chancen.
Ebenso Schas das heißt wir müssen jetzt jetzt unser Mittelständler den Start ups vorstellen.
Das heißt wir müssen jetzt unseren Unternehmen jetzt unseren Mittelständlern den Start den Forschern die Möglichkeiten eröffnen aus dem Vollen zu schöpfen.
Die Möglichkeiten aus dem.
Die Realität sieht aber noch anders aus.
Sieht anders aus. 80 Prozent der Industrie werden das ist eine riesige Verschwendung.
80 Prozent der Industrie Daten die gesammelt werden werden leider nie genutzt. Das ist eine riesige Verschwendung.
Meine Daten Verschwendung. Das hat man noch nie als Problem in Deutschland irgendwo zum Thema Daten Verschwendung.
Echte Daten Wirtschaft wäre hingegen ein kraftvoller Motor für Innovationen und für neue Arbeitsplätze deshalb werden wir im Rahmen von Next Generation EU eine europäische Cloud aufbauen.
Auf der Grundlage von Gaia X Der zweite Bereich,
auf denen wir uns konzentrieren müssen ist die Technologie und hier insbesondere die künstliche Intelligenz,
ob es um die Präzisionsarbeit in der Landwirtschaft geht oder um Treff genaue medizinische frühe Diagnosen oder ob es um sicheres autonomes Fahren geht.
Die künstliche Intelligenz eröffnet uns Welten das ist fantastisch.
Aber diese Welten brauchen auch Regeln.
Heißt Algorithmen dürfen keine Blackbox sein und es muss klare Regeln geben. Wenn etwas schiefgeht geht.
Diese Herangehensweise ist grundsätzlich zu begrüßen.
Aber wie gesagt Wir haben jetzt hier eine sehr allgemein gehaltene Rede die viele wichtige Dinge anspricht und in der Tat sind es Themen die eigentlich nicht vorkommen wenn wir uns deutsche Talkshows ansehen.
Dennoch kann man davon ausgehen dass dies alles gestaltet werden wird ganz stark von jenen die momentan Gestalter sind nämlich große Konzerne mit denen Politiker wie Ursula von der Leyen,
sagen wir kollegial zusammen.
Genau das ist eigentlich dieses Problem was jetzt zu kritisieren ist wenn es mal jemand ernst nähme was hier gesagt wird.
Wir haben dieses Buch gelesen.
Die haben wir damals so eine Idee gehabt waren nicht mal besonders kompetent bei Softwareentwicklung und so weiter und haben gesagt Na gut dann haben sie sich halt irgendwo eingemietet.
Da läuft sowas auf Amazon Seuffert und so weiter.
In Europa gibt's keine Möglichkeit dass auf einem deutschen oder europäischen Anbieter Nein du bist immer gleich der Falle Amazon ausgeliefert wo du genau weißt die schauen sich ganz genau an was du da machst und wenn es gut läuft dann ist das schneller weg geklaut als Idee,
selber hinterher gucken kannst braucht man halt sowas Man weiß aber auch Ja jetzt kommt erst mal T-Systems und HP und dann fällt mir erst mal 15 Jahre lang auf die Nase bevor sowas dann funktioniert.
Aber es ist halt irgendwo muss man dann halt auch mal anfangen wenn man auf so einem Gebiet echt inkompetent ist.
Aber die Zukunft da hat sie eines dieser Gebiete ist folgendes Wir kamen letzte Woche schon drüber gesprochen das diesen Text schrieb.
Die Europäische Kommission könnte ja mal ein Förder Umfeld schaffen oder selber als Investor tätig werden um Arm diesen britischen Hersteller von Mac und Mikrochips zu kaufen die jetzt gegen Intel da ganz schön auftrumpfen.
Dazu kam es nicht allerdings hat sie es zumindest hier mal als Programmpunkten.
Wir wollen dass die europäische Industrie einen eigenen Mikroprozessor der nächsten Generation entwickelt der uns erlaubt die steigenden Datenmengen energieeffizient und sicher zu nutzen.
Der europäischen Industrie.
Uns erlaubt die steigenden Energie-Effizienz.
Und all das und noch viel mehr gehört für mich für Europas digital zu Europas digital deckelt.
Nicht Europas zu Europas Team-Manager arm jetzt einfach von Softbank kaufen können.
Für überschaubares Geld stattdessen ist das jetzt ein kalifornisches Unternehmen gehört zu Nvidia natürlich.
Du kannst davon ausgehen dass eben diese Dinge dann wieder solche Platzhirsche machen werden.
Und das ist ja dann häufig bei diesen ganzen Ausschreibungen auch ein ganz großes Problem dass die die wirklich Innovatoren wären gar nicht zum Zuge kommen und dann trãgt ins Ministerium auch enorm hilft dass man das machen kann.
Das ist leider leider so verflixt.
Es sind viele schöne Punkte. Jetzt bräuchte man nur noch eine komplett andere Besetzung im Parlament,
und eine Aktion die Lobbyisten die dort sind erst einmal zurückdrängt und die entscheidenden kleineren Gruppen Grossmacht.
Ich meine es gibt ja gerade im Bereich des Datenschutzes so viele interessante intelligente Leute die nicht nur als Kritiker auftreten sondern auch Entwickler.
Ja eben die die einfach Design mitmachen.
Diese Chance ist erstmal vertan. Allerdings Das Internet bleibt die Bedeutung auch Wir haben beispielsweise jetzt das Ansinnen der Europäischen Union,
innerhalb der nächsten zwei Jahre eine Videokonferenz Plattform europäisch aufzubauen die abhörsicher ist.
Das ist ja schon mal ein Auftrag der das eine oder andere dann auch als Nebeneffekt mit sich hat wie vielleicht auch mal eine Förderung der Spielebranche denn da werden ja die ganzen Technologien entwickelt.
Jetzt habe ich vorhin schon gehört 37 Prozent dieses großen Geldboten gehen ins Klima das digitale hat sie auch eine Hausnummer.
Deshalb werden wir 20 Prozent von Next Generation you in das digitale investieren.
Wir wollen damit den europäischen Weg ins digitale Zeitalter gehen basierend auf unseren Werten unserer Stärke und unseren Ambitionen.
Europäische.
Basieren auf unseren unsere.
Das heißt 20 Prozent plus 37 Prozent 57 Prozent also 97 Prozent von 750 Milliarden gehen in Klima und digitale also echte Zukunftsthemen.
Und nicht nur die Subventionen der Landwirtschaft und was Europas alles berühmt war die letzten schwierigen und auch nervigen Jahre.
Hat dann zum Ausklang der Rede zum Oja sagt sie nur Seenotrettung ist nicht optional.
Sie weiß auch der Zug ist abgefahren. Rassismus möchte sie gern überall in Europa bekämpfen dann nimmt sie vor allem Blick auf Polen.
Die haben da so freie Zonen.
Und sie schließt ausdrücklich die Algorithmen mit ein.
Rassismus auch in Algorithmen bekämpfen und hinsichtlich der Entwicklung in Amerika sagt sie noch folgendes.
We need a new beginning Swiss Old Friends an Bossis Atlantic Bossis.
Also Amerika und Großbritannien sollten mal wieder ein bisschen zur Vernunft.
Mir bereitet eine solche Aussage durchaus Sorgen nicht aus so einem antiimperialistischen Affekt heraus sondern mit Blick darauf wie Militärausgaben ausfallen werden.
Da kann man mir auch sagen was man will das wird man jetzt nicht in klimaneutralen Krieg führen können und dann auch mit Blick darauf dass wir diejenigen sind die diese Konflikte unmittelbar involviert sein werden.
Und wenn man sich ansieht wie der in der Tat schreckliche Fall Nawalny dafür,
gesorgt hat dass er jetzt wieder am liebsten in so eine kalte Kriegs Constellation zurückwollen ist da eine große,
Zustimmung gibt seitens CDU aber auch einige viele Grüne.
Sehe ich da eigentlich sehr sehr finsteren Zeiten entgegen denn ob dann wirklich wir es hier noch mit dem dauerhaften Frieden zu tun haben ist sehr sehr fraglich.
Ja genau diese europäischen und ich würde auch immer für diesen Eurozentrismus einstehen diese europäischen Werte sehr laut hinauszulaufen und sie zu vertreten das andere ist aber,
machtpolitisch in einer Weise einzusetzen dass man doch eigentlich in eine sehr imperiale Haltung kommt die in den vergangenen 20 Jahren ja auch das Ansehen des Westens in der Welt demoliert hat.
Das Buch das ich zitiert habe.
Das ist ja so dass wir es mit einem Buch zu tun haben das sich immer wieder darauf stützt zu sagen guckt man doch nach Afghanistan Gucken wir doch in den Irak. Was war denn das immer gewesen.
Er sagt das an einer Stelle ganz ganz deutlich Western,
Country Western Political Model Lee Szenarios vom Euphoria,
oder From Euphoria Euphoria.
Allerdings China sorgt auch für viel Leid in Afrika und hält sich komplett raus beim Thema Migration und so weiter.
Allerdings.
Kann man ja nur wir müssen das einfach mal so konstatieren deswegen ja die Partnerschaft.
Da kann man diesen Vorwurf immer zurückgeben.
Die Frage ist dann welche künftigen Kriege warten auf uns.
Wir wissen es sind immer so Vorgänge da kann man nichts gegen machen. Da scheint man ganz ohnmächtig.
Madeleine Albright Ich dachte sie ist schon tot da taucht plötzlich in den Tagesthemen wieder auf und verkündet die letzten vier Jahre aber ich hoffe ihr holt uns zurück.
Da wird schon alles vorbereitet und mit beiden Zitaten eine Mannschaft ein die man kennt aus den letzten demokratischen Präsidentschaften.
Mit beiden zieht eine Mannschaft ein die man kennt.
Hellsicht.
Naja die Losung ist jetzt Trump muss weg.
Die Losung ist Trump muss weg.
Das amerikanische Volk hat sich entschieden ihn abzuwählen mit den Folgen müssen wir alle leben.
Wir werden sehen. Wir werden sehen.
Nächste Woche reden wir über Trump das ist nächsten Monat das ist ja kurz davor. Ansonsten verweisen wir euch jetzt noch auf den Salon,
Bob Woodward hat dann tatsächlich jetzt nochmal sein großes Buch geschrieben bestehend basierend auf 17 Gesprächen mit Donald Trump.
Es ist wenn man die erste Hälfte weg blättert dann doch noch einmal sehr aufschlussreich hat auch eine ganz gute Pointe und,
ist halt auch ein Buch das den Wahlkampf noch einmal prägt weil es jetzt einfach Bestseller Nummer Number One seit dem es da ist wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile gehen wird. Das ist dann doch sehr prägend.
Wichtiger ist allerdings dass wir David Schleppers bullshit jobs nochmal lesen.
Ich habe noch immer reingeschaut. Da gibt es auch eine ganz schöne Pointe zur Unterscheidung von Bullshit und Shit Jobs,
kann man nochmal hinsichtlich was wir jetzt über systemrelevante Jobs wissen abklopfen da steckt doch gerade auch weil David Kabalen Autor ist der ganz explizit sagt er schreibt das Buch um die Umstände zu verändern.
Er hätte noch einiges zu Corona dieser neuen Gewichten wird.
Jobs wer kann Homeoffice machen wer nicht und wer produziert wirklich wer hält den Laden am Laufen.
Und dann wird man noch mal ein bisschen rätseln was uns der nun tote David Klöpper wohl dazu gesagt hätte.
Ich möchte unbedingt die Karl Lagerfeld Biografie vorstellen von Alfons Kaiser.
Der Experte der F.A.Z. Lagerfeld sollte uns interessieren.
Zum einen weil er zwar kein Grunder ist wie wir jetzt so gerne diese Geschichten lesen und hören.
Aber er ist dann doch vielleicht ein Gründer in der Form dass er sich selbst kreiert hat und wie er einmal anmerkte so zur berühmtesten Silhouette,
der Welt geworden ist und für ihn war es dann gar nicht mehr entscheidend jetzt selbst das große Unternehmen,
aufzuziehen was ja viele Modemacher getan haben Er hat zwar eine Marke ins Leben gerufen Karl Lagerfeld,
die er aber eigentlich hatte immer so ein bisschen schleifen lassen. Irgendjemand sollte die betreuen.
Er war eigentlich immer Angestellter so hat er sich dann auch gerne verstanden.
Bei Chanel aber nicht nur sondern auch bei Fendi und.
Chloé und dort war ja zum Teil ja noch länger als bei Chanel und man kann da sehr sehr viel erfahren auch darüber wie exzessiv und das hat mir besonders gut gefallen.
Karl Lagerfeld Bücher konsumiert also Bücher kauft um diese Bücher aufzubauen diese tollen Bibliotheken.
Wir sprechen da von ein bis zwei Dutzend Bücher hat er pro Tag gekauft.
Großartig und heiteres dann im Salon und ein,
paar andere Texte und dann noch ein ganz wichtiger Text wie ich finde aus der Financial Times nochmal zum Thema China dass wir mal kritisch befragen sollen wie wir jetzt China einschätzen.
Ich glaube wir unterschätzen noch sehr viel und das macht dieser text nochmal an drei Punkten deutlich.
Sehr gut. Dann kommt alle in den Salon und dann Ende der Woche im Oktober kurz vor Trumps Abwahl bitte bringt euch in Partystimmung.
Du sagst das man wird uns das irgendwann noch alles vorführen gut bis bald.
Wir diskutieren das haut rein.
Intro/Outro